Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Es ist März. Wir stehen vor dem Salon, um heute den Untergang zu begleiten, so würde ich sagen.
Welchen Untergang denn genau?
Trumps.
Ist dieses Buch das Ergebnis des Untergangs oder ist das Buch das Plädoyer für den Untergang? Ist das Buch eine Gebrauchsanweisung für den Untergang? Oder würdest du sagen, dieses Buch ist geschrieben gegen Donald Trump? Nein.
Alex Karp hat ein Buch geschrieben mit einer Idee, die er gerne verwirklicht sehen möchte, von Donald Trump.
Ja.
Und wir sehen jetzt, dass nicht nur wir finden, dass Donald Trump dumm ist, sondern dass Alex Karp wahrscheinlich auch gerade die Hände über die Köpfe zusammenschlägt. Nicht nur seine, sondern auch Peter Thiels Kopf. Wir lesen sehr viel Peter Thiel Ideologie in diesem Buch. Und man sieht die Idee und man sieht den Ansatz. Aber wie es nun mal so ist, man schickt die Achtjährigen auf die Strecke, sie sollen so schnell laufen wie sie können, sie verlassen ihre Bahn, sie stolpern über ihre eigenen Füße und am Ende kommt niemand ins Ziel. Und dieses Buch dokumentiert es, finde ich, wenn man es klug und inspirativ liest, auf wirklich sehr eindrückliche Art und Weise.
Ja, ich hab's noch mal anders gelesen, also du hast vollkommen recht, nämlich in der Hinsicht, dass ich dachte, ja, die Milliardäre, man hört es immer wieder, wollen Opernhäuser bauen oder Tunnel durch die Alpen bohren oder einfach nur irgendwelche Superjachten besitzen. Und ich denke immer, das ist schlimm, aber es geht auch viel schlimmer, nämlich so, wie Alex Carps sich das ausdenkt. In gewisser Weise ist es das erschreckendste Buch, das wir im Salon je gelesen haben. Also ich bin wirklich schockiert darüber, finde es aber absolut zeitgemäß. Ich glaube, es knüpft einem so viel an, dass ich erstaunt war beim Lesen, aber ich habe mich selten so gegruselt. Auch weil es in einer fast argumentativen Redlichkeit erst einmal so tut, als sei das doch das, was der gesunde Menschenverstand so wollen mag. Und das ist ein wirklich erschreckendes Buch. Von daher bin ich ja froh, es gibt auch, wie ich hier sehe, auch noch andere Bücher zu lesen, die optimistischer sind. Oder naja, der Titel, die Kinderwüste, dein Buch ist jetzt erschienen.
Heute ist Erscheinungstermin. Du kriegst es natürlich vom Autor persönlich über dich.
Danke schön.
Denn die Kiste von Hoffmann & Crump ist auch bei mir jetzt endlich angekommen. Das letzte Buch, das ich hatte, war ja ein Diebstahl von mir von der Signieraktion. Ich hab mir einfach einen oder Umschlag so ein bisschen kaputt war mitgenommen. Jetzt ist es da. Es ist, du hast ja schon betont, am Ende geht es auch um Weltpolitik. Es geht die ganze Zeit um die Verklammerung kleiner und großer Politik. Ich beginne mit Dunja Hayali und sage, man kann nicht im heutischen Teil stehen und sagen, jeder der einen Haushalt führt weiß ja, woran es jetzt mangelt. Nein, diese Verknüpfung gibt es nicht. Und die Verknüpfung sind anders. Ich stelle da, wie die Politik immer auf die Familie zu sprechen kommt, aber nie auf die Familie, sondern immer auf das ideale Bild der Pastorenfamilie, weil man so auch den Staat organisiert. Helf den Nachbarn, achte auf Oma und Opa und so weiter und so fort. Also die Floskeln sind ja alle da, nur es passt immer nie. Und am Ende das große Finale natürlich, was ist mit China und Russland? Dort gibt es auch feministische Politik, feministische akademische Politikberatung und so weiter, weil auch in China 600 Millionen Frauen leben, die sich das nicht einfach, also die nicht einfach nicht mal in China tun, wie ihnen gesagt wird. Und der amerikanische Versuch jetzt den Frauen zu sagen, wo es langgeht, wird natürlich, also wird man halt diskutieren, platzt gerade in der Ansicht, es ist kein Buch über Gedöns. Es gibt genug Bücher über die Gefühlichkeit von Familie und wie erziehe ich meine Kinder und wie bringe ich sie zum Schlafen und was ist, wenn sie Piki-Ita sind, sondern es gibt andere Dimensionen. Und ich habe ja beim letzten Mal schon bemerkt, wie schnell sich Debatten drehen. Ja, im September 2022 kam die Altenrepublik. Damals war der Fachkräftemangel noch ein, das ist ja so eine Industrieideologie und heute wissen wir, nein, wir diskutieren anders darüber. Und wir haben es jetzt gerade diese Woche gesehen, wie Friedrich Merz noch im Fernsehen sitzt und sagt, Verschuldung niemals, Frau Maischberger in dem Fall. Auch in diesem Studio sitzen junge Leute, den können wir jetzt nicht sagen, dass wir deren Geld schon mal ausgeben müssen. Und eine Woche später tut er genau das. Wird das Vorzeichen einmal komplett umgedreht.
Und zwar richtig kräftig.
Wie es sich nicht mal die SPD getraut hat, im Wahlkampf zu sagen.
Ja, es stand nicht so im Wahlprogramm. Also die SPD ging ja in dem Wahlprogramm verglichen mit anderen relativ weit. Aber das ist weit davon entfernt geblieben, was man jetzt gerade macht.
Von daher, der Ansatz meines Buches ist, wenn man es durchgelesen hat, 140 Seiten absolviert, schafft man auf einer Zugfahrt, dass man danach sagt Familie, so geht es nicht weiter. Wir brauchen jetzt ein neues Vorzeichen. Es ist der große Systemstreit. Und alle mitten drinnen.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, freue mich sehr. Der Untertitel, wie die Politik Familien im Stich lässt. Und da steckt natürlich auch die Aufforderung drin, dass die Politik das nicht mehr tun sollte. Aber erstmal sieht es düster aus.
Sehr düster. Ja. Wir haben ein Investitionsprogramm in Brücken, Panzer, ja, immerhin ein bisschen Schule. Wir wissen nicht genau, wie viel dann da hängen bleibt. Und gestern gab es ja eine Meldung, dass ein Bundesland jetzt gesagt hat, als zentrale Anordnung, vier Unterrichtsstunden weniger pro Woche für alle Schüler als Beitrag für die Haushaltslage.
Wahnsinn.
Man kann es sich nicht vorstellen.
Nein, es ist katastrophal. Aber wir bleiben bei den katastrophalen Themen. Du hast wahrscheinlich auch dir Trump und Zelinsky angesehen. Wie wirkte das Ganze auf dich?
Ich schau mir jetzt alles gerne an, wo Trump auf dem letzten Loch pfeift. Wir haben sowas wie im Oval Office noch...
Hattest du den Eindruck, ja?
Ja, also ich habe derzeit konstant nur den Eindruck.
Das finde ich interessant. Ich habe den Eindruck nämlich nicht.
Also ich habe jetzt mehrfach, okay dann schildere ich erstmal meine Beobachtung. Ich habe jetzt mehrfach betont, dass sich Donald Trump bisher noch nicht zum Kongress getraut hat, sondern hat ihm einfach so ein Bill hingelegt, so ein Haushaltsgesetz und das ist One Beautiful Bill, wie es halt so heißt, in dem er alles mit einmal regeln will, weil er weiß, ich kann mich auf Streitereien dort nicht einlassen. Ich kriege nicht mal meinen eigenen Minister durch. Ich brauche JD Vance, der dort einen Thai-Break, obwohl ich eine 3-Stimmen-Mehrheit habe, bricht, damit die Senatoren sagen, der RFK kann doch mal Gesundheitsminister werden. So, Donald Trump ist jetzt zum Kongress gegangen. Es ist sozusagen der größtmögliche Auftritt, den ein amerikanischer Präsident haben kann. Den kann man aber nicht unendlich oft machen. So, wir hatten nicht nur die Oval Office Situation mit Zelensky, sondern wir hatten auch die mit Kirstama, wo Kirstama meinte, ich habe hier ein Brief von His Majesty und so. Er lädt sie ein, das gab es noch nie, es ist der zweite Staatsbesuch für einen amerikanischen Präsidenten. Üblicherweise gibt es nur einen, das ist und so weiter, ja? Ja. Also alles, was wir an Semantik erleben, ist das Maximum. Es lässt sich nicht nochmal toppen und wir sind erst im ersten Monat. Ja. Es muss aber immer weiter getoppt werden, das ist das Programm. Also wo soll das hinführen? Es ist alles ausgereizt. Und die Bedrohungslage ist soweit auch ausgereizt. So. Und das sieht man insbesondere bei Zelensky.
Wenn wir jetzt auf dieses konkrete Treffen kommen, wie hat denn das auf dich gewirkt? Also hast du nur diese 10 Minuten gesehen oder diese 50 Minuten? Weil wenn man sich diese 50 Minuten ansieht, was ich auch erst dann viel später getan habe, dann bekommt man ja doch einen anderen Eindruck. Ich glaube, ich brauche jetzt hier keinen Disclaimer zu machen, dass ich zwar ein Blöd finde und ich das alles sehr verantwortungslos finde etc. Nur gab mir etwas zu denken und zwar Jochen Bittner von der Zeit, also ein Transatlantiker, ein Konservativer, jemand dessen Artikel ich jetzt nicht besonders schätze. Dessen Meinung aber dann ja doch mitunter bei aller Kontraintuition für mich dann interessant ist, war auf Twitter zu lesen. Er schrieb dort oder auf X. Natürlich haben sich Trump und Vans vollkommen würdelos und autoritär gegenüber Zelensky und der Ukraine verhalten. Aber was ist in den ganzen 50 Minuten der Pressekonferenz passiert? Nicht nur in den letzten 10 Minuten. Und dann schreibt er, Zelensky hatte offenbar die Erwartung, dass die USA bei den Verhandlungen auf der Seite der Ukraine stehen, um Putin zu stoppen. Er ging davon aus, dass es keine Kompromisse bei Gebietsfragen geben könne und er wollte starke militärische Sicherheitsgarantien. Trump machte daraufhin noch einmal klar, was er seit langem sagt, dass er auf keiner Seite steht, sondern in der Mitte. Und das bedeutet bei den eigenen nationalen Interessen und so weiter. Diese Position war längst klar, schreibt Bittner. Und Zelensky hat aber nicht darauf entsprechend reagiert. Für ihn stellte das und das sagt Bittner hier auch verständlicherweise als Verrat da. Aber er sagt dann auch, der zweite Fehler von Zelensky war dann, dass er die ganze Politikmethode von Trump in Zweifel gezogen hat, in dem er bestritt, dass man mit Putin Deals machen könne. So und ich hab mir dann daraufhin, also nur aufgrund dieses Tweets habe ich mir dann diese 50 Minuten angesehen und dachte ja da hat der Bittner einen Punkt. Ja klar. Denn es war hochinteressant, wir wissen ja Trump ist unberechenbar, aber wir wissen auch in gewisser Weise wie er tickt und was geht, was nicht geht. Also man kann zum Beispiel Donald Trump nicht unterbrechen. Das ist einfach verboten.
Man muss ihm einen Brief zeigen des Königs, der eine einmalige Einladung ausspricht und alles andere.
Ich sage nicht, dass ich das, also ist verständlich die Reaktion von, also direkt zutiefst menschlich die Reaktion von Zelensky und all das. Nur wenn ich gehe nur strategisch blicke ich darauf und dann denke ich, nee das ist keine gute Strategie. Trump beginnt diese Konferenz damit, dass er sagt, ich habe da, wir machen ein Deal, ich bin ein Deal-Maker, wir brauchen jetzt ein Ende dieses Sterbens etc. Und er hat mit Putin gesprochen und auch mit Präsident Zelensky schon, und dass sie sich da einig werden und sowas. Also er verbreitet gute Stimmung. Daraufhin hat dann Zelensky das Wort und sagt, ja also Putin ist ein Terrorist, Putin ist ein Killer. Kompromisse mit einem Killer, wie geht das? Das kann ich natürlich so sehen und das setzt einen auch moralisch auf die richtige Seite. Nur strategisch gegenüber Trump, der gerade sagt, ich habe jetzt mal mit allen gesprochen und wir leiten da was ein, ist das natürlich maximal blöde. Also das hat ja auch dann dazu geführt. Also und das schaukelte sich immer weiter hoch an sich. Ich würde jedem empfehlen, sich das mal ganz anzusehen. Natürlich ist das eine Situation, die darauf ausgelegt ist, dass es zu so e-class kommen kann. Natürlich ist auch bemerkenswert, dass Trump das Ganze beendet mit, I think we have seen enough, what do you think, fragt er die Journalisten, great television. Und damit beendet er das Ganze. Also der wirkliche Affront liegt ja darin, dass das in der Öffentlichkeit ausgetragen wird. Denn dass Präsidenten so mit anderen Präsidenten sprechen, gerade US-Amerikanische, ist nicht ein Novum, was wir hier erlebt haben. Das Novum ist, dass wir dabei sein konnten. Bojan Panczewski, der ja diese großartigen Recherchen gemacht hat zu den Nord Stream 2 Sprengungen, hat auch zum Beispiel darauf hingewiesen auf Twitter, dass Biden auch 22 mit Zelensky heftig aneinandergerastet ist, nur hinter verschlossenen Türen. Das hat man dann mal so rausgefunden.
Obama mit den Europäern über dieselben Fragen auch.
Immer wieder geschieht es, was nur nicht auf offener Bühne. Das ist eben das Neue. Wir wissen, Trump versteht sich als Fernsehstar. Und weil du sagst, na ja, Trump ist angeschlagen und so weiter. Ich habe den Eindruck, dass Trump doch hier wirklich strategisch für seine Interessen ziemlich weit vorangekommen ist. Er hat dafür gesorgt, dass es diesen Eklat dann am Ende gibt. Also er hat natürlich dann Zelensky nicht gebremst und dann haben sie sich gegenseitig reingesteigt. Dann kam JD Vans noch dazu und hat das dann noch alles beschleunigt. Aber das hat ja dazu geführt, dass Zelensky dann zu Kias-Dama gereist ist, dort die anderen EU-Spitzen traf und von denen eigentlich aufgefordert wurde, diesen Brief an Trump zu schreiben. Jetzt scheint Zelensky wieder bald zu Trump zu reisen. Die Europäer haben entsprechend reagiert, indem sie sagen, wie viel Trillionen brauchen wir für die Aufrüstung, die EU, Deutschland? Alle haben darauf jetzt reagiert, auf das, was da vorgefallen ist. Und zugleich bedeutet das ja nicht das Ende der transatlantischen Partnerschaft, denn März ist ein Transatlantika, die gesamte CDU besteht aus Transatlantikern. Und man kann davon ausgehen, dass ja auch viele dieser Milliarden, die jetzt frei gemacht werden, investiert werden in der Form, dass man amerikanische Waffen kauft, was der amerikanischen Volkswirtschaft wieder dienlich sein wird. Also ich sehe, dass Trump fürchterlich agiert, skrupulous ist und alles Mögliche. Ich sehe aber nicht, dass er irgendwie freiträte oder so, sondern ich sehe, dass er sehr, sehr selbstbewusst seine Interessen oder die der USA verteidigt.
Also meine Lesart ist ein bisschen anders als deine und sehr anders als die, die wir gerade im Journalismus sehen. Beeindruckend ist ja, dass wir im Krieg zwei kleine Länder haben, die die ganze Welt in Schach halten. Also Russland so groß wie Italien, aber spielt sich auf wie und so weiter. Und wir haben jetzt auch immer wieder gehoert.
Volkswirtschaftlich meinst du.
Genau, Volkswirtschaftlich, aber halt Atomwaffen. Und wir haben jetzt auch gehört, wie hart Putin da geblieben ist. Weil ich stelle mir das so und so vor und das sind meine Vorstellungen. Und Trump hat dann es damit allein. Die Ukrainer noch kleiner. Also Volkswirtschaftlich spielt es gar keine Rolle. Militärisch, auch verloren im Posten, sind so krass abhängig von ausländischer Unterstützung, dass man wahrscheinlich in Tagen einfach eine Kapitulation befürchten müsste, wenn da keine Hilfe ist. So und jetzt haben aber beide Länder ganz schön viel rausgeholt für sich jeweils. Also Putin hat es irgendwie geschafft, China auf seine Seite zu ziehen und Nordkoreaner dazu zu bringen, ihre Bevölkerung dahin zu deportieren, damit die da irgendwie als Kanon futtern und so weiter. Und bei der Ukraine ist ja auch sehr beeindruckend, wie weit sie gekommen sind. Der Krieg dauert seit drei Jahren und man sieht null relevante Gebietsbewegungen. So wie gelingt das? Also ich habe im Oval Office da einen sehr hilflosen Donald Trump gesehen, der einfach nicht mehr weiter wusste. Und ich habe einen Zelensky gesehen, der einfach in dieses Meeting reinging, genau wusste, um was es da geht. Er wurde ja auch schon begrüßt mit seinem Wie siehst du denn aus? Was hast du denn da an? Und so weiter und so fort. Und dann hat Zelensky so ein offenes Messer hingestellt. Und dann ist zuerst Trump da reingeflogen und JD Vans ist noch hinterher gesprungen. Zelensky wusste, um was es geht, nämlich diesen Deal. Und ich habe auch schon gesagt, ich bin ein großer Anhänger dieser Stolperdrahttheorie. Also sobald Amerikaner auf ukrainischen Booten sind, sind die sozusagen unantastbar, auch wenn es zivile Leute sind, die dort als Unternehmer irgendwelche Minen ausbeuten und was auch immer. Ja eigentlich hätte ich auch gedacht, warum muss Trump jetzt noch mal Sicherheitsversprechen geben? Ist doch völlig klar, wenn dort Bodenschätze ausgeräumt werden von Amerikanern, dann ist das ein automatisches Sicherheitsversprechen. Da sind jetzt Amerikaner, da haben die Russen nichts zu suchen. Und notfalls macht Trump dann die große Ansage und gibt einen Befehl. So, er ist ja der Oberbefehlshaber. So, also eigentlich hätte es diese Art von Sicherheitsversprechen.
Ja und Trump sagt doch, er sei Präsident und man könne sich darauf verlassen, dass dann nichts passiert. Also er sagt jetzt ja nicht, welche Sicherheitsgarantien. Aber er hat mehrmals in dieser Pressekonferenz gesagt, Sie reden da von anderen Präsidenten. Wenn Putin sich da früher nicht dran gehalten hat, weiß ich nicht, kann sein. Da war ich nicht Präsident.
So und jetzt haben wir eine Lage, in der wir zwar alle über Trump jammern, aber diese Argumentation von Trump hat eine ähnerhänte Logik, die bestechend ist, weil wir davon ausgehen können, dass Trump seinen Antlitz nicht verlieren möchte. Er ist am Ende dieser Strongman. Also wenn da Minen in Gefahr sind, weil Amerikaner da keine Profite machen können, dann steht natürlich das amerikanische Militär bereit, stand es ja immer. Also deswegen, das ist ja die zentrale Funktion. So. Nun hat sich aber Zelensky nicht darauf eingelassen, sondern hat Chaos verursacht, indem er gesagt hat oder gedacht hat, ich weiß wie das hier läuft, also da sitzt jetzt der große Fürst der guten Gesellschaft und möchte alles in Interaktion klären. Der trifft mich also locker am Auto, holt mich ab, dann gehen alle nochmal aufs Klo, keiner spricht mit jemandem vorher, oder trifft man sich halt da und sagt, ja coole Minen habt ihr da, den Vertrag, den ihr da ausgearbeitet, der ist ja ganz cool, können wir denen das unterzeichnen? Dann sagt der eine ne. Dann sagt sie letztlich einfach, nö mach ich nicht, reicht mir nicht, ich will mehr. So. Und dann lief ein Countdown und es war völlig klar, das Ding eskaliert und Trump schickt ja auch keine Leute raus, bevor er nicht sein Deal bekommen hat, also standen die Journalisten alle ewig da. So und dann ging so eine Demütigungswelle los, als ob Zelensky nach drei Jahren Krieg das beeindruckt, auf seine Klamotte angesprochen zu werden.
Das war natürlich wieder dieser typische Irrsinn.
Das Ding ist am Ende klar geendet, es gab diesen Deal nicht und Trump stand ohne Deal da. Er konnte natürlich dann den großen Zampano machen und so weiter, aber wir haben doch gesehen, was das für politische Schockwellen in Europa hervorgehoben hat.
Aber dann hat doch Trump immer gesagt, die Europäer sollen sich darum kümmern und jetzt kümmern sich die Europäer dazu. Er hat doch genau das erreicht, hat gesagt, seht ihr, ihr könnt euch nicht auf mich verlassen.
Mobilisiert eure Milliarden.
Das ist doch eine klare Strategie von Trump.
Lass mich einen Bogen schlagen. Also wir haben jetzt dieses Buch von Alex Karp, der hat ja politische Ideen. Und jedes Mal wenn er Amerika nennt, heißt es direkt im nächsten Halbsatz und seine europäischen Alliierten. So, die kann man also, wenn man so eine Idee hat, wie wir sie gleich diskutieren, nicht aufs Spiel setzen. So, jetzt haben wir aber Europäer, die sagen, ne, Herr Trump, du hast doch immer gesagt, wir sollen uns um unsere eigene Sicherheit kümmern. Und wenn jetzt der französische Präsident kommt und sagt, ja, dann machen wir ein Konjunkturprogramm draus und unterstützen hier unsere Waffentechnologien. Und dann sagen die Deutschen, ja, wir haben auch Waffenthechnologien, wir sind die drittbesten Verbreiterexporteure der Welt, wir können das auch für uns selber bauen, wir brauchen nur das Budget. Und es liegt ein Vorschlag auf dem Tisch, den selbst Friedrich Merz als großer Gegner von Staatsverschuldung, er kriegt plötzlich 400 Milliarden dafür rausgeleiert. So, das ist nicht im Sinne Amerikas. Und das ist eine Leistung, die Zelensky in einer Interaktion hergestellt hat, in der er einfach nur gesagt hat, ich weiß, wie eine Interaktion läuft.
Aber machen wir uns doch nichts vor.
Hier sind die Eigenrechte der Interaktion, also das ist ja Lumensediktum, hier ist die Welt ausgeblendet.
Aber machen wir uns ja nichts vor. Das eine ist ja, dass die USA schon lange wollen, dass Europa mehr aufrüstet und mehr beiträgt.
Ja, aber doch als Alliierte in Amerika kaufen.
Aber das werden sie jetzt auch tun.
Nein, das werden sie nicht tun.
Sie werden in Amerika kaufen.
Nein, werden sie nicht. Also das werden wir sehen, das wird die Entwicklung sein.
Friedrich Merz muss ja noch hinreisen.
Aber die Gespräche in Europa laufen nicht darauf hinaus, dass man die Gelder, die man jetzt mobilisiert, nach Amerika überweist, um sich amerikanische Wehrtechnik zu kaufen.
Nicht alles, aber zum Teil wird es wahrscheinlich so sein. Ja, kennen wir ja, Brückentechnologie und so. Oder es kann sich Amerika auf den schlanken Fuß damit machen, indem Europa da selbst dann mehr macht.
Der Typ ist abgefahren. Diese Niederlage muss Trump jetzt einstecken.
Ich würde es noch nicht als Niederlage begreifen. Also zum Beispiel Bojan Panczewski schreibt, es geht Trump, er sagt dann aber auch, kann nach einem Telefonat sich natürlich alles wieder ändern, um die globale Einigung mit Russland, dauerhafte Deeskalation, Rückkehr zum Handel, Entschärfung der Spannung mit Moskau, um sich auf China zu konzentrieren. Russland und China so weit wie möglich voneinander trennen. Im Grunde war vieles davon die Politik von Clinton, Bush, Obama, Biden. Das hat aber nicht glänzend bisher funktioniert. Zweitens, Beendigung des Krieges in der Ukraine zu vernünftigen Bedingungen. Die Ukraine ist ein Ärgernis für die US-Regierung und sie will, dass das Problem gelöst wird. Kiev kann damit arbeiten. Mehrere Beamte der Biden-Administration haben zu Protokoll gegeben, dass eine Entmalitarisierung und die Umwandlung der Ukraine in einen russischen Vasallenstaat nicht einmal diskutiert geschweige denn akzeptiert werden wird.
Aha.
Trump wird es schwer haben, eins und zwei zu bekommen. Dafür gibt es strukturelle Gründe. Also muss er einen anständigen Deal hinbekommen. Welche Animositäten und Spannungen es auch immer geben mag, die USA werden die Ukraine auf keinen Fall im Stich lassen. Auch interessant. Es gibt eine Politik und Bemühungen, den Krieg zu beenden. Die Regierung Biden steckte ohne Plan in einer Schleife fest. Denn auch das ist ja einfach wahr. Biden hat nichts angeboten außer Waffen, die den Krieg zwar noch weiter durchführbar machen, aber den auch nicht gewinnen lassen oder sonst was.
Warum ist da hinten Köchel auszuholen?
Es gibt deshalb, sagt William Franchewski, Gründe für harten realpolitischen Optimismus. Also so schätzt er das ein und das ist jetzt nun auch kein Trump-Freund. Was doch klar ist, ist, dass die EU jetzt aufrüstet und Deutschland aufrüstet und all das, um sich stärker einbringen zu können. Aber was ja auch klar sein müsste und manchen Transatlantikern ist es inzwischen auch klar, man wird sich ja nicht mit der EU in einen Zweifrontenkrieg begeben. Man wird ja nicht während Trump beispielsweise jetzt mit Putin verhandelt und mit Zelenski wieder ins Gespräch kommt, den Krieg weiter intensivieren durch Wasmen-Lieferungen. Dass dann irgendein Journalist wie Felix Dachsel oder wie sie alle heißen, schreiben bei Twitter Taurus jetzt ist ja vollkommen irrsinnig. Damit würde man ja quasi Krieg gegen Russland und auch noch gegen die Interessen der USA führen. Das wird ja nicht der Fall sein. Also wird dieser Krieg in der Ukraine beendet durch eine US-amerikanische Politik, bei der man hoffen kann, dass gewisse europäische Interessen da auch noch vertreten werden, das kommt dann darauf an, wie gut man verhandeln kann und wie klug sich zum Beispiel Friedrich Merz anstellt. Aber es ist ja keineswegs so, dass das jetzt hier für Trump eine verlorene Sache ist. Und all das, was wir jetzt da gesehen haben, ist zwar an den Bildern und der Stimmung und so einmalig, sowas hat so noch nicht gegeben bei einer Pressekonferenz von Regierungschefs. Aber inhaltlich kann das ja niemanden überraschen, denn das ist ja genau das, was Trump seit Monaten schon weit vor seiner Wahl angekündigt hat. Dass dann jetzt Leute wie zum Beispiel der neue Grünen-Chef Jakob Lase bei Twitter schreiben, wer in dieser Weltlage noch immer zögert Europas Freiheit auch mit Waffen zu verteidigen, ist nicht links, sondern naiv und unsolidarisch. Da frage ich mich dann schon, naja, die Weltlage ist nämlich erst seit vergangenen Freitag so, wie sie ist. Und trotzdem ist ja da die einzig berechtigte Frage, die die Alexander Jorde gestellt hat. Du erinnerst dich der Pfleger, der damals gegen Merkel und Spahn gewettert hat. Er fragte nämlich dann bei Twitter, wann startet deine Grundausbildung Jakob Lase? Woraufhin er unglaublich viel Kritik bekam und böse beschimpft wurde, wo ich einfach sagen würde, nein, das ist genau die richtige Frage, die zu stellen ist. Denn wenn hier es ja heißt, wer noch zögert, also offenbar zögert ja Jakob Lase noch, der sei unsolidarisch, dann muss man sich ja diese Frage gefallen lassen. Zudem ja jemand wie Alexander Jorde seine Grundausbildung gemacht hat. Und im Übrigen bei der Marine, die haben ja die schönsten Uniformen, wie ich finde, kann also so jemand auf jeden Fall eine solche Frage stellen. Das ist aber jetzt gerade das politische Klima, in dem wir uns befinden und wo man nicht sehen will, dass man nur jetzt mit Trump irgendwie es schaffen muss, dass es nicht ganz so arg ausgeht für die Ukrainer und die Europäer. Aber man wird jetzt nicht mit europäischer Unterstützung Putin besiegen, während Trump irgendwas anderes macht.
Wir müssen hier also in dem Fall wirklich ganz detailliert vorgehen. Die Ukraine, also nicht die Ukraine, aber die Gebiete, die gerade von Russland besetzt sind und die auch in der russischen Verfassung als russische Gebiete schon aufgenommen sind, die werden entweder an Putin verloren gehen, dann beutet Putin das da aus oder an die Amerikaner. Dann gibt es diese etwas wageren, aber die werden jetzt wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen nachgerüstet, auch semantisch Gebiete, also wird es dann Sicherheitsvorkehrungen geben, allein weil der Amerikaner sind. Und sei es, dass man diese Minen, die von Amerikanern ausgebeutet werden und was auch immer, dann durch Waffengewalt nochmal und da reicht es ja völlig.
Es war ja auch immer in der sogenannten dritten Welt so, wenn die Amerikaner dort zu Gange waren.
Die Modelle sind ja sowieso schon seit ewig, also seit längerem jetzt seit dem Irakkrieg, dass da private Sicherheitsfirmen mit semistaatlichem Auftrag von privaten Firmen angeheuert werden, die dann irgendwelche Steuersubventionen, was auch immer, damit das nicht deren Kosten sind. Also die Ukraine, was das angeht, ist verloren für Europa. Entweder an Trump oder an Putin. Und ich sage jetzt Trump und Putin und nicht Russland und Amerika, weil ich es so meine. Davon unterschieden ist aber die Sicherheitsdiskussion Europas. Wenn wir eine Befriedung haben, die darauf hinausläuft, dass Putin oder Trump da irgendwelche Ausbeutungsgeschäfte zulässt, so dann stellt sich für die Europäer die Sicherheitsfrage neu, weil entweder ist der große Treiber, Putin führt jetzt keinen Krieg mehr, also rüstet er geradeaus, bereitet sich vor, also müssen wir uns auch vorbereiten oder wir können nie wieder den Amerikanern vertrauen, weil nicht nur jetzt unter Trump ist offensichtlich was passiert, sondern die Stimmung war auch unter Obama und unter Biden so. Sie bricht jetzt nur durch Trump aus, aber wir haben eine langfristige Entkopplung von Amerika. So. Und ich bin sehr davon überzeugt, dass wir zum einen einen neuen europäischen Aufrüstungsdiskurs dahingehen kriegen, dass Deutschland jetzt 400 Milliarden mobilisiert, Frankreich nochmal 200 Milliarden, die Briten da wieder groß eingebunden werden, dass Dahmer und seine Nachfolger dann auch wieder an EU-Gipfel teilnehmen, weil da auch demnächst über Wer und so weiter diskutiert wird. So, das ist aber noch mal eine eigene Diskussion. Also da rede ich über KI, Maschinen, Wertechnik und so weiter. Die Wer-Pflichts-Diskussion.
Die machen wir jetzt gleich.
Da bin ich mal sehr gespannt in Deutschland. Die machen wir gleich. Ich bleibe dabei.
Lass mich nur da anknüpfen.
Demografisch gesehen ist die Diskussion erledigt.
Stefan, ich wünsche mir nichts mehr, als dass du recht hast. Marc Schiritz, den ich eigentlich als Transatlantiker im Kopf hatte, schrieb im Zuge dessen, was im Weißen Haus geschah, etwas sehr interessantes auf Twitter. Er sagte, ein globales Bündnis gegen die USA ist die letzte Chance des Westens. China muss Teil dieses Bündnisses sein. Und das finde ich erstmal verrückt und dann fand ich es aber interessant. Und dann fand ich es sogar vielleicht sehr klug. Denn es ist ja so, wir haben jetzt diese NATO und all das, und das wird jetzt auch erstmal noch so bleiben. Also ich glaube, es ist auch jetzt nicht viel geworden, wenn man jetzt einfach sagt, wir gehen da raus und so weiter. Die Sache ist nur folgende, wenn es wirklich so ist, dass die USA, und das gibt es ja durchaus auch von demokratischer Seite, diese Idee haben, Adam Tewes hat ja davor häufig gewarnt, China sogar in eine schießende Auseinandersetzung, sprich in einen Krieg zu verwickeln, weil man nicht haben will, dass da eine andere Welt macht, genauso stark ist oder stärker. Dann Gnade uns Gott, da sind wir wirklich verloren. Insofern zu überlegen, ob China, gerade weil da umweltpolitisch so viel passiert, nicht doch ein Partner sein könnte, nicht mit dem wir alle Werte teilen, aber mit wem teilen wir im Westen schon auch alle Werte, wenn wir an unsere Postfaschisten und so weiter denken, dann ist vielleicht diese Idee, die Shiritz hier artikuliert, gar nicht blöde, auch wenn sie sehr utopisch erscheint, zumindest würde sie einmal uns Europäer dazu bringen, aus dieser Block-Konfrontation, die da von Amerika so sehr forciert wird, hinauszutreten und zu denken, wie können wir eigentlich wieder uns assoziieren mit anderen, denn es kann ja nicht hinauslaufen auf eine Welt, in der wir nur noch Blöcke haben und wählen können, mit wem wir gerade Krieg führen wollen, Trump, Putin oder Xi. Diese Kriege werden wir jedenfalls alle verlieren.
Als Soziologe ist mir nicht fremd, dass eine Beschreibung von Realität, wie sie in der Zeitung steht, eigentlich nur aktualisiert, wie es längst ist. Und das ist in dem Fall so. Als es hieß, es gibt jetzt irgendwie Zölle und die 800 Dollar Grenze für Importe greift nicht mehr. Das heißt, die ganzen Mädels können ihre Schiensachen nicht mehr bestellen. US Postal Service liefert keine Pakete mehr aus. Was bedeutet, pro Jahr sind es 1,5 Milliarden Pakete, die aus China auf diesem Wege nach Amerika geliefert werden. Die liegen jetzt beim Zoll rum und müssen wieder zurückgeschickt werden. So 1,5 Milliarden, wir hören das so und denken, wow, das ist aber viel. Aus China werden 4,5 Milliarden solcher Pakete nach Europa geliefert. So wir haben Eisenbahnstrecken, wo kilometerlange Züge bis nach Duisburg durchfahren. Ja. So wir haben einen Gesprächszusammenhang, der für die Tagesschau immer noch läuft, wie sich Richard David Brecht, der darüber lustig macht, dass auch die Menschenrechte angesprochen wurden und dann wurde da irgendwer besucht, wobei dieser Besuch schon gar nicht mehr stattfindet, jetzt werden nur noch die Menschenrechte angesprochen. Also dieser Blog aus China und Europa, der ist längst gegeben, wirtschaftlich auf jeden Fall. Die Dinge, also dieser Wirtschaftsraum ist so eng beieinander, so abhängig voneinander. 90 Prozent unserer Weihnachtsgeschenke, unseren Weihnachtsbaum und damit die Lebensfreude in der dunklen Jahreszeit hängt davon ab, ob es in China ordentlich läuft. So und wir sind eben auch in einer Schicksalsgemeinschaft.
Aber weiß Ursula von der Leyen das auch?
Ursula von der Leyen weiß das sehr.
Aber dann hätte sie nicht diese Zölle unbedingt. Ursula von der Leyen hat ja diesen beiden Anti-China-Kurs mitgetragen.
Soll ich dir sagen, wie diese Zölle gemacht werden?
Ich glaube, pass auf, also Biden hat ja diesen Anti-China-Kurs von Trump übernommen. Und Ursula von der Leyen sagte wunderbar, dann machen wir mit. Und das war ja auch etwas, was Adam Tours kritisiert hat, was aber auch unterstützt wurde von der Bundesregierung, zumindest vom grünen Teil der Bundesregierung und zum Teil auch von der FDP. Und da ist ja doch interessant, dass man jetzt plötzlich nicht mehr den Partner in Crime in den USA sieht und man tatsächlich dazu übergehen könnte, wie Schiritz das ausformuliert und wie du das jetzt gerade noch mal ganz plastisch gemacht hast mit den Geschenken, dass man doch sieht, dass man eigentlich mehr aneinander hat. Und das ist, um das hier nicht irgendwie zu relativieren. Natürlich ist jetzt China nicht das präferierte Modell für uns, dass wir sagen, so müssen wir auch werden. Nur wir können gleich mal gucken, wie USA auch sein könnte unter Alexander Kaab. Und dann fragen wir uns, wo ist der Unterschied, beziehungsweise ist uns vielleicht sogar doch China lieber?
Ich will mal, ich mach jetzt einen Brückenschlag, der ist, also ich mach eine Vermutung. Aber auf der einen Seite weiß ich genau wovon ich rede, auf der anderen Seite halt nicht. Ich weiß nicht, wie die EU-Kommission gerade mit der chinesischen kommunistischen Partei kommuniziert. Niemand weiß das. Aber ich weiß, wie die SPD und der DGB immer miteinander kommuniziert haben, wenn es hieß, die SPD muss ja mal einen Vorschlag machen zum Koalitionsfrieden, dass die Arbeitnehmerrechte und so weiter. Dann schreibt man erst mal, kündigt man sich an, sagt, wir brauchen mal einen Termin. So, dann sitzt der SPD-Vorsitzende und der DGB-Chef da und überlegen, okay, dann machen wir das so. Du sagst morgens im Deutschlandfunk das und dann reagier ich neun Uhr mit einer Pressemitteilung so und dann gehst du in die Fraktion und sagst das und dann 16 Uhr bereite ich mich noch mal drauf vor, an den Tagesthemen dann das zu sagen so. Und dann wird es einfach durchgespielt. So und meine Vermutung ist, wenn die EU-Kommission und die Chinesen jetzt irgendwelche Zollsachen austarieren müssen, weil es ein Zeitgeist gibt und man mit Trump und so weiter, dann wird das genauso gemacht irgendwie. Das ist, ich sehe jetzt nirgendwo, das ist ja auch, guck mal, Trump kam ins Amt und hat gesagt, ne, hier diese Zolldinger und so weiter, jetzt gibt es alles nicht mehr. Diese Pakete lagen auf den Schiffen und wurden in Amerika einfach nicht so. In Deutschland, in Europa ist es ja so, die EU-Kommission kündigt an, sich jetzt mal das Geschäftsgebaren von Schiien anzuschauen. Und dann geht so Zeit ins Land und dann kommt die nächste Pressekonferenz. So, wir starten jetzt mal Ermittlungen. Wir wissen nicht genau, wann die abgeschlossen sind.
Und was ja zum Teil auch richtig ist, das zu machen. Also es geht natürlich auch darum, dass da faire Bedingungen sind und dass zum Teil das da mit Schien nicht alles so glatt läuft. Das ist ja auch völlig klar, dass da nachgeguckt wird. Nur, dass man diese Konfrontation nicht weiter beschleunigt. Interessant ist ja auch, wir haben jetzt gerade so einen Börsendown. Dadurch, dass Trump Zölle verkündet.
Alle seinen Gewinnen seit Amtsantritt sind verloren gegangen dadurch.
Also das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Und wenn man es dann mal vergleicht und die Leute in der Finanzbranche, die vielleicht auch da auf Trump gesetzt haben, tun das ja. Die haben das ja im Blick. Man siehe sich den MSCI World an oder den S&P 500. Also S&P 500 beinhaltet die 500 wichtigsten amerikanischen Konzerne. MSCI World hat einen ganz starken Schwerpunkt USA. Alles runtergesackt durch diese Zollpolitik von Trump. Man sieht sich mal eine China ETF an und wird sehen, oh der ist aber ganz schön im Plus. Was ist denn da los? Und zwar seit Wochen, Monaten und das ist das Interessante.
Trump hat jetzt 1,5 Trillionen, also das was nach der Billionen kommt, an Wert vernichtet.
Ja.
Das waren zwar natürlich nur Buchwerte und so, aber die spielen natürlich trotzdem eine Rolle. Einfach weg.
Und das kann man nicht mit ein paar Steuererleichterungen wieder ausgleichen.
Das was Trump da gerade macht ist dumm und ich finde, man sieht jetzt in allen oder in vielen Belagen, dass es ausgereizt ist. Man kann immer nur so und so weit drohen, also drohen kann man immer. Man kann die Drohnen aktualisieren, dann kann man nochmal drohen, die Drohnen wieder deutlich machen und so weiter. Aber wenn man sie einmal umsetzt, dann geht es an die Substanz. So und Trump muss die ganze Zeit umsetzen. Der droht dem Kongress nichts an, sondern der muss die wirklich alle einbrauben und verschießt das Pulver für eine in Anführungszeit, in welchem State of the Union. Das kann er nicht jede Woche machen. Das war es jetzt erstmal. Das war jetzt die große Ansprache. Die nächsten drei Monate ist dann nichts möglich. So, das Pulver ist verschossen. 25 Prozent Zölle gegen Kanada. Das Pulver ist verschossen. Hier ist nichts mehr zu drohen. Hier muss jetzt austariert werden. Die Leute haben die Hände voll, damit jetzt diese Zettel da auszufüllen. Wenn Trump jetzt nochmal sagt 35 Prozent, dann denken die alle nur, was für ein Scheißer. So, also überall ist das Pulver verschossen. So und der große Vorteil von Trump, das können wir ja nochmal als Teaser für das Buch sagen, der große Vorteil von Trump ist, dass er dumm ist. Also als Sammelbecken für viele Strömungen gut funktioniert, von denen jeder glaubt, ich setz mich durch. Ich bin Elon Musk, ich brauch kluge, kreative Ausländer, ich setz mich durch. Gleichzeitig haben aber die ganzen Neonazis hinter sich, die sagen, gar keine Ausländer. Auch nicht die super klugen. Wir brauchen ein Ereignisbildungssystem. Du nennst JD Vans mit irgendeiner Peter Thiel Idee und so weiter. Also es sind ganz viele Ideen, die sich da kumulieren. Und eine von diesen Ideen kriegen wir ja in diesem Buch ganz detailliert vorgestellt. Und wir denken die ganze Zeit, wenn das die einzige Idee wäre, die Trump gerade durchsetzt, Hut ab. Aber er setzt vier solcher Ideen vor, die sich gegenseitig im Wege stehen.
Und dann müssten wir wirklich Angst haben. Also ein Präsident hat Vorteile.
So, aber dieses Projekt, was wir da detaillieren, geht nicht ohne internationale Allianz.
Jaja, aber es ist, wir ängstigen glaube ich in noch mehrfacher Weise.
Na ja, planen wir wieder in die Schublade? Für den nächsten Versuch. Ja, bzw.
glaube ich, dass schon etwas hier ausgesprochen wird, was als Stimmung wirklich im Raum ist und was man auch so in Deutschland finden kann. Und damit meine ich jetzt nicht bei irgendwelchen rechten Tech-Analysten oder so, sondern ich glaube, es ist etwas in der Luft und das ist beängstigend und das wird hier in diesem Buch aufgegriffen.
Wir können eine wirklich gefährliche Teaserfrage stellen. Dieses Projekt, du hast ja immer das gedruckte Buch hier, ich guck mal, das sind ja beeindruckende, also auch beeindruckendes Literaturverzeichnis, wirklich sehr ausführlich.
Ja, 200 Seiten.
Aber wir haben hier sehr viel Text, so 200 Seitentext. Was ich mich beim Lesen gefragt hab, warum verschwenden sie dieses gute, in sich schlüssige Projekt, das sie da haben, also für sich gut, für mich nicht. Warum verschwenden sie es mit einer republikanischen Präsidentschaft? Warum binden sie es nicht einem Demokraten ans Bein? Also die Gefahr besteht auch, dass man in Amerika einen Diskurs auslöst, in dem es heißt, die Idee war so gut, leider hat der erste Versuch nicht funktioniert durch Blödheit Trumps, aber sollten wir es nicht mit den Demokraten machen. Und wir wissen, die Shifts sind möglich. Mark Zuckerberg, Elon Musk, das waren alles mal quasi Demokraten, die die Vogue-Agenda und so weiter durchgesetzt haben. Die haben jetzt den Shift gemacht zu Trump. Die bleiben auch nach Trump und Palantir bleibt ja auch.
Ich glaube, es gibt genügend grüne Parteien, damit meine ich jetzt nicht nur unsere Grünen, die dieses Programm dankbar aufgreifen würden. Und das ist auch das Beängstigen daran. Also es ist eben nicht jetzt so ein verrückter Tech-Analyst und ein paar verrückte Reiche wollen irgendwas machen. Ich glaube, es geht noch tiefer. Ich war im schönen Österreich in Wien, bin dort aufgetreten mit Jean-Philippe Kindler und Ole und hatte auch noch das Vergnügen durch das Labor eines Physik-Nobelpreisträgers geführt zu werden. Ich habe also mit einem Quantenphysiker gesprochen und es war so, dass das einen doch sehr demütig macht vor dem, was die Wissenschaft so leisten kann, von dem wie die Welt ist bzw. was sie im Innersten zusammenhält und dass man es doch am Ende vielleicht gar nicht so genau sagen kann, dass wir doch irgendwo wieder einen Schritt in die Metaposik gehen. Ja, es ist also völlig logisch, dass man diesen Schritt nimmt. Nun bin ich ja schon religiös, deswegen muss ich es nicht erst noch werden. Aber es war wirklich hochinteressant zu sehen und für mich ein ganz besonderes Erlebnis. Aber natürlich ist Österreich auch noch was anderes. Da gab es den Opernball ein paar Tage vorher. In der Fernsehübertragung sehen wir hier Miriam Weichse-Braun, die jetzt in so einer Loge in der Staatsoper den Außenminister Alexander Schallenberg interviewt. Und du bist ja ein Verfechter, könnte man sagen, der nuklearen Aufrüstung in Europa oder in Deutschland. Die Österreicher haben es natürlich wieder ganz anders für sich gelöst. Das ist Österreich und dafür habe ich jetzt sechs Jahre im Ausland gearbeitet. Das ist unser Softpower. Es gibt die Hardpower und wir haben vielleicht keine Atomwaffen, wir haben Wolfgang-Madeus Mozart. Die Österreicher machen es einfach mit Mozart. Ist das nicht toll?
Ja, finde ich gut. Falls man sich fragt, ich habe ich so lange Povie studiert, was ist noch meines Softpower? Mozart.
Mozart. Ganz, ganz einfach und es wirkt und tatsächlich überall wird Mozart gespielt und gehört. Nochmal ganz kurz zu dieser Wehrpflicht. Es gab einen Kulturzeitbeitrag, in dem kamen auch Ohle vor, das spielen wir jetzt nicht, aber es gab dort auch eine Frau Professorin Grohe von der Bundeswehruniversität, die mit folgendem Statement in dem Beitrag vorkommt.
Denn im Ernstfall ist die Wehrpflicht kein Gebot, sondern eine Pflicht.
Der Staat muss wehrfähig sein, um sich zu wehren. Diese Wehrfähigkeit stellt er her, indem er seine Bürger heranzieht. Sowas funktioniert nicht auf rein freiwilliger Basis. Das heißt, da muss ein Zwang her. Wir Bürgerinnen und Bürger verteidigen unsere freiheitlich-demokratische Gesellschaft gegen Angriffe und Zerstörung von außen. Und das ist eine gesamtgesellschaftliche Pflicht. Und die darf dann auch von 60-Jährigen verlangt werden, von 18-Jährigen.
Ja.
Und da sagst du einfach, ja, so ist es halt.
Zum Glück bin ich alt. Also Amerika, die ja die Welt dominieren, der Hegemon sind, 900 Milliarden, Verteidigungsbudget durchballern, die lösen das auch in einer Werbpflicht. Hab ich irgendwie nicht so ganz mitbekommen, wo die Logik ist.
Ich finde es so interessant, dass sie sagt, es braucht den Zwang und redet dann im nächsten Satz von der Freiheit. Also das ist ja auch das Interessante, dass die ganze Zeit die Leute, die so viel von Freiheit reden, laufen und die schon eine Einschränkung darin sehen, wenn eine Steuer erhoben wird oder so, sagen jetzt wird aber meine Freiheit beschnitten, die dann zugleich sagen, naja also bei Militär, also da muss schon ein gewisser Zwang her, da muss schon Ordnung und Disziplin sein. Es ist verrückt. Ich finde auch interessant, dass es nicht eine große Rebellion gibt bislang, obwohl diese Pläne auf dem Tisch liegen für eine Wiedereinführung der Wehrpflicht seitens der Eltern. Also ich kriege es nicht so ganz zusammen. Wir haben doch dieses Phänomen Helikoptereltern. Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen größer als man denkt, aber es ist ja in der Tat so, dass mir zum Beispiel Lehrer erzählen, sie geben im Aufsatz eine 4, sofort stehen die Eltern auf der Matte, sagen wir können auch noch den Rechtsanwalt mitbringen. Früher hat man auch mal Kinder, wenn sie sich nicht benommen haben, im Unterricht vor die Tür gesetzt, dann kommt gleich psychische Schäden, traumatisiert etc. Also wir haben diese hypersensibilisierten Eltern, die aber offenbar überhaupt nicht hypersensibilisiert sind, wenn es um die Wehrpflicht geht.
Ich verstehe nicht warum. Was ist so schwer daran zu beobachten? Die Eltern gehen auf die Matte, wenn das eigene Kind eine Vier hat. Ja. Die machen aber keine Demonstrationen vor dem Rathaus gegen Vieren allgemein. Wenn der Brief im Briefkasten landet, dann ist die Diskussion klar.
Glaubst du?
Diese Eltern haben die Hände voll. Ich erlebe es doch an mir selber.
Aber du glaubst wirklich, dass dann, wenn die Wehrpflicht da ist, dass das dann Ärger gibt?
Also wenn ich eine Überzeugung habe, dann, dass es nicht möglich ist in Deutschland jemanden einen Brief nach Hause zu schicken, in dem drin steht, dein 18-jähriger Sohn, den du so und so viel zum Musikunterricht, zur Schule, zum, was weiß ich, Sport gefahren hast, den brauchen wir morgen in der Kaserne. Vor allem nicht, wenn du den dann da hinbringst, ja, und dann da siehst, das ist die Kaserne, dann ist Krieg in Deutschland.
Stefan, mögest du Recht haben?
Bevor wir Deutschland mit einer Wehrpflicht im äußeren verteidigen, ist hier Bürgerkrieg. Das ist wirklich eine ganz feste Überzeugung. Ich habe mich sehr viel mit Familie und Gemütszuständen und demografischen Grundlagen und Mangellagen befasst.
Im Zuge unserer Folge hat mir eine Hörerin auch einen Hinweis gegeben im Presseclub. Vom vergangenen Sonntag war unter anderem der Journalist Mark Brost zu Gast, der äußert sich zur Aufrüstung und diesen Sondervermögen wie folgt.
Was ganz schwierig ist, und das haben wir eben gesehen seit dem 24. Februar 2022, ist, den Menschen zu erklären, warum wir das tun, warum wir die Ukraine verteidigen, wer uns eigentlich angreift. Und da sind wir wieder bei einem Punkt der putinischen Kriegsführung, warum er, da bin ich ja ganz bei Ina Ruck, im Augenblick im Kreml sich das anschauen kann wie eine Kinoshow. Die Destabilisierung westlicher Demokratien, die innere Zersetzung des Diskurses ist auch ein Teil der russischen hybriden Kriegsführung. Das heißt, diese Veränderung, die wir jetzt erleben, trifft auf ein aufgerautes Land, das nicht nur wegen drei Jahre Ampel gerade mental ein bisschen am Boden ist, sondern man muss wahnsinnig viel erklären, machen und tun. Wir müssen unter Umständen über eine Wehrpflicht reden. Wir müssen darüber reden, ob unsere Kinder wieder tatsächlich dieses Land verteidigen müssen. Das sind alles ganz schwierige Debatten. Mein Sohn ist 17 Jahre, ich möchte auch nicht, dass er in den Krieg ziehen muss. Aber das sind alles Dinge, die wirklich jetzt Führung erfordern und eine große mentale Veränderung. Der Rest ist ehrlich gesagt politische Routine.
Da ist wieder das Wort Führung und da wird jetzt schon der Journalismus darauf eingeschworen, eine Stimmung herzustellen, bei der dann irgendwann alle einwilligen und sagen, ja es muss aber auch leider sein, mein 17-Jähriger muss auch los.
Journalisten haben in diesem Land nichts mehr zu sagen. Niemand guckt den Presseclub, außer 75-jährige Omis. Wirklich, hier muss man jetzt, wann kriegen denn...
Aber bei Twitter sind es doch auch die Jungen, hier Jakob Lase und diese jungen Grünen, die sind doch genauso verrückt. Du glaubst doch, wenn du den jungen Grünen jetzt vorlegen solltest, Wehrpflicht einführen, dann würden die doch höchstens noch fragen, ja aber ist das auch gleichberechtigt, damit auch Nonbinäre bei Militär dienen würden? Das wäre doch die einzige Frage, die die noch stellen, um dann einzuwilligen.
Also die letzten jungen Grünen haben als kollektive Entscheidung gesagt, nicht nur diese Partei nicht, sondern dieses System nicht, dass danach eine junge grüne Generation nachgrücken gelassen wird, die natürlich wieder auf den, komm wir machen euch wieder versprechen, ihr seid die Neuen, ihr könnt hier aufsteigen, dass die nachplappern, was sie irgendwo lesen, ja. Aber sorry.
Also Stefan.
Völlig ausgeschlossen. Ich sage es heute und ich habe schon Stefan, ich hoffe. ein paar harte Sachen gesagt. Ja. Und die waren auch richtig am Ende.
Stefan, ich wünsche mir nichts mehr.
Niemand konnte sich vorstellen, dass März 500 Milliarden Sondervermögen so, außer wir. Wir haben das schon vor Jahren gesagt. Und jetzt ist jetzt das Moment da und ich sage, werpflicht kann man diskutieren, so viel man will. Den ersten Brief in den Briefkasten reinstecken, lesen lassen und dann mal gucken, was passiert.
Du bist ja auch bei Threads, da bin ich nicht. Nee, da bin ich nicht.
Ich schicke da nur automatisiert meine stephanschutz.com Blogartikel.
Aber du hast mir irgendwas von Threads geschickt. Das konntest du vielleicht mal vortragen. Das hat mich wahnsinnig gefreut, dass du mich da mit konfrontiert hast.
Ich gehe in meine Meta-Messages um.
Also über Instagram hast du mir einen Screenshot geschickt.
Den trag ich gerne vor, ich weiß grob, worum es geht. Also. Paul Ronzheimer schreibt, das Interesse an der außenpolitischen Lage nach dem Silensky-Trump-Eckla und der Anknüpfung des Waffens-Stops ist riesig. Auch bei Podcasts. Piatow und ich haben gestern Nacht aktuell produziert, aus Kiew natürlich, dazu in den vergangenen Tagen Folgen mit und so weiter. Wir wissen ja, Ronzheimer macht ja immer am 13. Tag des Monats den 11. Podcast. Und das ist jetzt keine ausgedachte Zahl. Daraufhin nimmt, warte mal, Micky Beisenherz? Nee, das ist Jan, ich bin hier im falschen. Ach hier. Oh, oh, oh, wir gehen ans Eingemachte. Ich lese vor. Friedemann Karich schreibt, es war eine Falle, um den Verrat der USA an Ukraine und NATO und die Allianz mit Putin zu legitimieren. Es ist aber auch die größte Chance für Europa, sich jetzt zu einem echten Gegengewicht zu vereinen. Und so wird Friedrich Merz noch vor Amtsantritt der vielleicht wichtigste Politiker der freien Welt. Ich hab dir das aus Gründen geschickt.
Ja, weil ich mich natürlich wahnsinnig darüber freue.
Es war Karneval.
Es war Karneval, ja. Und das ist Karneval.
Das ist Karneval.
Das ist, wenn die Ordnung auf den Kopf gestellt wird. Ja. Siehst du, da vielleicht Friedrich Merz, dass du sagst, für den würde ich aber schon kämpfen wollen für die freie Welt.
Ja. Friedrich Merz ist ja nicht so blöde, die 500 Milliarden jetzt schon wieder mit irgendwelchen Bürgergeldverrechnungen zu machen.
Ja, ja.
Söder sekundiert das auf der Aschermittwochsbühne und so.
Aber das ist unsere freie Welt. Für die werden wir gemeinsam mit Friedemann Karich kämpfen.
Was haben wir bei der Impfpflicht immer gesagt? Bei der Impfpflicht haben wir irgendwann festgestellt, nachdem es da plötzlich so zur Diskussion gab, ah, da gibt es so Leute, die nutzen jetzt die Gelegenheit, um dem Staat zu sagen, du hast nie etwas für mich getan, also tu ich nichts für dich. Ist es egal, was du von mir wählst, in dem Fall ist es eine Impfung, kriegst du nicht. So, das ist der Modus. Und die Leute gucken nicht Presseclub und lassen sich dann irgendwie, und der Merz ist jetzt der Führer der freien Welt und übrigens auch dein Bundeskanzler.
Ja, ich hab dann gedacht, wie kann man sagen, das ist jetzt irgendwie der Mann der freien Welt und so was, und dann hab ich gedacht, irgendwie geht das doch gar nicht so alles überein, oder? Und dann hab ich mir gedacht, als wenn mir das schickt, dass ich hör mal kurz rein, es gibt in den Senden, den mit Samira, El-Wassil und Friedemann Karich, diesen Piraten-Sender Powerplay-Podcast. Und dann reden die da tatsächlich über Friedrich Merz. Und ich habe jetzt einfach mal so einen längeren Clip, der geht eigentlich noch viel, viel länger, in dem Friedemann Karich, bevor er das geschrieben hat, über Friedrich Merz redet. Und dann können wir uns ja nochmal fragen, ob es zwei Friedemann Karichs gibt oder zwei Friedrich Merz. Das ist eigentlich die Frage, die man sich da stellt.
Eins muss man Friedrich Merz wirklich lassen. Er ist der konsequenteste Kanzler, den man sich für Deutschland gerade vorstellen kann, weil er, finde ich, alles das, was ich an Deutschland nicht mag, in sich vereint. Also er ist ein aufbrausender Seriositätsdarsteller, der einerseits mit großer Geste im November einen fairen Wahlkampf und eine Abgrenzung nach rechts verspricht und bald es super lässig bricht, sobald es ihm irgendwie zu nützen scheint. Der ist nie bereit, sich zu korrigieren und an meinen Fehler zuzugeben, aber immer bereit für unfaire Attacken gegen seine Gegner, gegen Arme, gegen anders Aussehende und Andersdenkende, wie jetzt eben mit dieser Anfrage. Der ist diese Attitüde, solange ihr eure Füße unter meine Bundesrepublik stellt, das ist er auf zwei Beinen und einer Haarinsel. Das ist jemand, der sich durch hoch dotierte Mandate, Wirtschaftskompetenz selber zuspricht, was auch so deutsch ist und nicht checkt, dass das eigentlich nur ein großer Ausdruck seiner Privilegien ist. Er ist ein Dampfplauderer und Wichtigtur, der immer irgendwo was zu melden haben muss, der pathetisch mit seinem Gewissen argumentiert, um seinen eigentlich grenzenlosen Opportunismus zu überspielen und dann drei Wochen später als alle anderen längst eingesehen haben, dass er mit seinen angeblich vom Gewissen getriebenen Forderungen in der Migrationspolitik komplett daneben lag, die Position dann räumt. Aber ohne das wirklich zuzugeben, das könnte natürlich jemand wie Friedrich Merz, wie der typische Deutsche, nicht. Er hört sich gerne reden, wäre gerne volksnah, hat aber eigentlich glaube ich so große Angst vor Menschen, dass er lieber den Privatflieger nimmt als mal die Bahn. Er ist rechts offen und hat Angst vor links, weil er das nicht versteht und schon gar nicht, was an Recht so schlimm ist, weil es ihn ja persönlich nicht bedrohen würde. Ich glaube, Friedrich Merz hält es oft für ein politisches Talent, die Leute im Zweifel schamlos anzulügen. Und gesteht sich das auch alles selbstgerecht, glaube ich, zu. Aus der Kränkung heraus, gegen eine Frau verloren zu haben, was auch so unfassbar deutsch ist.
Ja und dann können wir uns ja nochmal überfragen, ob das jetzt der tolle Anführer der freien Welt ist. Kann jeder für sich selbst beantworten. Und wir leiten über zu dem Buch.
Ich halte übrigens Friedrich Merz auch für einen Loser einfach. Also wirklich mit 28,5 Prozent.
Ja, das ist ja überhaupt kein tolles Ergebnis.
Das ist einfach katastrophal. Das ist so schlecht. Und da kann man sich froh sein, wenn man überhaupt eine Bundestagsmehr zusammenkriegt, um den Kanzlerposten zu haben. Aber danach müssen eigentlich die Tore offenstehen für ich mach hier mal Koalitionsfrieden und na klar, mach ich Zugeständnisse und überhaupt und so.
Er war ja bei dieser Bildgala, wir haben ja ausführlich drüber gesprochen und hatte dort doch erst seine Spendenhöhe daran knüpfen wollen, wie erfolgreich die CDU abschneidet. Und da sprach er ja von 40 Prozent. Es ist einfach absurd.
Wir müssen uns jetzt trauen, die Loser auch als Loser zu beobachten. Wir können nicht immer die ganze Zeit, oh ich hab so Angst vor Trump, weil der hat ja Atomwaffen und so. Trump ist ein Loser, Merz ist ein Loser, es sind alles Loser.
Kämpfen für Friedrich Merz ist wirklich keine gute Idee. Wir sprechen jetzt über dieses wirklich spektakuläre Buch, The Technological Republic, Hard Power, Soft Belief and the Future of the West von Alexander C. Karp und Nikolaus W. Samiska, sie beide sind von Palantir und legen uns ihre Vision ganz offen da. Eigentlich eine Dystopie, für sie ist das eine Utopie. Wir müssen darüber ausführlich reden. Ich habe mich aufgrund dieser Lektüre dann entschlossen, doch noch mit dem Manifest des Una-Bombas zu warten für den nächsten Monat, weil ich nicht noch was Gruseliges lesen wollte, sondern habe dann als Gegengift, wenn man so möchte, Y2K gelesen. Hast du vielleicht schon gehört von Colette Shade, eine Journalistin, How the 2000s became everything. Sie erzählt also die Geschichte, die popkulturelle, digitale und ein bisschen auch die politische Geschichte der 2000er Jahre und zeigt, wie sich alles so veränderte und was uns davon heute noch prägt. Ein kurzweiliges Buch, ein Buch, das eben nicht so dystopisch auf die Welt blickt und gerade nicht auf diese Konsumerkultur, die Alexander Kaab so sehr abstraft. Außerdem ist zur richtigen Zeit ein kurzer Roman erschienen von Lucas Maisel. Der beschäftigt sich mit dem Mann, der damals nichts tat, der damals oder das richtige Tat, in dem er nichts tat, der nämlich als ein Alarm angezeigt wurde, nicht darauf reagierte und sagte, das kann nur ein Fehlalarm sein. Wir können hier nicht von der Sowjetunion aus jetzt davon ausgehen, dass die Amerikaner die das Atomprogramm gezündet haben. Und damit hat er tatsächlich das Ende der Welt verhindert. Und da gibt es einen kurzen Romanzo, den sollte man jetzt unbedingt lesen. Außerdem gibt es noch von mir Musik, diesmal Benjamin Britten aus der FAZ, einen kurzen Bericht über die Rekrutierer in der Ukraine und das brutale Vorgehen und ein Artikel über einen Ring, mit dem sich Paare gegenseitig überwachen können.
Ja, sehr gut. Ich habe auch ein Anti-Dote, oder wie das heißt, ein Gegenentwurf zu Alex Grab, denn die Direktorin des Bundesinstituts für Bevölkerungsforschung, klingt natürlich gleich super sexy, Katharina Spieß hat im Wirtschaftsdienst, das ist natürlich special interest, ich habe einen höheren Hinweis dazu bekommen, zum Thema Förderung der frühen Bildung und in alternden Gesellschaften, worüber man so nachdenken muss, brauchen wir ein Bundesprogramm für Kitas. Ich möchte gern vorher schon sagen, das ist viel näher dran an einer Wehrpflichtsdiskussion, wenn man sie ernsthaft über Verteidigungsfähigkeit, Willigkeit und gibt es eigentlich was zu verteidigen, führen möchte, ja, dann sollte man in diese Richtung denken. Dann stelle ich zwei Texte gegenüber, zum einen hat Kevin Roos in der New York Times darüber geschrieben, wie es ist, jetzt ohne Coding-Kenntnisse Code zu produzieren, Software herzustellen durch KI-Hilfe und in seinem Marcus On AI Newsletter hat der ehemalige Professor für Psychologie und eben heute KI-Unternehmer selbst, Markus, glaube ich seinen Nachnamen nicht, naja, jedenfalls Markus, Gary Markus heißt er, so heißt er, eine Antwort darauf geschrieben, wo die Gefahren liegen. Kleine individuelle Vorteile, klar, die sind da, aber haben das ja vielleicht auch mit großen Problemen zu tun. Und dann hat Philipp Hopf in seinem Hopf und Hate Podcast über sein Lieblingsbuch gesprochen. Ich habe Claude danach gefragt, was hat es mit dem Buch auf sich? Wir gehen Claudes Antworten durch und schauen in einen Text von Anne Applebaum. Sie hat im The Atlantic über den neuen Amerikaner gesprochen, den brutalen Amerikaner, wie er uns gezeigt wurde. Denn der ist ja gar nicht so neu, er hat jetzt nur die Vorderbühne betreten. Da gibt es so ein paar Sachen, über die wir mal nachdenken müssen. Und außerdem finde ich das aus akademischen Kniffen ein sehr guter Text. Wir haben sie ja sehr kritisiert für ihren... Klar, sie hat die Gelegenheit genutzt. Wir müssten eigentlich auch das Auswahlkomitee kritisieren dafür, überhaupt einen Applebaum Friedenspreis des Deutschen Buchandels zu geben. Aber es sind nun mal kriegerische Zeiten und ein paar Gedankengänge sind ja gar nicht so schlecht. Also gehen wir einem nach, den ich gut finde.
Dann sehen wir uns im Salon. Ich will noch darauf hinweisen, dass ich in diesem Monat in Duisburg und in Reutlingen zu Gast bin. Das findet man alles auf meiner Homepage wolfgangm schmidt.de Sehr gut.
Ich habe auch zwei Termine im April fürs Buch. Einen Karlsruhe, einen in Wien findet man. Ich habe es noch nicht auf der Webseite eingetragen, aber werde ich jetzt die Tage machen.
Wunderbar. Dann sehen wir uns im Salon. Bis gleich.
Bis gleich. Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Du hast kein Smartphone.
Immer noch nicht.
Bist du damit ganz auf Alex Carps Seite?
Könnte sein.
Was ist Alex Carps Seite?
Ja, es ist eine, die sich lustig macht oder geradezu mokiert darüber, dass Silicon Valley die Leute abhängig gemacht hat von Smartphones, dass es nur noch um Consumer Electronics geht, um irgendwelche Apps, mit denen man sich Essenden, Geschlechtspartner oder sonst was liefern kann. Aber sie haben doch eigentlich nichts Nennenswertes für die Nation, für die Identität, für den großen amerikanischen Mythos getan. Es war doch einfach nur eine Zerstreuungskultur der schlimmsten Art und sie war unverantwortlich, sie war auf kurzfristige Profite hinaus und das muss sich doch dringend ändern. Und wer jetzt denkt, naja das klingt aber doch so ein bisschen nach eher linker Kulturkritik, hat in gewisser Weise erst einmal Recht. Und dann werden wir aber merken, dass das in eine andere Richtung kippt. Das ist wirklich ein Buch, das einen erschüttert deshalb, weil dieses Buch natürlich an sehr viel Angriff, bei dem man erst einmal eine gewisse Ambition hat das zu teilen. Ja, also man sagt, das stimmt ja auch, wir sind ja alle so zerstreut. Es stimmt ja auch, dass sich lange Zeit immer nur gedacht wurde, wie kann ich mir noch günstiger irgendein Produkt bekommen? Was muss ich jetzt gerade besitzen? Sollte ich zwei davon kaufen? Gibt's morgen noch eins? Also auch diese ganze Influencerkultur. Das ist etwas, was Alexander Kaap und Samiska, der Co-Autor kritisieren. Aber wir werden dann sehen, es geht in eine andere Richtung. Wir sehen schon am Titel The Technological Republic. Es ist hier ein staatstragendes Buch, das wir vor uns liegen haben.
Zu dieser Frage, du hast kein Smartphone und Alex Kaap sagt, das ist ganz gut, weil du dann sozusagen deine Zeit nicht vergeudest. Hier muss man noch mal einen ganz klaren Unterschied zu Manfred Spitzer und Co. machen und so. Denn Alex Kaap geht es ja nicht um dich. Du bist für Alex Kaap schon zivilisatorische Verfügungsmasse, Spielball. Du bist schon so ein weicher Pudding, den man einfach nur so hin und her zieht. Ihm geht es ja um diejenigen, die die Smartphones herstellen, die ihr Talent verschwenden, sich nicht für den Start und die große Idee opfern, sondern einfach 300.000 Euro bei Facebook verdienen, um den Leuten Video-Sharing von Auto-Unfällen zu ermöglichen. So. Also wir haben ja einen Elitendiskurs. Die Chefs eines Silicon-Wallet-Unternehmens nehmen das ganze Silicon-Wallet hart ins Gericht und das Publikum des Silicon-Wallets, das ist schon ausgeschlossene Masse. Das hatten wir ja auch schon bei Elon Musk gehört damals, der ja gar nicht mehr von Menschen und Menschheit und so spricht, sondern nur noch von so zivilisatorischen und wir brauchen hier mal die 1000 Mozarts. Das wiederum ist ein Zitat von Jeff Bezos. Also wir sind ja nah dran an einem Denken, dass wir, was das angeht, was uns angeht, was wir hier übersehen werden, als schon ganz schön verabscheuungswürdig sehen. Und dieser innere Diskurs, der da stattfindet im Silicon-Wallet, die steigen ja wirklich hart, hart, hart in dieses Buch ein. Ich würde auch vorschlagen, dadurch, dass ich mir relativ viele Originalzitate rausgezogen habe und dann mit Klod auf Deutsch übersetzt habe, dass man mal so richtig im Wortlaut durchgeht, wie dieses Buch beginnt im ersten Kapitel. Und wir kennen ja schon die Diskussion von Peter Thiel mit David Grebber. Es wird ganz oft immer wieder darauf Bezug genommen. Wir erinnern uns, wir haben ja auch einen Clip davon gespielt, wie die beiden übereinstimmten, dass ja, wir kriegen ja ganz schön viele Videosharing-Apps und können jetzt twittern, aber wo ist das fliegende Auto? Wo ist der echte Fortschritt? Wo sind die Atome? Statt nur einfach Bits hin und her zu schubsen. Dieses Buch beginnt so, dass hier kurz gesagt wird, es geht um ein, also das Buch selbst ist das Ergebnis eines jahrzehntlangen Gesprächs, der stattfand, über Technologie, über das nationale Projekt und die neuen gefährlichen politischen und kulturellen Herausforderungen, denen man sich stellen muss. Es ist ein Moment der Abrechnung, ein Moment of Reckoning für den Westen gekommen. Also wir sind ja schon so in Hollywood Sprache irgendwie. Sie beklagen den großen Verlust der nationalen Ambitionen. Die Interesse oder das Interesse am Potential von Wissenschaft und Technologie wird vergeudet. Der Staat ignoriert das einfach. Bei der Medizin, bei der Raumfahrt, militärische Software, es ist eine gigantische Investitionslücke, die sie beklagen. Der Staat hat sich von den bahnbrechenden Durchbrüchen zurückgezogen. Er hat damals noch die Atombombe mit einem großen Projekt hergestellt. Das Internet wurde auch auf staatliche Initiative hingegründet. Die heutigen Herausforderungen werden alle dem privaten Sektor überlassen. Es ist ein bemerkenswertes und nahezu vollständiges Vertrauen in den Markt. Nun kann man sich fragen, wer denn das provoziert. Also Elon Musk ist halt hingegangen und hat gesagt, ich hätte gern Subventionen, dafür müsst ihr nicht mehr drüber nachdenken. Ich bau jetzt die Raketen und dann haben die halt alle gesagt, okay. So, also niemand hat so viel von der amerikanischen Bürokratie profitiert wie Elon Musk durch diese ganze Subventionierung und den CO2-Handel und so weiter. Alles was staatlich eingerichtet wurde.
Bei Palantir ja auch.
Und da sowieso, da wird ja direkt das Produkt vom Staat gekauft.
Ja und darum soll es ja gehen. Wir haben mal, es ist Ewigkeiten her, im Salon ein Buch gehabt, das hab nur ich vorgestellt, das war von dem Anwalt von Microsoft, das hieß Tools and Weapons. Und da schlug er vor, dass die Unternehmen doch jetzt Hand in Hand mit der Regierung zusammenarbeiten sollten und nicht mehr so einen Anti-Regierungskurs pflegen. Im Prinzip knüpft das Buch jetzt hier an, radikalisiert nur diese These, in dem gesagt wird, ihr Silicon Valley Gründer habt Amerika als eine absterbende Nation angesehen. Ihr habt euch nie um eine nationale Identität gekümmert. Was euch interessiert, war Konsumkultur, wie man mit Werbung viel Geld verdienen kann und wie man Leute dazu bringt, dass sie shoppen. Das war das Programm. Und das Silicon Valley sollte jetzt beginnen, eine neue Beziehung zur Regierung aufzubauen. Und interessanterweise legt er sehr früh Wert darauf, dass dem Staat eine ganz entscheidende Rolle dabei zukommt. Er sagt, es ist natürlich der Schutz der individuellen Rechte vor staatlichen Eingriffen, der im Westen seine moderne Form gefunden hat. Ohne, dass der schwindelerregende Aufstieg des Silicon Valley niemals möglich gewesen wäre. Also es gibt da zwar eine Spannung, aber er sagt dann, dass die Tech-Konzerne eigentlich und das Silicon Valley besonders den Erfolg dem Staat zu verdanken haben, weil der Staat früh auftrat in Form von Investitionen, vor allem ins Militär. Er geht ja immer wieder in die 40er Jahre zurück, beschreibt das sehr deutlich. Ich dachte dann und habe es mir dann schon früher in den Land geschrieben, das ist eigentlich eine Argumentation, wie wir sie von Mariana Mazzucato finden. Und einige Seiten später zitiert er dann auch Mariana Mazzucato direkt und deswegen habe ich eben im Teaser gesagt, naja, das wäre vielleicht ein Programm, das den Grünen gar nicht so unrecht wäre, denn das ist ja quasi die Lieblingsökonomin von Habeck. Denn hier wird gesagt, also der Staat ist nicht der Antipode dieser Unternehmen, sondern muss eigentlich mit denen ein Bündnis bilden. Und wozu soll dieses Bündnis denn da sein? Denn man kann das natürlich jetzt verknüpfen, um zu sagen, damit wir solidarischer werden, mehr Bildung haben, mehr Klimaschutz oder so. Klima kommt überhaupt nicht vor in diesem Buch, interessanterweise. Es geht um, Zitat, eine Re-Invention of a national project.
Genau und jetzt kann man sich ja schon die Frage stellen, was wir in Realität sehen im Vergleich zu dem, was hier im Buch beschrieben und kritisiert wird. Denn die Gründer der großen Silicon Valley Unternehmen, die sich also dem Wohlbefinden ihres Publikums nähern und sagen, ihr wollt Video-Sharing, also hier habt ihr 1000 Apps, mit denen ihr eure Videos teilen könnt, betrachten Amerika als sterbendes Imperium, das ihrem eigenen ökonomischen Erfolg im Weg steht. Die Hinwendung zum Staat, die wir jetzt gerade sehen, Elon Musk mit seiner Ich-bin-der-Doge-Beauftragung da, die hat ja nicht eine Ich-mache-mir-den-Staat-untertan, sondern ich baue ihn gerade ab. Und man könnte nicht mal sagen, okay, vielleicht ist das so in zwei Schritten. Wir bauen erst die Bürokratie ab und dann springt Palantir da rein, wie das der Arjo Schumacher beschrieben hat, sondern nein, hier wird ja wirklich Wüste hinterlassen. Also hier findet kein konstruktiver Umgang statt. Das heißt, Elon Musk fährt hier wirklich gerade sein eigenes Programm. Und wir können davon ausgehen, dass Peter Thiel das ganz uncool findet. Vor allem kommen wir dann im Verlauf des Textes dazu, wie sehr das immer wieder betont wird, wenn man eigentlich eine große gemeinsame Idee, die Amerika integriert und Amerika in den Allianzen der Welt hält. Ja. Und das wird gerade alles abgerissen. Also in der Ansicht fällt hier schon Wunsch des Palantir-Chefs und Wirklichkeit, wie sie Elon Musk herstellt, ganz radikal auseinander.
Und das ist ja eine interessante Strömung innerhalb der Rechten, dass man eigentlich sehr stark diese Leute hat, die einen schlanken Start wollen, die eigentlich einen Libertarismus fahren möchten. Da werden vielleicht noch einzelne Partikularinteressen bedient, wenn es dann um irgendwelche Meme-Coins oder so geht, aber es geht nicht um ein solches Projekt. Wenn man sich die faschistischen Regierungen der Vergangenheit ansieht, dann waren die ja, wenn man so möchte, kainsianisch. Die haben ja sehr viel Geld in die Hand genommen und dann wurden Autobahnen gebaut, was auch immer. Und Adam Toos hatte ja mal vor einer Weile in einem Podcast, in einem Vortrag gesagt, mit der AfD, weil die so sehr von dieser Austeritätspolitik besessen sind, ist nicht einmal ein Faschismus zu machen. Und in gewisser Weise ist das ja auch eine gute Nachricht. Und man kann das jetzt da übertragen. Bei Elon Musk ist das ähnlich. Der will alles kurz und klein schlagen. Ich will jetzt nicht Alexander Karp unterstellende Willen Faschismus etablieren, aber was der auf jeden Fall will, ist einen autoritären Staat, in dem sich alle einem Kollektiv unterordnen. Das hat faschistoide Tendenzen, die natürlich bei ihm etwas inklusiver sind als jetzt in einem Nazi-Faschismus. Also er lässt da natürlich im Einwanderungsland wie USA noch ein bisschen mehr gelten als die Nazis. Aber es läuft natürlich auf ein Programm hinaus, bei dem der Staat wirklich immer die Entscheidungsfunktion hat, über alle Köpfe hinweg zu regieren und auszurichten, was jetzt geglaubt, gedacht und gemacht werden muss.
Dazu gehört eigentlich in seinem Bild ein nach chinesischen Maßstäben befriedetes Publikum, das bereit ist zu verzichten.
Homogenität muss hergestellt werden und verzichten. Ja.
So und das sehen wir gerade nicht, sondern das Silicon Valley hat ja alle gerade darauf gebracht, dass sie viel weiter über ihren eigenen Möglichkeiten, später im Text schreibt er ja von dem aristokratischen Lebensstil, man lässt sich alles auf den Zuruf bringen und so weiter, aber man hat eigentlich gar nicht das Gehalt dafür. Also baut man sich so Apps, Uber, Essen, Lieferer und so der ganze Kram.
Ja und das hat ja auch in gewisser Weise funktioniert, also mit einem relativ niedrigen Gehalt kann man Dinge erleben, die früher undenkbar gewesen sind. Also dass Leute, die jetzt Studenten sind oder so mal mit einem Taxi durch die Gegend fahren, das war früher jetzt eher ungewöhnlich, aber mit einem Uber ist schon jeder mal gefahren, egal wie wenig Geld er irgendwie hat. Ja und ähnlich bei den Mahlzeiten, also das hat sich schon sehr verändert. Und jetzt muss man nämlich folgenden Punkt machen, das ist mir ganz wichtig, das nochmal zu betonen. Wir haben ja durch die Grows und so weiter eine Verzichtsidee, die im Raum ist, ja. Also dass man sagt, nehmt euch zurück und seid nicht so hedonistisch und all das. Ich warne, also ich und ich kann das auch alles sehr nachvollziehen, da geht es ja um sparen von CO2-Emissionen und so weiter. Ich halte da vieles für nicht gut, aber grundsätzlich ist die Stoßrichtung mir einleuchtend. Die Leute, die so etwas vertreten, müssen höllisch aufpassen, dass sie nicht falsche Freunde machen, dass sie jetzt plötzlich in jemanden, der auch sagt, genau wir brauchen jetzt mal Verzicht und wir haben doch höhere Ideale, dass die gleich glauben, ach der gehört ja zu mir. Und das ist ja interessant zu beobachten, dass wir, auch wenn ich jetzt Alexander Karp und Ulrike Herrmann feinsäublich voneinander trennen will, man doch zum Beispiel bei Ulrike Herrmann feststellen kann, dass sie zum einen ganz gegen eine Konsumkultur ist und sagt, das ist alles unverantwortlich. Zum anderen aber will sie eine Kriegswirtschaft wirklich im Sinne von einer massiven Aufrüstung haben und findet diesen Verzicht, der da gepflegt wird, dann wieder sehr gut. Das heißt, man muss wirklich das sehr fein voneinander trennen. Also eine linke Konsumkritik, die ich oft sowieso nicht für besonders intelligent halte, sollte man schon sehr klar abzugrenzen wissen von dem, was Alexander Karp da fordert. Denn das, was die hier wollen, ist auf jeden Fall schlechter als eine Gesellschaft, in der die Leute die ganze Zeit sich irgendwelche Essen bestellen und auf irgendwelchen Sharing-Apps die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Bildchen hin und her versenden. Das ist auch alles ein bisschen blöde. Und wir haben es ja hier auch hundertfach kritisiert. Aber am Ende würde ich doch sagen, eine Jugend und generell Menschen, die anderthalb Stunden bei TikTok verbummeln, sind mir dann am Ende doch lieber, als Leute, die sich diesem Kollektiv unterwerfen, das Alexander Karp hier vorschlägt.
Wir können das ja mal verorten. Also diese Kritik am Silicon Valley ist jetzt sehr deutlich geworden. Und er sieht das ja in dem größeren Rahmen, diese Art von Verzicht und das große nationale Projekt. In Russland wird es einfach durchgesetzt. China auf der anderen Seite hat diesen technologischen Fortschritt, weil die sich eben konzentrieren durch Ansagen, wir machen ja planwirtschaftliche und so weiter, wir wollen die Schlüsseltechnologien. Wartet mal mit euren Entwicklungen von irgendwelchen Annehmlichkeitskram. So kann man ja alles in WeChat einbauen, dann ist es erledigt, reichen zehn Leute für. So weshalb er ihm ganz deutlich ist zu sagen, es ist ein sehr zerbrechlicher geopolitischer Vorteil, der zu bewahren ist, den wer hat, die Vereinigten Staaten und ihre Verbündeten in Europa. Also hier ganz großer Widerspruch zu dem, was wir gerade in der Nachrichtenlage haben. Und er betont eben noch ganz deutlich, nicht nur haben wir einen zivilisatorischen Wettstreit zwischen Menschen, Blöcken, also China, Russland, Europa, Amerika, wir auch immer, sondern wir müssen auch eine Vorherrschaft durch KI über die KI selbst bewahren.
Die KI soll die neue Waffe sein.
Genau, sie ist die neue Atomwaffe. Sie wurde uns ja später da vorgestellt. So und dann betont er nochmal, dass Palantir der Versuch ist, diese Art von kollektiver Unternehmung zu verwirklichen, die ein kreatives Ergebnis durch diese neue Verbindung von Theorie und Handlung herstellen möchte. Also er idealisiert Palantir auf eine Weise, was ich ein bisschen haarsträubend und auch sehr den Hahn herbeigezogen finde, weil Palantir ja sehr obskur handelt. Also wir sehen jetzt hier kein Meta-Konzern oder Google oder Apple, die so mit das ist unser Campus, das ist unser Menü, hier kriegt jeder Kosten, das Kindergarten und so. Sondern wir wissen gar nicht, was Palantir ist. Also er kann uns jetzt alles verkaufen.
Und das Interessante ist, er sagt uns auch fast gar nicht zu dem Unternehmen, er sagt das nur in der Abstraktion. Er sagt Palantir, das ist Theory and Action. Und man denkt so, äh ja interessant. Und wenn man dann natürlich ein bisschen nachschaut, was machen die, also die Verkaufen Polizeisoftware, die Polizeihessen. Überwachungssoftware, Gesichtserkennung, diese ganzen Dinge. Sie kooperieren natürlich mit dem Verteidigungsministerium in Israel. Sie kooperieren mit allen möglichen anderen Regierungen, Polizeistationen etc. Und darin sehen sie ihre große Aufgabe, nämlich sie glauben, dass diese Art der Überwachung und der repressiven Apparate, die sie herstellen, dass darin eigentlich das große Potenzial liegt, dass man diese Consumer-Kultur und all das verlässt, dass man die Nation neu erfindet und das westliche Projekt als solches absichert vor seinen Feinden, von seinen Feinden, die von außen kommen, aber auch von den Feinden im Inneren. Denn natürlich sind das ja auch Denunzianten-Softwares, wenn man so möchte. Also das ist etwas, womit man glaubt, dass man damit alle wieder auf Linie bringen kann für ein westliches Projekt, von dem dann immer wieder gesagt wird, das ist es eigentlich, was verloren gegangen ist, durch das egoistische Silicon Valley Unternehmertum.
Genau. Und das beschreibt er hier dann im Folgenden ganz klar, da sind wir auch wieder bei Ulrike Herrmann. Also im November 1944, wir wissen also, der Zweite Weltkrieg läuft noch, schreibt Roosevelt als Präsident ein Brief an Vannevar Bush, damals Leiter des US Office of Scientific Research and Development und sagt, dieses einzigartige Experiment, was hier gerade läuft, dass wir also sogar eine Atombombe herstellen können, wenn wir nur die Wissenschaft und den Staat zusammenbringen, das soll am Leben erhalten bleiben, auch in den absehbaren Friedenszeiten, denn Deutschland war so fast besiegt. Da wird es also schon mal vorbereitet. Der Staat soll seine Macht, sein Prestige und seine nicht nur finanziellen, aber vor allem finanziellen Ressourcen dafür aufwenden, auch in Friedenszeiten diese Zusammenarbeit gewinnbringend an den Staat zu bringen. Er erinnert dann an John Adams, den zweiten Präsidenten der Vereinigten Staaten, der damals schon den Hunger besiegte, indem er sagte, wir als Staat stellen uns auch die Aufgabe zu koordinieren, wie die Wissenschaft uns dabei hilft, die Landwirtschaft usw. zu verbessern. Also er kommt auf diese ganzen punktuellen Erfolgsgeschichten zu sprechen. Wir haben die Nazis besiegt, wir haben den Hunger besiegt und das Internet geschaffen. Und jetzt haben wir das irgendwie aus dem Augen verloren und wir sehen nur Technik-Chefs, die sich in der Wissenschaft bedienen, indem sie die jungen Mathematiker und wir noch immer abwerben, um denen dann zu sagen, ihr baut jetzt Technik, mit der wir direkt mit dem Kunden kommunizieren und ich halte euch dafür den Staat vom Leib. So und das ist, wir sind sozusagen falsches Vorzeichen. Die Distanz zwischen Wissenschaft und Staat ist ihm zu groß.
Und wir haben ja im Wahlprogramm zum Beispiel der FDP, aber auch bei der CDU gibt es diese Stimmen vernehmen können, dass man die Zivilklausel abschaffen will, dass also die wissenschaftliche Forschung an den Universitäten durchaus jetzt auch zu militärischen Zwecken sein soll. Was man eigentlich da ausgeschossen hatte. Und das ist etwas, was Karp absolut befürwortet. Ja, das Silicon Valley hat vergessen, dass seine Ursprünge militärischer Natur sind und dass das etwas ist, woran man jetzt wieder anknüpfen muss. Und dann bringt er natürlich sehr viele Gründe dafür, warum das so gekommen ist. Interessanterweise geht er immer wieder auch auf die 68er ein. Also die 68er mit ihrer Staatsskepsis, mit der Conta-Culture, mit all dem, was als subversiv galt, hat dafür gesorgt, dass also der eine große Glaube an die Nationen, an den Westen unterminiert wurden. Und das gilt es jetzt wieder rückabzuwickeln. Und das ist natürlich das große Programm, das man dann auch vernehmen kann, wenn so Leute wie Friedrich Merz oder Jens Spahn sagen, Deutschland ist nicht links, Deutschland ist nicht mehr länger links oder so, dann schwingt dann natürlich genau dies mit.
Interessant ist auch, wie er argumentiert, denn die, die wir die Texte so ein bisschen näher kennen als er wahrscheinlich, je nachdem, was er gelesen hat, es taucht dann so Jürgen Habermas auf oder so.
Aber an ganz verrückten Stellen.
Ja, also Jürgen Habermas wird hier in Beschlag genommen, um darzustellen, dass ein Versagen von Führungspersönlichkeiten, die implizit oder expliziten Versprechen an die Öffentlichkeit einlösen, einzulösen, das Potenzial haben, eine Legitimitätskrise für eine Regierung hervorzurufen. Also könnte mir jetzt tausend Fäden stricken, wie man Habermas hier so ein Text einbaut. Aber dass Habermas jetzt den charismatischen Führer noch mal als Legitimator eines, nein, also hier könnte man...
Das ist ja gerade nicht.
Genau.
Wenn ja irgendwas, Jürgen Habermas nicht will. Also ich kenne jetzt nicht jedes Zeichen.
Eigentlich ist das das zwanglose Argument eines offenen Diskurses, der auf einen Konsens mit dem Alleinverstand in den Hinschlaufen läuft. Aber gut, Habermas hat offenbar noch mal das Führerprinzip.
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen und es ist interessant, wir kommen ja vielleicht nachher noch drauf, er hat ja auch über Martin Walzer dann in diesem Buch geschrieben, also dass es dann ganz klar gab. Ich wollte nur darauf hinweisen, ein Hörer hatte mir die Dessertation von Karpf geschickt, die er in Frankfurt ja geschrieben hat. Und die habe ich mir dann zu Teilen durchgelesen, die ist überhaupt nicht lang. 129 Seiten, auch eigenartig. Finde ich gut. Ja, aber es ist sehr eigenartig, dass das durchgegangen ist. Da habe ich mich auch schon wieder gefragt, was ist da gelaufen, dass man mit 129 Seiten promovieren kann. Und dann habe ich gelesen die letzten 40 Seiten, weil es da auch um Walser und sowas geht. Und es ist derart dürftig intellektuell und auch stilistisch so schwach. Und was er dort an Textexegese betreibt, er arbeitet da mit dem Jargon der Eigentlichkeit von Adorno und geht dann damit ein bisschen diese Walser-Rede in der Pauzkirche durch, dass ich dachte, es ist sehr komisch, dass das als Dissertation durchgegangen ist. Denn man würde so sagen, das ist vielleicht für so eine Pro-Seminar-Hausarbeit ganz schön, das mal so miteinander verbunden zu haben und würde auch bestimmt eine 2 Plus geben. Aber es ist keineswegs besonders intellektuell. Und hier merkt man aber immer wieder, wie sie bemüht sind, weil sie die ganze Zeit vom Westen und dieser gemeinsamen Kulturen-Alter sprechen, irgendwelche Autoritätsargumente rein zu streuen in Form von großen Namen, mit denen sie aber gar nichts anfangen können. Also dieses Habermas-Beispiel ist ja nicht das Einzelne. Sie gehen auch auf Anja Seller oder so ein und auch da, wissen sie nicht so zu sagen.
Ja, also wir sind jetzt im KI-Zeitalter und zwar seit einem Jahr oder so, in dem einfach, ich habe dieses Beispiel genannt mit Antwerpen, wir kriegen Antwerpen überall hinunter gejubelt. Das ist kongolesisch, es ist niederländisch, es gehört zu Singapur. Ja, also wenn man will, kriegt man jetzt alles unter. Habermas nochmal auf Seite 17 einbauen klappt jetzt immer, was für uns heißt ab sofort, wenn Habermas hier in dem Text auftaucht, muss man genau prüfen, was da Sache ist, weil es könnte sein, dass wir hier an dieser Stelle etwas zu weit in die Manufaktur dieses Textes hineinschauen können und sagen müssen, es ist ganz schön viel Bullshit. Und damit meine ich jetzt ganz konkret und das werden wir häufiger, also in dem Text sehen wir es auch oft, aber das werden wir jetzt häufiger sehen. Menschen konzentrieren sich jetzt sehr, sehr, sehr auf eine inhärente Logik ihrer Argumentation und übersehen damit so ein bisschen die Resonanzfindung und Approximationshoffnung zur Welt, in der sie diese Argumentation machen. Also man läuft sozusagen 80 Prozent des Weges und dann härtet man diese 80 Prozent ab, statt noch den Brückenschlag bis zum anderen Ufer zu machen.
Und tut so, als sei man im Ziel.
Genau. Und das ist ja, wir haben es bei Harari auch schon kritisiert, dass da einfach zu viel Empirie zufällig passt.
Ja.
So ja und das haben wir hier auch immer wieder. Also diese Martin-Weiser-Sachen, da kommen wir ja nachher, das war der am Ende dann, warum auch immer. Wahrscheinlich wusste er, das Buch wird vor allem in Amerika und Deutschland gelesen, weil er so einen Deutschlandbezug hat. Dass er da nochmal Martin-Weiser und vor allem die Paulskirche einbauen muss, ist natürlich Frankfurt. Gut, aber am Anfang, also die Friedensdividende ist aufgebraucht und er sagt ganz klar, die fähigste Generation von Kodern hat nie einen Krieg oder echte soziale Umwälzung erlebt. Jetzt ist wieder an der Zeit. Und er betont, ganz wichtig, deswegen werde ich es auch immer wieder betonen, immer wieder Europa.
Aber das ist doch tatsächlich diese Stimmung, die er hier evoziert, eine, die wir vorfinden in unseren Diskursen. Also das ist ja so, das könnte jetzt auch Claudia Major gesagt haben.
Ja, aber jetzt ist immer wieder bei dieser Frage, die du ja eben schon hattest beim Thema Eltern. Die große Idee und das eigene konkrete persönliche Schicksal. Wir können immer sagen, ach die Koder, könnten die nicht mal und so weiter und so fort. Aber am Ende kommt es darauf an, dass wir Leute als Staat werben wollen, die beim Meta einfach 300.000 Euro im Jahr verdienen, ein ganz geruhsames Leben führen, dort gepampert werden und so weiter und so fort. Können wir uns eine Behördenstruktur vorstellen, in deren Behördenchef mit seinem 71.000 Euro oder was auch immer Befehle gibt an irgendjemanden, den man 400.000 Euro im Jahr bezahlen muss und sehr viel Freiheit einräumen. Also das muss man dann auch erstmal organisieren, so wie er sich das hier wünscht. Also die an so einer Verwaltung eingliedern ist schwierig. Aber gut, das sind die Versuche zu diesem Europa. Ich lese nochmal ein Beispiel vor. Also es wird jedoch eine Vereinigung des Staates und der Softwareindustrie sein, nicht ihre Trennung und Entflechtung, die erforderlich sein wird, damit die Vereinigten Staaten und ihre Verbündeten in Europa und auf der ganzen Welt in diesem Jahrhundert so dominant bleiben wie im Letzten. Also dieser Ton für Allianzen, für internationale Verbindungen und so weiter, den muss man immer wieder in den Kontrast zur Realität, wie wir sie sehen. Dass wir hier Aufrüstungsdiskurse haben, dass wir natürlich eine Betonung, das ist auch eine Wirtschaftsförderung für Europa haben.
Aber ist das ein Kontrast dazu? Also würdest du sagen, das ist ein Kontrast?
Ich hätte Angst, wenn ich sehen würde, dass gerade ein Demokrat in Amerika regiert, der immer mal wieder so Andeutung macht, dass man ja mit dem Silicon Valley und so weiter und Europa gibt es auch tolle Institute und so. Und dann gibt es so neue Forschungsförderungen. Davor hätte ich dann Angst, weil dann würde ich sehen an so einem Buch, ah, da kommt das her. Aber während sich gerade Zelensky und Trump gegenseitig Messer aufstellen, um sich da reinlaufen zu lassen und dann lese ich hier die große Ambition einer Allianz zwischen Amerika und der Wissenschaft. Und die Wissenschaft wird gerade auch sehr von Trump nicht inkorporiert.
Zugleich gibt es ja große Investitionen in USA und KI. Und das gibt es jetzt auch auf europäischer Ebene und immer mit diesem Sicherheitsaspekt. Also was wir doch jetzt erleben ist ein Aufblühen des militärisch-industriellen Komplexes, wie man es früher mal genannt hat. Das ist ja etwas, was wir jetzt auch nicht nur in der westlichen Welt, sondern überall eigentlich erleben können. Deswegen glaube ich, ist das Buch so zeitgemäß, dass man jetzt zwar diesen verrückten Elon Musk dort erleben kann. Und wer weiß, wie lange er das so treiben kann. Und wenn Trump das zu bunt wird, dann wird er vielleicht wieder verstoßen. Aber dass das doch eine allgemeine Entwicklung ist jetzt gerade, die uns beängstigen sollte, dass man sagt, es geht also jetzt wieder ganz stark darauf, dass wir sagen, wir müssen aufrüsten und zwar nach innen und außen versuchen, eine ganz klare, hierasische Ordnung herzustellen, in der sich alle bereits in einem Kollektiv zu unterordnen. Und jetzt haben wir eben ja im Teaser diese Dame der Bundeswehrakademie oder Universität gehört, die dann sagte, ja, das ist das dann einfach so, da muss man die Leute auch zwingen. Das ist ja im Prinzip der Ton, der hier von Karp auch angeschlagen wird. Und wenn er sagt, die Wiederherstellung einer technologischen Republik erfordert eine erneute Bekräftigung der nationalen Kultur und Werte und in der Tat als kollektive Identität und Bestimmung, ohne dass die Errungenschaften und Vorteile der wissenschaftlichen und technischen Durchbrüche des gegenwärtigen Zeitalters möglicherweise nur den engen Interessen einer abgeschotteten Elite dienen. Also was er auch ganz klar sagt ist, er will nicht, dass diese Partikularinteressen nur bedient werden, also dass die nur auf schnelle Gewinne aus sind. Das war ja auch immer eine linke Kritik, machen ja alle nur Shareholder Value und was weiß ich. Dass man jetzt aufgrund dieser Kritik dazu kommt zu sagen, ja die unterwerfen sich wirklich einem nationalen Programm, das noch viel furchtbarer ist, als sich einfach nur kurzfristigen Propheten zu unterwerfen. Dass das jetzt so eine generelle Stoßrichtung wird in der Wirtschaft. Mit anderen Worten, dass wir uns irgendwann noch nach den verrückten Milliardären auf ihren Jachten zurücksehnen, denn die wollten ja nur spielen.
Also das amerikanische Militär hat ja von Seiten der Marine in dem Fall jetzt schon die ersten Ausschreibungen gemacht für KI-Software, denen die irgendwie die Manöver erleichtern. So Microsoft und Google haben sich jetzt beworben, Google hat ja dafür auch extra sein, wir arbeiten nicht für militärische Zwecke und so gecancelt.
Gab es früher Proteste, jetzt nicht mehr.
Also wir müssen uns jetzt genauer angucken, zukünftig nicht nur, wo wird der Staat abgebaut in Amerika, sondern auch, wo werden Kapazitäten aufgebaut. Wenn jetzt irgendwann die große Nachricht kommt, Palantir stellt jetzt Software zur Verfügung für das Sozialversicherungssystem, nachdem es sich gezeigt hat, die Bürokratie kriegt es nicht hin. So kann ja auch sein, dass es, nachdem man jetzt die Hälfte der Mitarbeiter der IRS da gehen lässt und man dann so ein Chaos Jahr hat, in dem es heißt, sorry, eure Steuerrückzahlung kommt Monate später, weil wir sind mit der Berechnung so hinterher, dass dann ein Druck entsteht, um zu sagen, okay, 2026, jetzt kommt Palantir, damit die Auszahlung wieder rechtzeitig ist. Das sind dann Gefahren für nächstes Jahr. Aber erst mal jetzt gerade sehe ich das nicht. Also auch nicht in Vorbereitung. Also diese, sagen wir mal, Verfeindung von, wir haben ja gesehen, was auf der Ausgabüne los ist und Trump. Also Leute denken ja trotzdem mit, es sind eben nur 50 Prozent der Amerikaner gewesen, die Trump gewählt haben und diese Unterstützung sinkt.
Doch zugleich war ja das Silicon Valley bei der Inauguration anwesend.
Das Silicon Valley, wer ist das Silicon Valley? Wenn wir jetzt Karp nehmen, dann gibt es die Milliardäre und deren Mitarbeiter. So deren Milliardäre standen da alle parat. Aber die haben ja auch Interessen, das sind ja ihre Unternehmen. Mitarbeiter, also da haben man zuletzt die letzten Jahre und Jahrzehnte anderes aus dem Silicon Valley gehört.
Ja, ja.
So, San Francisco ist anders aufgestellt.
Nur weht der Wind nicht bald anders. Also ist das nicht einfach ein Zeitgreif, dem sich Leute bereit sind anzupassen. Genau, ich glaube auch noch nicht, dass das so ist. Und sonst würde er das Buch auch nicht schreiben, weil die beiden beklagen ja laufend, dass das noch nicht so ist. Deswegen hast du vollkommen recht, wenn du sagst, ja ich sehe das jetzt gerade nicht. Aber ich habe so den Eindruck, dass auch wenn man so manche Leute bei Social Media beobachtet, wie sie sich jetzt zu verschiedenen Themen geopolitisch oder so äußern, dass das jetzt etwas ist, was plötzlich für sie eine Relevanz bekommt. Vielleicht auch weil natürlich diese Consumer Culture, dass diese dazu geführt hat, dass manche eine gewisse Sinnlehre verspüren. Und nun plötzlich gibt es noch mal ein Sinnangebot. Es ist zwar ein uraltes, nämlich die nationale Identität, aber immerhin es ist eines. Wir haben schon mal Mark Zuckerberg. Du hast irgendwann mal diesen verrückten Clip mitgebracht. Das ist ein paar Jahre her. Mitbekommen, als er gefragt wurde auf der Bühne, mit wem er sich dann noch so unterhält. Wer gibt ihm Ratschläge? Und was antwortete er? Er kommuniziert mit Gott. Auch hier gibt es ja eine Rückwendung zum religiösen.
Also nochmal die Betonung, ein bisschen zu unterscheiden zwischen dem, was wir vom Silicon Valley auf der offenen Bühne sehen und das wir wissen ja, wie Unternehmen funktionieren. Gibt es halt auch Freundschaften und so weiter. Interne Klicken, die dann einfach und so und die müssen halt überzeugt werden. Dafür braucht man Softpower. Weshalb ich glaube, das was wir hier sehen, ist ein großes Projekt. Und das sagt er ja auch, das ist ein Jahrzehnt des Gesprächs, das jetzt hier so mündet. Es kann durchaus sein, dass wir und die Situation hatten wir ja schon mal, es gibt eine Präsidentschaft nach Trump und wir wissen alle, wie schnell es ging, dass sich Biden auf der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz zuschalten ließ und sagte, Amerika ist back. So, wenn Trump den Staat in Trümmern legt und dann das demokratische Angebot kommt, wir bauen es jetzt wieder auf und jetzt müssen auch alle mal ran, weil ihr seht ja in welchem Zustand wir sind. Und ich meine, ich rede jetzt so von drei Jahre Rückgänge des allgemeinen Wirtschaftswachs, so viele Nationen gehen durch die Decke und also totales Chaos von Trump und in drei Jahren ist ein Präsidentschaftswahlkampf. Dass dann plötzlich die Leute im Silicon Valley sagen, natürlich helfen wir dabei, den Staat jetzt aufzubauen. Und dann kommen plötzlich diese Carbs.
Ja, ja, ich würde auch sagen, das ist ein Programm, dass man mit, sagen wir, moderater Gestimmten besser umsetzen kann, als mit diesen Freidrehenden. Das ist nicht ein Programm für Millet und Musk.
Nee, nee, nee, genau. Das ist für Leute, die wieder ernsthafte Sonntagsreden halten, die wir belächeln, aber die Mehrheit nicht. Ja. So und das.
Also er zitiert jetzt zum Beispiel auch zustimmend.
Wenn der dann die Großen redet.
Ann Applebaum. Und Ann Applebaum ist natürlich einer, die sagt, die westlichen Ideen, wir tragen sie überall hin, auch wenn sie dort keiner hören will. Und das ist ja etwas, was Carb auch so sieht.
Genau.
Und wenn du dir jetzt so Interviews anhörst, zum Beispiel mit Matthias Döpfner, dann geht der in eine ähnliche Richtung.
Ja.
Von dem wissen wir ja neuerdings, dass sein Sohn, also wir haben einen Text zugeschickt bekommen, in dem drin stand, dass Matthias Döpfners Sohn der Büroleiter von Peter Thiel ist.
Was ja bedeutet, da sind auch die ein oder andere Kontroversen aufgedeckt.
Da ist ein direkter Nähje. Also wir können davon ausgehen, dass Matthias Döpfner dieses Buch auch schon zur Kenntnis genommen hat.
Wenn nicht sogar ein bisschen mitgeholfen hat.
Ja, er hat ja ein Buch geschrieben gegen China. Also er hat sich ja mit dem Freihandel beschäftigt und wir haben das Buch jetzt nicht gelesen, aber ich hab Präzensionen dazu rezipiert und da ging es ja für Döpfner ganz klar darum, dass man eine Allianz schmiedet der westlichen Identität gegen das, was aus dem Osten kommt und das ist besonders China als das Feindbild und da würde ich sagen, kann Alexander Karb nur zustimmen. Karb sagt ja an einer Stelle, dann schon im zweiten Kapitel, obwohl es derzeit in Mode ist zu behaupten, dass die Stärke unserer Ideen und Ideale im Westen unweigerlich zum Sieg über unsere Gegner führen wird, gibt es Zeiten, in denen dem Diskurs Widerstand, sogar bewaffneter Widerstand, vorausgehen muss. Unser gesamter Verteidigungsapparat und militärischer Beschaffungskomplex wurden aufgebaut, um Soldaten für eine Art von Krieg auszubilden, auf großen Schlachtfeldern und mit Zusammenstößen von Menschenmassen, die vielleicht nie wieder geführt werden. Diese nächste Ära der Konflikte wird mit Software gewonnen und oder verloren werden.
Dieses zweite Kapitel steht ja unter einem besonderen Diktum. Er sagt ganz viel Software, keine Sünde. Die Moral wird erstmal ausgeschaltet. Es beginnt ganz sanft mit diesem Oppenheimer. Also wir kennen jetzt durch den Film, wissen wir ja genau, worum es da geht. Percy Williams, Bridgeman ist ein Schüler Oppenheimers in Harbert. Oder? Der Oppenheimer als Undergrader. Genau, also Oppenheimer war sein Lehrer, der dann später sagt, Wissenschaftler sind nicht verantwortlich für die Fakten, die in der Natur existieren. Es ist ihre Aufgabe, die Fakten zu finden. Es gibt keine Sünde, die damit verbunden ist, keine Moral. So, man spricht sich schon mal frei. Listen to the science. Es gibt hier weiter keine Dimension, die man beachten muss. So, das ist natürlich jetzt für Karp wieder so ein, ja ja, in diesen Geschichtesteil greife ich mal rein, diese Argumentation brauche ich, dass da die Leute, die eine Atombombe abgeworfen haben, dann Universitätslehrer wurden, Schüler hatten, die sagten, der Oppenheimer konnte gar nichts dafür, die Atomphysik ist halt wie sie ist. Und dann gab es ein staatliches Programm, das gesagt hat, ich habe die Atomwaffe geworfen. Das ist ja auch eine wichtige Szene im Film, dass der Präsident sagt, du hast die Waffe nicht geworfen, ich habe sie geworfen, du hast sie nur gebaut. So, also die Wissenschaft ist entschuldigt, hier gibt es keine Moral und damit ist gemeint, es ist nicht unmoralisch diese Wissenschaft, sondern sie ist amoral. Also die ganze Kategorie gibt es einfach gar nicht, damit ist natürlich der Weg frei, und dass man aus der Oppenheimer Atombombe einen Bogenschlag zur LLM, heutige KI-Zeit hat, das haben wir ja auch schon begleitet, das wurde ja immer wieder thematisiert, diesen Bogenschlag nimmt er natürlich gerne mit und sagt dann auch, und wenn es so kommt, dass wir hier Sprachmodelle haben, die so viele Synapsen haben wie das menschliche Gehirn, also 100 Billionen, dann haben wir halt ein menschliches Gehirn gebaut, wenn wir es noch größer bauen, ist es noch größer, es ist halt wie es ist. Das ist die Physik, das ist die Biologie, sie macht, was sie macht, wir bauen sie nur. Und das ist natürlich dafür, dass hier dann tatsächlich die Menschheit einfach überragt wird. Er kommt natürlich auch und da muss man sagen, so langsam ist man auch gelangweilt nochmal auf diesen Le Moin von Google zu sprechen, der dieses Gespräch hatte mit der KI. Ja, das finde ich auch bestaunlich. Und dann sagt Google, wir kündigen dich, weil du dem schon wieder diese Sentimentalitäten unterstellt hast. Und Kevin Drews Chat mit Microsoft Bing, heirate mich, nein, ich habe schon eine Frau. Ach komm, ich bin viel besser und so. Also das ist ja auch.
Also das finde ich jetzt auch ein bisschen...
Kitschig fast.
Ja, kitschig und auch lame, dass man jetzt, wo man ja doch bessere Beispiele vorziehen könnte, um zu zeigen, wie toll KI funktioniert, nochmal diese alten Hüte präsentiert und damit beweisen möchte, dass die KI eigentlich schon fast ein Bewusstsein hat, wir das nur noch nicht so richtig gecheckt haben. Das stimmt ja so nicht. Aber man kann ja auch feststellen, dass KAB davon ausgeht, AGI kommt auf jeden Fall. Also das ist ja das große Versprechen und daran hält er auch fest. Ich finde dann aber erstaunlich, dass er das nicht so zusammenkriegt. Und dann sieht man auch immer, dass diese Leute dann doch mit Wirklichkeit nur noch wenig zu tun haben, dass wenn gesagt wird, KI hat dann diese Kriege zu führen oder es sind KI-Kriege, als ein ist dann nicht mehr Menschen, die davon betroffen sind. Denn es war ja Yuval Noah Harari, der jetzt in den vergangenen Monaten immer wieder darauf hingewiesen hat, dass der Krieg in Gaza natürlich ein Hightech-Krieg ist. Und die Software bereits Entscheidungen trifft darüber, wer wird getötet. Also dass diese palästinensischen Opfer Opfer der KI sind, das sind Menschen, das sind nicht einfach zwei KIs stehen sich gegenüber oder so, sondern die KI richtet sich gegen Menschen. Das ist etwas, was hier völlig ausgeblendet wird. Das ist alles so dann vielleicht Kollateralschaden.
Also er macht das natürlich clever als Autor, denn er beginnt da mit Oppenheimer, der Atombombe, um dann zu sagen, der Atombombe war die Waffe des letzten Jahrhunderts, jetzt ist es KI. Wir müssen, er sagt dann der Bau der nächsten Generation von KI-Waffen, also er sagt KI-Waffen, so das steht so im Text. Und dann kommt natürlich sein besonderer Kniff, dass er wieder über den Abschreibungsmodus kommt. Also Thomas Schelling hat damals dieses, als Wirtschaftswissenschaftler von Yale und später Harvard, muss natürlich dazu gesagt werden, das sind die Eliten des Denkens, um Zwang auszuüben, muss Gewalt erwartet werden. Sehr klug Ersatz. Braucht man eigentlich nicht die großen Akademiker, sondern mehr so die politischen Realisten, also hier gerade der Hyperrealismus, den es jetzt gibt, der uns das sagt, die Macht zu verletzen ist Verhandlungsmacht. Sie auszunutzen ist Diplomatie. Böse Diplomatie, aber Diplomatie. Nun läuft ja dieser Diskurs, wie du sagtest, ganz anders. Denn eine Atomwaffe kann man als Drohmacht benutzen, weil man kann sie entweder nur einsetzen oder nicht. Man kann sie nicht so halbeinsetzen oder klein einsetzen oder sonstiges. Das ist natürlich bei diesen KI-Waffen ganz anders. Da ist einfach ein Schwarm von Drohnen und die sind halt auf dem Feld eingesetzt. Also hier ist nichts mit Drohmacht. Hier gibt es vielleicht noch ein Kräftegleichgewicht. Ja. So, aber nur weil beide Seiten jetzt KI-Waffen haben und er sagt ja später, die kinetischen Mittel der letzten Kriege, Panzer, Flugzeuge und so weiter sind nur noch das Arsenal der Software. So, also der Verkörperung der Software. So, die werden natürlich eingesetzt. Die verbleiben ja nicht als Drohmacht wie eine Atombombe im Bunker. Und dann sagt man so bei der Verhandlung übrigens da hinten stehen sie, sondern...
Nee, sie werden ja viel leichter eingesetzt, weil sie auch dann ja nicht mehr teuer sind. Also was wir ja gerade beim Krieg in der Ukraine beobachten können, und zwar auf beiden Seiten, ist ja eine Verkleinerung und eine Verbilligung des Krieges. Also der Krieg ist zwar wahnsinnig teuer, aber natürlich hat man ganz viele Waffen plötzlich entwickelt, die sehr viel günstiger sind, beziehungsweise haben die Russen ja erst mal so ganz baff dargestanden und waren erstaunt darüber, dass man einen Panzer, der 6 Millionen kostet, mit einer Drohne, die 10.000 kostet, zerstören kann und ähnliches. Das heißt also, was ja die Ukrainer in Innovation dann auch reingebracht haben in den Krieg, ist ja von den Russen dann wieder sehr schnell noch aufgeholt worden und dann gibt es eben einen Wettbewerb darum, wer hat jetzt die tollste Software oder das bestfliegende Produkt. Aber es ist ja keineswegs so, dass die jetzt sich gegenüberstehen und sagen, ach so, jetzt haben wir ja beide so Software und alles. Dann lassen wir es ja erst mal über.
Stattdessen werden wir ja sehen, dass der Krieg sogar vom Kampfort weg und dann fällt halt einfach mal in der Stadt so die Wasserversorgung aus oder so was. Das ist plötzlich eine Kriegshandlung.
Du hast es ja beschrieben jetzt U-Boote, dann hängen wir irgendwie an die Ostsee, da können wir dich umfallen im südchinesischen Meer. Aber was ist eigentlich mit den Mini-U-Booten, die unbemannt sind, die durch den Main schwimmen können?
Doch, der Main einfach so ein Ding auf und pustet so eine Dampfwolke hoch. Jeder sieht es und fragt sich, was ist das jetzt? So ist das jetzt eine Kriegshandlung oder nicht? Ist das giftig oder nicht? Also das sind ja diese kleinen Sachen, also von dieser mega bedrohenden Atombombe ist ja hier gar nicht mehr zu reden.
Was dann ja auch bedeutet, für Palantir gibt es überall was zu tun. Also du musst eigentlich alles, sowohl dein Eigenheim wie jeder öffentliche Platz, alles muss eigentlich durchsetzt sein von Überwachung, Gesichtserkennung etc. Weil diese Mikrokriegsführung überall ist, das bedeutet auch die Mikroüberwachung muss überall sein. Also Palantir hat ja hier natürlich auch so eine Schrift verfasst für künftige Investoren, Aktionäre etc. Sagen wir sind für alles dann gerüstet, was kommt bzw. passen uns an.
Palantir ist der Hammer und jetzt muss man sich einen Nagel dabei schreiben. So, Thematisierung von Deutschland. Wir sind noch lange nicht bei Martin Walzer, sondern bei Günter Krass.
Genau, der kommt ja auch noch vor.
Also es ist sehr witzig, aber er kommt auf natürlich den Autor an der Blechdromel zu sprechen. Das Land, in welchem Kontext hat er das denn hier gemacht? Das war ein Widerstand gegen weitere militärische Invention ist natürlich besonders in Deutschland weiter verbreitet. Ach so, weil Günter Krass, der Romanautor.
Krass war ja sogar, das wird hier nochmal angeführt, Krass war ja gegen die Wiedervereinigung, weil er sagte, so ein erstarktes Deutschland, und das war ja durchaus eine Position, die man bei vielen Ehrlingen, intellektuellen antreffen konnte, sei eine große Gefahr. Wir haben ja schon einmal gesehen, das macht ein zweites Ausschwitz möglich.
Soweit hat das getrieben in der Argumentation.
Und da sagt er, das sei also sehr typisch für die Denkweise auch der linken Intellektuellen, dass sie nicht mehr groß denken wollen und sich lieber verzwergen möchten.
Genau. Nichts, Günter Krass 1991. Nichts, kein Nationalgefühl. Wie idyllisch auch immer gefärbt. Und keine Zusicherung spätgeborener Wohl-, spätgeborener, was? Keine Zusicherung spätgeborener Wohlwollens kann die Erfahrung, die wir als die Verbrecher mit unseren Opfern als ein Verein des Deutschland hatten, modifizieren oder zerstreuen. Okay, das wurde jetzt einmal auf Deutsch und wieder auf Englisch übersetzt, aber Günter Krass wetterte gegen das Nationalgefühl, das erst recht aufkommt, wenn man wiedervereinigt.
Das war 1991. Krass hat ja dann durchaus nachher auch gesehen, dass die Wiedervereinigung eine sinnvolle Sache war, aber wovor er gewarnt hat und ich finde, dafür hat er auch sehr zurecht vorgewarnt, ist so ein wieder erstarkenes Nationalgefühl und das kann noch so heiter sein, das führt am Ende zu nichts Gutem. Und dem setzt sich Karp natürlich jetzt in den Weg und sagt, nee, also Nationalgefühl brauchen wir.
Und da liegt noch ein Traum drauf, denn er verbindet diese Neutralisierung des Landes, des Staates mit und nur deswegen, weil wir uns, der Rückzug des muskulösen und selbstbewussten Deutschlands führt er dazu, dass Putin gesagt hat, na dann kann er ja die Ukraine angreifen. Ja.
Und das natürlich völliger Blödsinn, das hat ja gar nichts damit zu tun.
Also sehr interessantes Kapitel von dieser Atombomben, das Manhattan-Projekt und jetzt brauchen wir wieder einen Staat und die neuen KI-Waffen, die die alte Drohne macht, der Nuklearzeit alles aktualisiert und so weiter und so fort um, und das ist eigentlich witzig, weil wir haben jetzt schon kritisiert, er kommt gar nicht auf den strategischen und sehr viel weitreichenderen Einsatz von diesen neuen KI-Waffen zu sprechen, sondern betont dann eben einfach die Flugzeugträger und Kampfjets, die die Kriegsführung in der letzten Ära definierten, werden zu Zubehör für Software. Software ist im Vergleich zur Atomwaffe nun wirklich eine ganz virtuelle Sache. Also für eine Atomwaffe brauche ich einen Bunker und eine Doktrin und Leute, die sich damit auskennen, um KI-Software herzustellen. Also das kann ich im Zug auf meinem Tablet programmieren. Das ist einfach überall und mit anderen Dimensionen.
Da geht es nur um die Rechenzentren dann am Ende, die muss man besitzen und die werden ja überall errichtet.
Rechenzentren brauchst du nicht unbedingt. Also DeepSeek, dieses chinesische Modell, zeichnet sich ja gerade dadurch aus, dass es nicht nur leicht war das zu trainieren, also kostengünstig, sondern du kannst das ganze KI-Gehirn, das ganze Modell einfach auf deinen privaten Rechner runterladen und ohne Internetverbindung Fragen daran stellen, weil das auf normaler handelsüblicher Computertechnik läuft. Und auch die Open AI und Cloud Modelle sind ja nun nicht, die laufen aus Performance Gründen in der Cloud, wie so vieles auf der Cloud läuft, aber die könnte man auch, die werden ja nicht zum Download angeboten, bei den Facebooks Dinger schon, aber im Grunde kannst du das überall. Also dieses, wir lesen nachher diesen Text, Kevin Reuss programmiert jetzt zu Hause für sich alleine, das kann er auch ohne Rechenzentrum, ohne Internet und so weiter. Dafür braucht er wirklich nur einen etwas leistungssteileren Computer und dann könnte er alles machen. Und wenn dann Elon Musk kommt und sagt bei Croc, ich gebe hier keine Limitierung mit, dann sitzt halt jemand da und programmiert KI-Waffen damit und stellt gleichzeitig noch ein Gift her. Einfach nur auf seinem eigenen Computer. Und damit sind wir ganz weit weg von Atomwaffen. Also da gibt es keinen prinzipiellen Vergleich. Und der bietet sich auch nicht an, weil ein Jahrhundert mal Atomwaffen war und jetzt ein anderes Jahrhundert ist, also brauchen wir was Neues, KI.
Dieser Atomwaffen-Vergleich, der wird ja seit wir diesen KI-Boom haben die ganze Zeit gebracht, der ist nur damit begründbar, weil die Leute davon ausgehen, dass irgendjemand als erstes AGI hat, das heißt also die KI, die so übermächtig ist, dass sie den Menschen übertrumpft, ein eigenes Bewusstsein hat, sich selbst dann so optimieren kann, dass sie sich völlig loslöst von allen anderen KI's und dann möglicherweise die Weltherrschaft oder was weiß ich an sich reißt. Da wird dann gesagt, dass es dann dieser Oppenheimer-Moment, der da entstehen kann. Aber das ist ja eine Prämisse, die ich schon an sich nicht teilen würde mit AGI. Aber sonst ist das wirklich völlig hirnrissig, denn das ist ja gerade das Problem all der Staaten, die gerne auch eine Atomwaffe haben möchten und aber Schurkenstafen oder was weiß ich sind, dass sie nicht so einfach das produzieren können. Und jetzt mit der KI sieht es natürlich anders aus.
Ist allenfalls intuitiv plausibel, aber trägt nirgendwohin dieser Quatsch. Im nächsten Kapitel wird es genauso holprig.
Du bist jetzt bei Kapitel 3, ja?
Nein, Kapitel 4 ist ja Ende des Atomwaffenzeitalters. Und dann kommt zum ersten Mal hier David Graeber, der ja schon gefragt hat, wo ist denn hier mein ganzer Kram und so. Und jetzt haben wir dieses Zeitalter, in dem wir GPT haben, die eben sagen, okay, wir machen nicht nur die nächste Consumer-Elektronik, dass wieder der nächste David Graeber sagen kann, wo ist denn jetzt mein fliegendes Auto, sondern die militärischen und Kriegszwecke für die eigene Technologie sind jetzt auch bei OpenAI. Seit Anfang 2024, wie er schreibt, wurde dieser Kurs geändert. Möglich. Und dann kommt ein Lobgesang auf Elon Musk. Denn Elon Musk verkörpert nun vieles von dem, was er will. Und ich frage mich vielleicht nicht die aktuelle politische Praxis. Denn hier, der Lobgesang bezieht sich natürlich darauf, dass Elon Musk zum Eigen gesagt hat, ich baue nicht nur Software, sondern auch kinetisch ein Auto, Raketen.
Hardware.
Hardware, genau. Atome, Hardware. Für mich ist die Software Mittel zum Zweck.
Und dass jemand noch groß denkt. Die anderen haben ihn verlacht, er will zum Mars, er will Raketen. Aber genau das sei eigentlich das richtige Programm, dem sich jetzt alle unterordnen sollten.
Und damit ist er in die Innovationslücke gesprungen, die der Staat gelassen hat.
Ja und Peter Thiel träumt ja, wird dann hier auch erwähnt, ohnehin von einem neuen Apollo-Programm. Und Elon Musk ist quasi der Vorreiter eines solchen Programms.
Genau, Peter Thiel wird nämlich dann gleich als nächstes genannt. Und dann als nächstes kommt Xi. Wir haben ja so einen Kapitel, das von ein Bogenspann von Elon Musk zu Peter Thiel zu Xi, dem chinesischen Präsidenten.
Und zwischendurch bekommt noch Mark Zuckerberg eins mit, da heißt es nämlich, ja und Instagram und YouTube, was haben die gemacht? Die haben ihr Geld damit verdient, dass sie Werbung an Kinder ausspielen. Das wird noch gerade so reingesetzt als Argument und dann kommt Xi als der große Visionär.
Xi, der ganz große Visionär, der eben auch Macht in einer Weise ausübt und behalten hat, also erfolgreich ausgeübt hat, die die meisten unserer gegenwärtigen politischen Führer im Westen nie verstehen werden. Sie kriegen es ja gerade vorgeführt. Nur, wie ich schon anmerkte, so richtig erfolgreich ist das gerade nicht, was Amerika zeigt. Also China hat ja hunderte Millionen Menschen aus der Armut in die Mittelschicht geholt. Diese Leute haben sich urbanisiert. Sie arbeiten 350 Tage im Jahr, um dann sechs Tage irgendwie frei zu haben, von denen sie zwei Tage noch in den Zügen sitzen, weil sie 500 Kilometer weit reisen müssen und der ganze Kram. Das ist eine Erfolgsgeschichte. Das, was wir jetzt gerade bei Trump sehen, der Xi und so weiter nacheifert, keine Erfolgsgeschichte. Eint weder das Land noch stellt es wirtschaftliche Leistungsfähigkeit her, noch bringt es den Staat in eine Handlungsmöglichkeit, die er vorher nicht hatte. Das ist einfach in allen wichtigen Dimensionen ist das ein Abbau, in der Hinsicht wird dieses Kapitel nicht gut altern. Also weder das über Masks der Lob gesangen, als noch das über Shis macht.
Er zitiert dann zustimmend einen Applebaum, die vor diesen autoritären Regimen warnt und da muss man also dem jetzt was entgegensetzen. Kissinger habe das auch schon so gesehen, der wird dann auch nochmal angeführt. Und was soll man dem jetzt entgegensetzen? Naja, das ist am Anfang des Kapitels dann zu lesen. Da heißt es nämlich, dass Deutschland nur noch die Karikatur einer Armee habe und dass sowohl Deutschland als auch Japan, das heißt vor allem ihre politischen Führer, sollen die Bevölkerung darauf einspüren, kämpfen zu wollen. Also es zu wollen, das was wir eben im Presseklub auch gehört haben. Ja, wir müssen mal sehen, wie gehen wir da mit unseren 17-Jährigen um. Das ist also etwas, was hier ganz klar das Programm ist, dass man sich nämlich, es geht immer darum, dass man sich diesem Kollektiv unterordnet. Und das ist ja interessant, wenn man jetzt von links da draufblickt, ja, also mit so einem sozialistischen demokratischen Sozialismus, ob das jetzt Bernie Sanders ist oder was sich jetzt hier so bei der Linkspartei tut, dann ist ja immer die Neoliberalismus-Kritik folgende. Der Neoliberalismus singularisiert die Leute, individualisiert soweit, dass nicht mehr an Gemeinsinn oder irgendetwas gedacht wird. Und das ist ja eine Kritik, die wir absolut teilen. Wir haben ja bei Horst und Hopf schon darauf hingewiesen, wie sehr das eigentlich nur darauf hinausläuft, dass du dich selbst retten kannst und vielleicht auch deine Familie und sonst das Schluss. Und in gewisser Weise knüpft jetzt Karp an diese Kritik an, aber nicht in dem Sinne, dass er sagt und so schaffen wir dann eine solidarischere Gemeinschaft, in der nicht Kinder in Armut leben müssen und und und, sondern worum es ihm geht, ist diesen Individualismus hinter sich zu lassen, um sich einem nationalen Kollektiv anzuschließen, das wehrhaft ist gegen irgendwelche Feinde, die die dann noch da ausmachen für sich und ein Kollektiv, das bereit ist zu verzichten und sich einer totalen Überwachung zu unterwerfen, weil es ja nur in ihrem Sinne ist und damit die Leute auch wirklich bereit sind zu kämpfen und das zu wollen, brauchen sie wieder eine große Erzählung und brauchen sie auch den Mythos. Denn die Linken, die Intellektuellen, die Silicon Valley Milliardäre, die Influencer, die hatten keinen Mythos mehr, die kannten nur noch das Ich. Wir müssen also wieder die große Erzählung wagen und die meint natürlich eine große imperialistische westliche Erfolgserzählung.
Genau. So und jetzt ist wahnsinnig interessant, dass damit Part 1 dieses Buches abgeschlossen ist und dann beginnt Part 2. So, jetzt hast du ja schon gesagt, okay, das Publikum wird, also dem wird so ein neuer Mythos vorangestellt, die sollen jetzt wieder kämpfen wollen. Wer es ein bisschen höher schafft, sollte diese Annehmlichkeiten ablehnen und seine Programmierdienste, das soll es eigentlich höchst bietend, sondern dem Staat und der KI-Waffe zur Verfügung stellen. Und jetzt dieses, dieser zweite Part des Buches beginnt mit einer ganz interessanten Kritik an den Eliten des Staates. Wer erklärt sich bereit, ein öffentliches Amt zu bekommen unter diesen Bedingungen, wie wir sie heute haben, die ja alle kritisiert? Die Transparenzanforderungen sind pervers. Leute sollen die ganze Zeit erklären, wie viel Steuern sie gezahlt haben, mit welchen Frauen oder Männern sie verkehren und wie auch immer. Also alles muss disclosed werden. Und dann sagt er, das funktioniert so nicht. Also wir brauchen hier und das ist ja die DI-Logik, also wir wollen ja nicht mehr das Migrationshintergrund und Geschlecht in Rolle, sondern nur noch die Meritokratie, also nur noch das Leistungsprinzip. Wir brauchen einfach die Besten, ganz egal was mit denen ist. Und dafür opfert er einfach so ein ganzes Kapitel. Um jetzt darzustellen, Richard Nixon musste 1952 erklären, öffentlich, dass er ein Haus besitzt, das 13.000 Dollar kostet, auf dem er eine Hypothek von 3.000 Dollar hat, dann hat ihm seine Ehefrau gefragt, wieso müssen wir solche Details öffentlich klären? Und dann sagt Karp, ja genau, also wieso müssen wir das eigentlich öffentlich klären? Das bringt uns doch nur dahin, dass die Leute, die wir da brauchen in diesen Posten, dieses Transparenzspektakel nicht mitmachen wollen und deswegen für die öffentlichen Ämter nicht zur Verfügung stehen. Und um das dann theoretisch zu untermauern, bringt er uns Irving Goffmans totale Institution. Ich bin ja ganz froh, dass er dich noch das Panoptikum untergebracht hat und wir nochmal und so.
Ich hab damit eigentlich gerechnet, ja.
Aber das geht wirklich zu weit. Also das ist einfach dumm. Dieser Textteil ist einfach stront dumm.
Aber bleiben wir mal ganz kurz bei diesem Argument. Es ist ja tatsächlich so, dass wer jetzt in die Politik gehen will, durchleuchtet wird von oben bis unten. Das ist ja nicht angenehm. Und jetzt ist ja die Frage, wird damit jemand ausgeschlossen, der eigentlich sehr qualifiziert wäre, der nur sagt, dieses Spektakel tu ich mir nicht an. Die Frage ist aber, sind nicht vielleicht die fähigeren Leute in den Ministerien, also in der zweiten Reihe nicht in der Öffentlichkeit, und die werden ja nicht in dieser Weise durchleuchtet, wie er das beschreibt. Also die öffentlichen Kandidaten, das stimmt, werden von vorne bis hinten durchleuchtet. Und wenn jetzt jemand aus der Linkspartei mit dem Mercedes vorfahren würde, wäre sicher, dass das morgen in der Bild-Zeitung ist. Dann würde man sagen, seht her, so sind sie und und und. Ja und dann muss man sich lieber arm rechnen, ehemann irgendwas. Das ist ja in der Tat so. Ja, aber jetzt wird aber der der der der der der Fehlschluss, der jetzt hier aber gemacht wird und das ist das Interessante ist, die, die moralisch so richtig daneben langen, wie Trump, ja die, das sind doch eigentlich die Fähigen. Jemand, der Geld verdient, der der protzt und so. Das sind die eigentlich tollen Typen.
Genau.
Und das ist und das ist genau der Fehlschluss, der da ist. Ich glaube auch, dass manche Leute von der Politik aus solchen Gründen abgeschreckt sind, dass sie sagen, ich habe keinen. Aber das ist, glaube ich, dann generell die Frage, ist man der Politiker-Typus? Ist man jemand, der gerne jeden Tag Statements in der Öffentlichkeit abgeben will? Das also erbringt ja auch das Thema Gehälter oder so noch auf dem Punkt. Man kann natürlich, also wenn man jetzt, also ich bin jetzt niemand, der sagt, die Politiker verdienen alle zu wenig. Ich bin aber auch niemand, der sagt, die werden aber so zugestopft mit Geld. Das ist auch nicht richtig. Also wir haben ja einen interessanten Punkt doch, wenn wir sehen, jemand geht in die Politik, dann muss er sich Wahlen aussetzen, muss sich Parteigezänk aussetzen, muss sich in der Öffentlichkeit aussetzen und dann bekommt er 10 oder 20.000 im Monat je nach Posten. Das ist natürlich viel Geld, wenn man auf die Durchschnittsdöne blickt, wenn man aber sich denkt, als Zahnarzt kann ich eher noch mehr verdienen, habe aber ein durchaus geruhsameres Leben, würde ich, wenn du mich jetzt fragst, doch eher sagen, ich würde gern Zahnarzt werden.
Also ich widerspreche all dem, was der Karp hier schreibt, grundsätzlich und vollständig und ich gebe da auch nicht, aber da hat er einen Punkt oder so. Sondern die Politik ist einfach nicht die Wirtschaft. Wir haben eine moderne, funktionale Differenzierung zwischen diesen beiden Feldern. Ein deutscher Bundeskanzler zum Beispiel kriegt 400.000 Euro, aber darüber hinaus Annehmlichkeiten, die in Millionen werden, gemessen werden. Ein wahnsinnig interessantes Leben, ständige Bewirtung, Transportation, Information, es mangelt ihm an nichts. Das Haus hat 4,5 Milliarden Budget. Wenn er etwas will, schnippst er mit dem Finger und zack, gibt es eine Gesundheitsministerkonferenz mit den Amtskredillieren seines eigenen aus 60 Ländern in seinem Foyer. Diese Fragen, ob hier nochmal Jolte eine andere Entscheidung getroffen hätte, wenn man ihm 800.000 statt 400.000 im Jahr bewiesen hätte, ist völlig Nonsens.
Nee, glaub ich auch nicht.
Donald Trump selbst, Elon Musk, die sind ganz stolz darauf, dass sie natürlich gerade kein Geld verdienen. Dass sie sich nicht bezahlen lassen.
Ich weiß es nämlich auch nicht, ich wollte nur nochmal deutlich machen, man kann natürlich über Gehälter reden von Politikern und kann jetzt erstmal sagen, es ist nicht das luxuriöseste Leben überhaupt, das man haben kann, wenn man jetzt Politiker ist.
Ja, aber wenn man grundsätzlich ein luxuriöser ist...
Bei manchen würde ich aber auch sagen, in der freien Wirtschaft würden sie definitiv weniger verdienen.
Also das politische Leben bringt dir, wenn es erfolgreich verläuft, Macht. Ja. Das heißt aber noch lange nicht, dass diejenigen, die in unserer westlichen Welt Macht über diese Art erringen, auf ihre anderen Annehmlichkeiten plötzlich verzichten müssen. Niemand hat Donald Trump gesagt, ab jetzt musst du dein Unternehmen verkaufen und darfst auch keine Dogecoins im Amt oder sowas verkaufen, weil du bist ja als Präsident. Nein, das macht natürlich alles weiter. Wenn du ein Bundestagsmandat erringst...
Kubecki an.
Genau, da gibt es einfach eine Abstufung aus fünf Dingern, wo man sagt, wie sind denn ihre Lebensverdienste zwischen 0 und 10.000, zwischen 10 und 20.000 oder über 20.000. Da kreuzst du einfach an über 20.000 fertig. Und danach wird nie wieder danach gefragt, wie er das Geld verdient oder was auch immer. Das sind dann journalistische, dass man mal so, okay, wir gehen mal durch, was er so macht. Aber die Bundestagsverwaltung will dann nichts sehen. Die will einfach nur einen Haken sehen bei, ah ja, sie verdienen mehr als 30.000. Ja, okay, so. Dann ist es auch nach oben offen. Und so gilt das eigentlich für alle. Und wenn man dann mal vom Mandat zum Amt drüber wechselt, ein Staatssekretär wird, muss man halt für sich eine biografische Entscheidung treffen, ob man dieses und für manche ist das ja wichtigerer Luxus als ein materieller, wenn sie die ganze Zeit gefragt werden, ständig in der Aufmerksamkeit stehen, große Schicksalsfragen für sich und sehr viele Menschen treffen können und so weiter. Und da wird es immer genug geben, die das können und das wollen und das können und wollen, sich um diese Ämter bewerben und so weiter. Ich sehe jedenfalls nicht, dass wir gerade unsere Politiker ins Amt prügeln müssen, weil leider keiner will.
Nee, seine These ist ja, dass viele Leute potentiell in der Politik eine Rolle spielen könnten, aber sie tun es nicht, weil diese Hürden da sind. Ich würde sagen, ja das mag sein, dass manche Leute sagen, ich hab jetzt hier einen Job, der bringt mir viel mehr ein und den kann ich nicht parallel machen. Also man wird jetzt nicht Chefarzt sein können und gleichermaßen im Bundestag den Zampano spielen können. Das geht einfach nicht. Bei anderen Sachen wie Anwalt oder so, da scheint mehr möglich zu sein über eine Kanzlei, die man dann hat und dann lässt man auch andere mehr für sich arbeiten. Alles gut und schön. Er sagt, da bleiben welche draußen. Dann würde ich sagen, ja generell stimmt das. Aber das stimmt auch sowieso, weil viele Leute, die sicherlich tolle Ideen hätten für irgendetwas, zum Beispiel für die deutsche Infrastruktur, nicht da drin sind, weil das einfach nicht ihr Ding ist, in der Öffentlichkeit zu stehen und sich abends in der Talkshow zu zanken und morgens vom Bundestag noch mal eine Rede zu halten. Und deswegen sind sie nicht da. Also das ist einfach unsinnig. Was ich aber auch glaube, ist, dass er so tut, als seien das so Leute, die jetzt in der Politik sind. Und das ist natürlich diese Kritik am Beamtentum, die man bei Elon Musk natürlich in gleicher Weise finden kann, als seien das irgendwie Leute, die noch so ein Salär vom Staat brauchen, um über die Runden zu kommen. Und da würde ich sagen, da sehen wir ja bei sehr vielen Beispielen. Du hast jetzt eben die Prominenten aus den USA genannt. Wir können es aber auch in Deutschland sehen, dass da ja viele sind, die jenseits der 100 sind und trotzdem noch antreten für den Bundestag, die wirklich kein Geld brauchen und auch nicht wissen wohin damit und trotzdem sagen, ich will das aber machen, weil ich davon überzeugt bin, dass ich für das Land das Beste bin oder dass das für mich das Beste ist.
Genau. Und an dieser Stelle ist dieses Buch ganz dumm. Ich will es mal konkretisieren. Also die totale Institution von Erwin Goffman, die er hier als Erklärungsfolie anführt und da hört man ja schon am Namen. Totale Institution, ja da will man nicht hin. Also man hätte gern so ein bisschen Freiheit. So die totale Institution, wie er sie hier beschreibt. Also Orte, wo eine große Anzahl ähnlich situierter Individuen, abgeschnitten von der weiteren Gesellschaft, für eine beträchtliche Zeitspanne gemeinsam ein geschlossenes, formal verwaltetes Leben führen. Totale Institution bei Goffman sind geschlossene Heilanstalt für psychisch Kranke. Gefängnisse und so. Nicht der Bundestag, wo man auch mal eine Frage bekommt zu irgendwas und so. Und besonders witzig finde ich, dass er hier auf wir brauchen das meritokratische System und welchen Autor nimmt er sich, um uns vorzustellen, wie das meritokratische System ist und wie wir es nutzen sollten?
Michael Zendel, der gegen das meritokratische Prinzip ist.
Das ist doch absurd, einen Text so zu bauen.
Die sind nicht in der Lage, die Texte zu lesen.
Ich hatte einfach KI, Schlagwortmäßig Michael Zendel, Meritokratie und dann auf Seite 17 hat das beschrieben, dass die anderen 300 Seiten des Buches eine Abklärung von diesem meritokratischen System sind. Hat er einfach ausgeblendet.
Also wenn man eine Kritik lesen will an der Meritokratie, dann findet man bei Michael Zendel etwas. Kein Plädoyer.
Also Habermas und das Führerprinzip und Michael Zendel, der uns die Meritokratie verkauft bei Alex Karp, ja?
Es ist einfach Unsinn. Aber wahrscheinlich wird uns bald Ursprachschat erzählen, dass Alexander Karp einer der genialsten Denker unserer Zeit ist.
Und von wem er dann diesen Arbeitsauftrag bekommen hat, das wissen wir dann auch.
Und das ist ja so erstaunlich, dass man sich nicht schämt, das zu schreiben. Also du hast ja eben so gesagt, bei Trump ist diese Blödheit ja so offen und man weiß gar nicht, ist das gut oder schlecht, dass er so blöd ist.
Blutblödheit.
Und das ist ja hier interessant, das ist so eine gewitzte Blödheit, die hier auftritt. Und auch nochmal so diese politische Ausrichtung wird einem dann klar, wenn es um Anpassungsweisen geht, an die Konformität, also das ist ja eben seine Kritik auch daran, nicht einfach nur die Falschen regieren oder haben wichtige Positionen im Staate, zum Beispiel Universitätspräsidenten, sondern sie sind auch so furchtbar angepasst, dann bringt er da als Beispiel nur die Uni-Präsidenten, die da angesprochen wurden auf die pro-malestinensischen Proteste. Generell ist für ihn ja so, dass alles, was da irgendwie an Kritik, an israelische Regierung kommt, für ihn falsch ist. Und da tut er so als seien das die Angepassten. Also er stellt sich wirklich auf die Seite der israelischen Staatsmacht und der amerikanischen Staatsmacht und glaubt, er sei damit der Nonkonforme. Dabei ist er ja die ganze Zeit einer, der hinter dem militärischen Apparat sogar von beiden Seiten, von beiden Ländern steht. Dass er das immer noch als Nonkonformismus verkaufen kann, ist ja verrückt. Aber das fügt sich dann ein in diese Idee von Eliten, die eigentlich an einem großen Projekt arbeiten müssen. Und da kommt die Religion ins Spiel. Er spricht ja dann über die technologischen Agnostika in Kapitel 6. Da sagt er, das sei das Problem, die seien nicht fest im Glauben diese Leute im Silicon Valley. Er sagt, es mag in der heutigen Kultur selbstverständlich sein, dass alle Ansichten toleriert werden sollten. Aber wir müssen zugeben, dass selbst der leiseste Hauch von tatsächlicher Religion in bestimmten Kreisen der unironische Glaube an etwas Größeres in vielen Vorstandsetagen von Unternehmen und sicherlich in den Hallen unserer selektivsten Colleges und Universitäten als im Wesentlichen vorindustriell und rückständig angesehen wird. Dieser Wandel vollzieht sich seit Jahrzehnten. Die Intoleranz der Elite gegenüber religiösen Überzeugungen ist vielleicht eines der aussagekräftigsten Anzeichen dafür, dass ihr politisches Projekt eine weniger offene intellektuelle Bewegung darstellt, als viele in ihr behaupten würden. Und da würde ich sagen, ja aber der Glaube wird doch überall im amerikanischen Wahlkampf groß thematisiert, ist doch tatsächlich für viele ein sehr wichtiger Bestandteil. Also hat man den Eindruck, dass wir den großen Rückzug der Religionen beobachten? Im Gegenteil, wir haben doch auch eine Aussprache für mehr Religion. Wir haben einen engen Zusammenschuss zum Beispiel auch in Deutschland zwischen Kirche und Staat immer wieder. Also er spricht da über gewisse intellektuelle Kreise und bezieht sich dann darauf, dass schon Freud die Religion kritisiert hat. Wo ich denke, ja die Psychoanalyse hat auch genau diese Aufgabe, den großen anderen als eine Illusion zu entlarven. Aber worauf will der dann da hinaus? Also was er eigentlich möchte ist ein Ende des analytischen und dialektischen Denkens. Man soll eigentlich jetzt wieder danach gehen, dass die Leute, und da sagt er ja People are local, dass die ihren Glauben haben. Und dem soll man jetzt eigentlich so einen Überbau wieder schaffen. Also man soll gerade nicht zum Beispiel auch eine Religionskritik üben, sondern soll eigentlich dahin gelangen, dass man sagt, ja das ist ja ganz toll, wenn die Leute fest im Glauben stehen. Und für ihn ist das natürlich gut, weil man das natürlich dann verbinden kann mit einem politischen Projekt. Weshalb ja auch Trump diese Hinwendung getan hat zum Glauben. Und man kann das ja zum Teil jetzt auch bei der AfD, gerade auch bei Alice Weidel erleben, dass man versucht, dass man diese Leute, die religiös sind, einzufangen, denen man sich auch als religiös markiert.
Ja, er versteckt da hier noch so ein paar Sachen in diesem Kapitel über die technologischen Agnostika, den man so einen Punkt macht. Es gibt so die Prime Directive, das ist ja so ein Star Trek Begriff, die oberste Direktive. Also man landet auf irgendeinem Planeten und sagt, hier mischen wir uns nicht ein und so. Und der sagt, nein, die oberste Direktive ist gerade, wir machen Cancel Culture, niemand soll hier mit irgendwas und so weiter. Also er kritisiert ja den typischen Vokismus. Was für mich den Text ganz interessant macht, der bei hier ja auch da klar wird, wenn man aus seiner Sicht noch was Gutes an Ilinqmas Entbürokratisierung sieht, dann ist es vor allem diese Entideologisierung, die da drin steckt. Also dass es gar nicht darum geht, die Bürokratie abzubauen, sondern eine Deep-State-Ideologie, die sich da immer wieder durchsetzt, weshalb es für Trump dann so lohnenswert ist zu sagen, zuerst war ich Opposition gegen die Demokraten, dann bin ich selber Regierung geworden, und jetzt bin ich Opposition gegen die Bürokratie. Weil zuerst haben die Demokraten den Vokismus hofiert und jetzt ist es plötzlich der Staat. Also man findet immer sich selbst in dieser Oppositionsrolle wieder. Und da wir es ja hier mit einem Buch zu tun haben, das die ganze Zeit Technik mit in den Raum stellt, schreibt er hier ganz deutlich mit Bezug auf Orwell, die dystopische Zukunft, wie Orwell sie sich vorstellt, ist durchaus nah. Aber nicht weil wir einen Überwachungsstaat haben, sondern weil wir Vokismus haben.
Naja, das ist ja eine Argumentation, die jetzt bei Springer auch so.
Aber wirklich so in einem Satz. Also ich lese mal wie Kloot das auf Deutsch übersetzt hat. Die dystopische Zukunft, die Orwell und andere sich vorgestellt haben, mag nah sein, aber nicht wegen des Überwachungsstaates oder Konstruktionen, die von Silikon-Welle-Giganten gebaut werden, die uns unsere Privatsphäre oder unsere intimsten Momente allein brauben. Also dass das möglich ist, steht da durchaus zu. Wir sind es, nicht unsere technologischen Schöpfungen, die dafür verantwortlich sind, dass wir es versäumt haben, die radikalen, den radikalen Akte des Glaubens an etwas über und jenseits des Selbst zu fördern und zu ermöglichen. Die Geschwindigkeit der Begeisterung, mit der die Kultur jeden für seine wahrgenommenen Übertretungen und Fehler aufspießt, mit der wir übereinander herfallen für Abweichung von der Norm, verhindert nur weiter unsere Fähigkeit, uns der Wahrheit zu nähern. Das ist so absurd, sowas zu schreiben. Also so bescheuert. Er sagt einfach, okay, da gibt es so ein Vogue Mind Virus, den kritisiere ich jetzt inhaltlich, aber eigentlich finde ich das schon richtig, wie engagiert die Leute sind. Nur sollen sie nicht so sehr Anwaltschaft wie jemand anderen, also so alter Ego prinzipmäßig, was du mir nicht tust, tue ich dir nicht und so weiter, sondern wir sollten dieses Engagement aufgreifen und jetzt in einen neuen Staatsdienst stellen. Ja. Aber keine Angst vor Überwachungstechnologie haben. Die befördert das dann nur, dass wir alle in die gleiche Richtung gehen.
Ja.
Also er möchte sozusagen eine Denunzierungsmaschine bauen, die sozusagen im Konzert mit der, aber wir richten uns auch alle gleich aus, wir haben die gleiche Idee vom Staat, wir treten ein bisschen zurück, wir zeigen unseren Verlust und wir sortieren nur die aus, die nicht mit uns und dem Staat übereinstimmen. Ja. Das ist wirklich absurd.
Er spricht sich ja dann für eine Kanonbildung aus an der Universität, er bringt diese alte Debatte nochmal. Wir hatten das auch in Deutschland mit der Frage, brauchen wir einen Literaturkanon. Das heißt also, was müssen westliche Studenten wissen? Da muss man wieder ganz klare Pflöcke einschlagen, was wichtig ist und was unwichtig ist. Und damit ist dann auch klar, dass er den Postkolonialismus kritisiert, weil dieser ja dann die westlichen Ideale unterminiert. Und um das hier ganz deutlich zu sagen, ich finde schon, dass er in manchen Passagen einen Punkt hat, aber das bleibt nicht aus, wenn man 220 Seiten schreibt, dass irgendwo was ist. Ich habe natürlich auch während meines geisteswissenschaftlichen Studiums oder auch dann in Gesprächen in Künstlerkreisen oder so, erlebt, dass natürlich eine solche Abwehr gegenüber der, wir sagen jetzt mal der Einfachheit halber europäischen Hochkultur entstanden ist, dass ich so dachte, ja, ihr habt jetzt aber auch alles nur dekonstruiert, habt ihr auch mal vielleicht dann selbst noch mal bei Goethe nachgelesen oder bei Shakespeare. Also es war dann nur noch die Ablehnung und es gab Dokumentakuratoren, die sagten, man kann eigentlich gar kein Gemälde mehr aufhängen, das sei nur die Repräsentationslogik des Eurozentrismus fortgesetzt und so Dinge. Diese Spielereien gibt es natürlich und die habe ich immer kritisiert und werde sie auch immer kritisieren. Nur was jetzt hier passiert ist, dass er das auch kritisiert und natürlich gibt es diese Auswüchse, will aber dann einfach nur in eine andere Richtung gehen. Also mich hat das ja immer gestört an vielen Wurkenströmungen, dass das so Glaubensgemeinschaften wurden, die dann ohne ein Argument noch zu bringen einfach gewütet haben, gesagt haben, nein das geht nicht und damit setzen sie sich mal was an. Er findet, wie du das sagst, das eigentlich gut. Nur bitte in die richtige Richtung und bezieht sich dann auf Samuel Huntington, der schrieb ja nicht nur vom Kampf der Kulturen dieses Buchs, sondern er schrieb ja auch Who are we? Also er wollte da bestimmen, was ist eigentlich die westliche Identität. Und das ist etwas, was er jetzt wieder will, was die auch die Tenure-Professoren in den Mittelpunkt rücken sollen. Bislang war ihnen das er nimmt auch hier das deutsche Wort verboten, dass sie darüber noch nachdenken. Aber jetzt soll genau das wichtig sein. Also nicht länger soll auch das Primat des Ökonomischen im Mittelpunkt stehen, sondern jetzt geht es um Kultur und Identität. Und das bedeutet für ihn ganz klar, die Postmoderne muss abgewickelt werden, denn diese hat den Westen geschwächt. Und da finde ich übrigens das nur anekdotisch angeführt ganz interessant. Ich hab das so ein bisschen bei Twitter damals verfolgt, als das alles losging mit dem Kriegen der Ukraine und so. Dass also sehr viele Leute, die ich noch von der Uni kannte, die sehr auf diesem Postmodern-Trip etc. sind, die waren alle für wahnsinnige Aufrüstung, Waffenlieferung und so weiter. Das stimmt auch als Diagnose gar nicht. Also so zu tun, als seien jetzt die Postkolonialen oder sonst wie Geprägten die Gegner von Aufrüstung oder die Gegner von Militär. Schön wärs, würde ich sagen. Das ist einfach nicht der Fall.
Naja, aus seiner Sicht. Also wir können uns ja ungefähr vorstellen, wie ein Dokument da aussähe, die Alex K beauftragt, gestaltet zu werden, ja? Ja. Also da ist einfach, da wird erstmal der Staat verherrlicht und dann werden, es gibt ja diese schöne Szene von Stephen Colbert, damals noch als Sidekick von John Stewart, der Atomwaffen-Gegner da hat und sie einfach fragt, okay, okay, okay, aber würden sie nicht wenigstens einsehen, dass es total geil aussieht, wenn eine Atombombe explodiert? Und die natürlich, nee, das können wir echt nicht sagen und so. So und ich könnte mir jetzt vorstellen, Alex K der sieht sich natürlich so einen westlichen Campus an und sagt, okay, Wolfgang M. Schmidt hat gesagt, die sind ja irgendwie pro und so weiter, sehe ich einen Ansätzen. Also er würde dann so sagen, ja, da hat Wolfgang Schmidt schon so ein bisschen Punkt, aber mir geht es echt nicht weit genug, ja. So und er würde natürlich liebend gern so eine Documenta machen, wie wir es eben beschrieben haben, nur der freie Künstler spielt da, nein, da wird nur das Vorzeichen umgedreht. Also da werden dann sozusagen, guck mal, wie geil eine Atombombe aussieht, wenn sie explodiert. Ja, beziehungsweise die Rakete fliegt und der ganze Kram.
Der Künstler, der wieder ein religiöses Programm vorlegt, an das man glauben kann, auch hier ist wieder ganz interessant, wir haben ja über Richard David Precht's Buch gesprochen. Precht hat ja den Westen als Konzept infrage gestellt kritisiert. Er macht das ja auch alles unhinterfragbar. Er nimmt ja keinmal eine Bestimmung des Westens vor oder versucht mal deutlich zu machen, was damit so allgemein gemeint sein könnte. Das Einzige, was er kann, ist den Westen abzugrenzen von irgendetwas. Und das ist zum Beispiel der Postkolonialismus. Also das schlimmste Buch für ihn ist Orientalism. Von etwa Zaid und auch da wieder lustig. Er zitiert Pankai Mishra, der ja ein sehr bekannter Autor ist. Der hat gesagt, dass eben diese neue koloniale, postkoloniale Theorie quasi den Weg geöffnet hat für alle möglichen Karrieren im Westen. Und hat dann auch gewisse Dinge an diesen Orientalismus-Studien kritisiert. Aber Pankai Mishra ist ja gerade jemand, der sich gegen diese westliche Hegemonie stellt mit seinem Schreiben. Das weiß er aber offenbar gar nicht. Zitiert ihn hier einfach nur so zustimmend, als würde er in seine Richtung argumentieren. Und ich glaube, hier muss man nämlich ganz vorsichtig sein. Und das hat man ja doch auch erleben können jetzt so in dem deutschen Diskurs. Es gab ja linke Kritiker der Identitätspolitik, die irgendwann ganz verplüfft waren darüber, dass sie auch Schreibaufträge von der Welt und so weiter erhalten haben. Und dann haben sie irgendwann sich auf der Seite von Matthias Döpfner und Ulf Poschert wiedergefunden und konnten es selbst nicht so fassen. Das Problem ist nun aber, dass es hier ja um was anderes geht. Also eigentlich war ja diese Kritik der Identitätspolitik eine. Und da hat er ja recht, wenn er das anspricht, dass nur noch die Identität des Sprechers eine Rolle spielte und nicht mehr der Inhalt, sondern nur noch die Frage, wer sagt was. Aber dieser Irrsinn, so möchte ich es mal bezeichnen, ist ja heute längst auch die Strategie der Rechten geworden. Wer spricht, wenn die das sagen, wenn das ein Sachse sagt, dann muss das stimmen. Und es ist übrigens auch die Strategie von Journalisten, zum Beispiel mit Osteuropa-Hintergrund, die sagen, du bist gegen Waffenlieferung, aber du weißt ja gar nichts von den Ukrainer, du bist nämlich keiner. Du bist ja noch nicht mal Pole, sonst könntest du es vielleicht noch beurteilen. Das heißt also, diese Identitätspolitik, die da einst von links kritisiert wurde, grassiert ja längst überall und ist längst das Programm auch der Rechten und Konservativen geworden.
Deswegen bin ich auch sehr gespannt. Ich meine, die Aufschwünge der Rechten sind ja auch dadurch begründet, dass man irgendwie sagte, ne ich will nicht, dass irgendwie mehr sprachliche Vorgaben gibt. Und dann, wann man Wortendungen verwendet. Die Antwort aus rechter Seite ist, dass es jetzt Gesetze gibt in Amerika, executive orders, was in Forschungsanträgen nicht geschrieben werden darf. Welche Worte nicht verwendet werden dürfen, zum Beispiel das Wort Frau. Also wir sind da nicht nur auf Augenhöhe, sondern die treiben es noch viel weiter. Und sehr interessant, wir hatten jetzt wieder einen, ich sag mal Terroranschlag und dann Amok-Fahrt wie auch immer in Mannheim mit Toten. In dem Falle war es aber ein Alexander, der die Fahrt gemacht hat. Ich höre also sehr interessiert natürlich die Horst und Hopf Sendung dazu, die zwei Botschaften haben. Zum einen, wir können ja nicht über jede Terrorfahrt reden. Achso. So und die andere, ja und wenn das dann passiert und dann ist es ein Alexander, dann sehe ich schon wieder die Linken, die bei uns Botschaften schreiben. Ich bin mal gespannt, was ihr dann darüber sagt und so. Also plötzlich spielt das Ereignis keine Rolle mehr, sondern es ist nur noch dieser Metadiskurs. Genau, wenn das jetzt kein Alexander, sondern ein Achmed gewesen wäre, wäre es genau derselbe Podcast wie immer geworden. Aber jetzt, sie konnten es nicht verschweigen, also mussten sie es so machen.
Im Übrigen auch gilt das für viele andere Medienhäuser, was du da jetzt gerade beschreibst. Man hat zwar drüber berichtet, aber in einer heruntergedimmten Form. Es waren nicht diese Debatten, die sich irgendwie da angeschlossen haben. Und es war ja auch interessant, dass einige, als es nur hieß Amokfahrt in Mannheim, man noch gar nichts wusste, schon ganz genau wussten, was los war, wobei Twitter losgelegt haben, Volker Beck etc.
Genau, also dieser Orientalismus, dieses Buch da von 1978, wird hier ganz interessant aufgegriffen. Ich habe sowas nicht präsent, also ich muss dann auch kurz bei GPT nachfragen, was steht denn eigentlich in dem Buch drin? Ah ja, okay und so und er greift das dann auf und sagt, nicht nur ist es so dieses, der Sprecher ist wichtiger als das, worum es geht, darauf nimmt er dann später nochmal Bezug, sondern es ist grundsätzlich diese Idee von, dass es eine Geschichte ist, an die wir mit politischen Handlungen anschließen. Also wir interessieren uns nicht für den Orient, sondern für unseren, also nicht für deren Orient, sondern für unseren Orientalismus. Was erzählen wir uns denn davon und so. Und da steckt eben mehr oder weniger, ich sag jetzt mal so zwischen den Zeilen, wahrscheinlich wird man es auch sehr explizit finden, diese grundsätzliche Idee drin, bei der wir uns ja immer fragen, warum ist das hier immer so retro bezogen? Also warum geht Alex Carpets nicht mit Hilfe von Technologie und so weiter einen großen Schritt in die Zukunft, sondern warum ist es dieses Besondere, wir bauen uns eine Rakete mit ganz neuem Antrieb und ganz neuer Technologie und wo fliegen wir hin? In die Vergangenheit. Warum eigentlich? Und auch diese Frage, wann war Amerika so great, dass Trump dahin zurück will? 1950, als Amerika nicht mal halb so viele Einwohner hatte und weltpolitisch jetzt nicht die große Rolle spielte, weil es musste alles erst entwickelt werden und so weiter. Ist doch alles absurd. Und hier wird es auch wieder deutlich, Alex Carp hat diese völlig absurden Erinnerungen an, ah ja damals hat ja der Eisenhauer den Brief geschrieben, er wollte gerne das Manhattan-Projekt zivilisieren, diese große konzertierte Aktion aus Wissenschaft und Politik und dann kommt der Prestige des Staates noch dazu und so haben wir ja auch das Internet gegründet und jetzt sind wir aber heute wo wir sind und geschriebene Geschichte ist nochmal geschriebene Geschichte und eine neue Idee sollte eben mal eine neue Idee sein und nicht eine alte. Und auch wenn er mit David Gewer dann übereinstimmt mit, wo sind die fliegenden Autos? Ja, solange sie keiner gebaut hat, hat sie halt keiner gebaut. Aber nur weil wir mal Altonbomben gebaut haben, heißt das noch lange nicht, dass wir jetzt ein Manhattan-Projekt für fliegende Autos brauchen. Ja, also es ist die ständige Abkehr von Zukunft zum einen und dann von dem anderen. Also er verabschiedet sich komplett von, dass es nochmal eine eigenständige Zukunft gibt. Das ist alles nur Revitalisierung, alles nur Renaissance. Alles soll nochmal wiederholt werden, was ich schon mal super lame finde. Und dann hier in diesem Orientalismus-Kapitel, sie sind nicht über Lage über die anderen zu reden. Über Amerika hat er noch so ein, finde ich, schon ziemlich pervertiertes Selbstbild über diese Geschichtsverherrlichung, über wie das mit den Allianzen ist. Also glaubt er wirklich die Sonntagsreden, dass die Europäer immer als beste Freunde an der amerikanischen Seite den großen Fehler eingesehen, dass ein Weltkrieg doch nicht so eine gute Idee ist, aber Internet ziemlich geil, danke, dass sie uns Demokratie und Internet gebracht hat und so. Das sind doch alles Sonntagsreden, auf die kann man doch jetzt nicht einfach reinfallen und uns dann gleichzeitig erklären, also wie wir uns immer den Orient herstellen, so ist der gar nicht. Wir müssen hier mal wieder Realität gewähren lassen. Da sind Horden von Menschen, die sich nicht zivilisieren und wenn wir die erschießen müssen, müssen wir sie halt erschießen, wenn die unserem zivilisierten Projekt im Wege stehen. Also die totale Verklärung der eigenen Vergangenheit und den eigenen Allianzen und dann gleichzeitig das völlige, also die anderen haben wir ja immer nur durch ideologische Brille und so weiter, die nehme ich gar nicht, also er nimmt gar nichts wahr, für ihn gibt es keine Zukunft, für ihn gibt es den anderen nicht, für ihn gibt es nur wir, unsere Allianzen, das verherrlichen wir uns alles, da denkt man gar nicht drüber nach und die anderen, keine Ahnung, aber die Geschichten, die wir uns über die erzählen, die sind alle falsche.
Nein, also die Geschichte ist ja eher so, dass er, bei aller Kritik, die man an etwa Said auch haben kann, die These von Said bestätigt. Er sagt Said mit seinem Buch, ihr habt euch den Orient ausgedacht, ihr habt da genau solche Bilder von Horden und so weiter kreiert, um euch eine Identität zu geben. Das ist ja die These von Said und da würde ich sagen, die bestätigt Karp aufs Beste.
Ja, die bestätigt mir auch die Tagesschau. Also wenn die Tagesschau mir irgendwas aus Afrika zeigt, arme Leute, die hungern, die unsere Hilfe brauchen, wo nichts passiert und so weiter. Also diese Art von Orientalismus.
Ja, es ist ein sehr obskures Buch vor allem auch, weil er dann auf den Personal Computer eingeht, dann sagt er, dass dieser Personal Computer die Emanzipation von Staaten und Institutionen ermöglichte und da dann auch den Weg geöffnet hat für die Counterculture. Und das ist ein Problem, weil dadurch natürlich nicht mehr eine kollektive Identität hergestellt werden konnte.
Und dann schließt er ja diesen zweiten großen Blog ab mit einer Sache, die wir mal diskutieren müssen.
Lass mich noch eine Sache anführen, denn er geht ja noch auf einen Film ein. Geht ja noch auf einen Film, nämlich Before Sunset von Richard Linklater.
Kennst du den?
Mit Ethan Hawke und Julie Delpy. Das sind aus den aus den Nuller Jahren. Aber das ist eine Trilogie. Also über viele Jahre gibt es drei wunderbare Filme, die man sich ansehen sollte. Und zwar ist das hier die Geschichte von zwei Menschen, die sich zufällig im Zug begegnen und dann so einen Flirt haben, der sehr intensiv ist. Einen Abend lang. Und dann gehen sie auseinander und dann sehen sie sich im zweiten Teil Before Sunset wieder. Und um den Zeitkreis, der heute virulent ist, abzubilden, wird in diesem Buch jetzt aus Before Sunset zitiert. Und da sagt Ethan Hawke, I just feel like I'm designed to be slightly dissatisfied with everything. I certify one desire and it just agitates another. Und dann sagt Julie Delpy, But I feel really alive when I want something. Wanting, whether it's intimacy with another person or a new pair of shoes, is kind of beautiful. I like that we have those ever renewing desires. Und was er jetzt sagt ist, das ist typisch für unsere Zeit, das ist Toys R Us, das sind die Apps, so leben wir unsere individualistischen Leben. Schluss damit. Jetzt gibt es natürlich da eine Melancholie drin und das ist ja das, was der Film auch ausdrückt. Warum können die eigentlich nicht einfach ein Paar werden? Die passen auch gut zusammen, aber irgendwas geht ja dann da doch nicht. Und das ist natürlich das moderne Subjekt und darunter kann man auch in gewisser Weise mal leiden und man kann auch sagen, das ist aber eine merkwürdige Engführung von andere Personen, mit denen intim werden oder sich ein neues Paar Schuhe kaufen. Aber das Gegenangebot, das gemacht wird und das können wir jetzt gerade auch sehen, wenn es um Familienpolitik in den USA geht oder das, was Alexander Kaab macht, ist, ne, du brauchst jetzt bald gar nicht mehr entscheiden. Diese Qual nehmen wir die ab, wir entscheiden für dich und dann suchen wir am Ende dir vielleicht auch noch den perfekten Partner aus, der dem nationalen Interesse dient und dann ist gut. Also das ist genau diese Kritik, die da drin liegt. Man kann ja auch die Konsumkultur im Dating und so weiter kritisieren und sollte das auch tun, denn da gibt es natürlich sehr viele Schattenseiten und vieles Leid, das dadurch auch produziert wird. Aber wie gesagt, das Gegenangebot, das hier gebracht wird, ist, wir machen jetzt eine autoritäre Gesellschaft und dann hast du dich dem zu unterwerfen und dann ist da nicht mehr dieses Gefühl, dass du noch etwas Neues brauchst oder so. Du hast dich mit dem abzufinden, was du besitzt bzw. was wir dir zugedacht haben.
Also dass Konsum Kompensation ist, ist ja weiterhin kritisiert und gerade diese Autoren im Silicon Valley, die so viele Bedürfnisse, also über FOMO-Technologien befriedigen oder angeblich befriedigen, sind ja immer fasziniert davon, dass es den Menschen eigentlich nicht um das Materielle geht, sondern um diese Metaebene. Das andere oder das Objekt wird für mich erst interessant, wenn jemand anderes plötzlich darauf zugreift, ich also nicht mehr kann, dann plötzlich ja wie kleine Kinder, man will immer genau mit dem Spielzeug spielen, mit dem der andere gerade spielt. So, das ist ja so, dass man daraus sozusagen ein Rettungs in der Rettungsethologie macht, dem man sagt, nee komm, wir organisieren jetzt deine Bedürfnisse. Das ist ja nun einprogrammiert in Silicon Valley. Es wäre auch interessant gewesen, da noch tiefer reinzugehen, um zu sagen, wir im Silicon Valley haben nicht nur Technologien hergestellt, sondern wir wissen auch, wie man Bedürfnisse schafft, wie man sie so befriedigt, dass sie nie ganz befriedigt werden, dass die Leute immer morgens als erstes erst mal scrollen gehen und so weiter und so fort. Und das machen wir jetzt dem Staate zu Nutze. Also wir geben nicht nur einen Technologietransfer, sondern auch so eine Art, was haben wir eigentlich so rausgefunden in unseren eigenen psychologischen Studien und so, dass man die auch dem Staate übergibt. Und jetzt hat er ja dieses achte Kapitel zu den Flawed Systems, in denen haut er ja noch mal auf die Ingenieure drauf. Die Apple-Leute kriegen ja fett weg, Disney, denn hier haben Leute Technologien erschaffen, die so als Lifestyle-Technologien, wie vorhin schon angesprochen, die Leute in so eine aristokratische Rolle bringen, die aber ihrem Bankkonto nicht gerecht wird. Man bestellt sich jetzt essen, statt zum Essen hinzugehen. Man lässt sich befördern, obwohl man sich gar kein Auto leisten kann. Man greift ins Kulturarchiv von Musik, Film und wie auch immer, obwohl man gar nicht alle Rechte an allen, man holt sich halt so eine Lizenz und merkt gar nicht, dass man spielball ist. Und er sagt, das ist eine Illusion des guten Lebens. Und ich denke mir irgendwie, ne, das ist nicht nur eine Illusion, sondern das ist das gute Leben. Also mit Spotify haben wir ein Ausbeutermechanismus für die Musikindustrie, aber für uns Zugang zum ganzen Musikarchiv. Dasselbe mit Netflix, YouTube und dem ganzen Kram. Alles, was zum Beispiel in meiner Kindheit als, ah, da wohnen die Superreichen, die haben eine riesige Videotheke im Keller. Das haben wir heute alle. Die Bildschirme, die großen Fernseher, alles leicht verfügbar. Ständige Verfügbarkeit mit dem Handy, wir können uns unsere Services holen und so weiter und so fort. Ich würde ja sagen, ein großer Schritt in die Zukunft wäre, wenn wir uns das jetzt anschauen, was wir als Produkt haben und es dann noch mal sozial verträglich gestalten. Richtig. Also wir haben ein individuelles Beförderungsbedürfnis. Es reicht aber nicht bei der Taxifahrt, sondern das muss dann eben subventioniert werden wie auch eine Opernkarte. Geht auch nicht für 300 Euro die Oper, obwohl die 300 Euro kostet die Karte, sondern nur für 100. Den Rest bezahlt halt jemand anders. Ah ja, wir selber. Staatliche Aufgabe. Also man könnte einen staatlichen Auftragskatalog darstellen und sagen, der muss jetzt irgendwie bezahlt werden. Und wenn es dann heißt, die Superreichen müssen für die Ärmeren in der Gesellschaft die Annehmlichkeiten finanzieren, ist das weder Illusion noch Luxus eines guten Lebens, sondern das ist das gute Leben.
Ja.
So, hier ist also für mich jetzt...
Er sagt aber uns, euch geht es zu gut.
Er will uns das ausreden.
Jaja.
Und ich denke mir, ok, du hast es jetzt angesprochen im Text. Du hast einen Text dazu gemacht. Für mich ist das jetzt der Anlass, um hier raus eine Vision, eine politische Vision zu stricken. Ja. Weil ich es genau anders sehe als er. Er möchte einfach den großen Krieg und ich möchte das gute Leben für alle. Und er hat uns gezeigt, wir sind doch eigentlich kurz davor. Warum sagen wir uns das nochmal auf David Graeppers? Wo sind denn die fliegenden Autos? Also wir kommen auch ohne fliegende Autos schon ganz schön weit, würde ich sagen.
Wir brauchen nur entsprechende Tarifverträge für Uberfahrer. Das ist das, was benötigt wird. Und er will aber wirklich das Sinn stiftende und das kann am besten der große Krieg oder sowas sein. Es ist nicht das gute Leben, das hier gewollt wird, sondern es geht nur darum, eine Härte nach außen zu zeigen, aber auch nach innen. Alle, die sich als Delegenten verhalten. Beziehungsweise, damit kommen wir jetzt zu diesem dritten Part.
Ich will eine finale Kritik zu diesem Part 2 machen. Und sie klingt ein bisschen abgedroschen. Man hat sich schon ein paar Mal gehört und es gibt sie auch als politisches Programm. Aber ich will es ganz deutlich sagen. So denken Milliardäre, weil sie Milliardäre sind. Alex Karp ist ein Milliardär und natürlich denkt er so über uns und möchte uns den Verlust und das geht ja nicht. Das aristokratische Leben, das du dir hier, du kannst ja nicht einfach eine Uber holen. Wir brauchen den Fahrer für den Panzer und den Hersteller der Uber-App für die KI-Waffe und so weiter. Wir können es dir eigentlich nicht gönnen. Und ich sag, ich will aber, dass es mir gegönnt wird. Und technologisch ist es da und finanziell trägt es sich so halb, aber nur weil du Milliardär nicht bereit bist zu verzichten. Also wir haben hier einen Milliardär, der von uns Verzicht verlangt. Und ich sage, nee lieber Milliardär, du verzichtest bitte.
Damit es aufgeht. Was wir tatsächlich in vielen Elitendiskursen haben, dass wir immer Leute jetzt hören, die sagen, und das muss man auch mal den Leuten klar machen, dass es so nicht weitergehen kann und die Friedensdividende und so. Das ist ja dieses ganze Reden, immer von Leuten, die von dieser Rede niemals betroffen sein werden. Dann haben wir jetzt gerade gesagt, alles soll ich dem Kollektiv unterordnen? Ja, aber irgendwie doch nicht, denn es geht jetzt um die Ingenieure. Man braucht den Ingenieur-Mindset und da erzählt er erstmal ganz viel was von Bienenschwarm. Also da werden in Münzen 1951 wird der Bienenschwarm untersucht.
Findest du das nicht kritikwürdig? Ich finde das ja einen sehr interessanten Punkt, denn er sagt ja, der Bienenschwarm funktioniert am Bewusstsein des Einzelnen vorbei. Jetzt hab ich ja schon häufiger gesagt, also diese Floskel am Bewusstsein des Einzelnen vorbei kennt man von mir schon über Jahre. Und ich hab das jetzt zuletzt intensiviert über, man muss das übers Gefühl machen, nicht über die Aufklärung. So, also hier alignt der Text wieder mit mir, was die Methode angeht. Aber eben aufgeladen mit der Nerva Bitte und mit anderem Vorzeichentext.
Was er jetzt da sagen will, also der Schwarm, wie er sich organisiert, diese kollektive Organisation, ist eigentlich eine, die Unternehmen, besonders Start-ups, entsprechen sollte. Dann springt er dazu über, dass wir Improvisation brauchen. Ja.
Ich hab mir das Buch auch mal bestellt.
Bezieht sich dann auf das Buch Improvisation and the Theatre von Keith Johnston, dass Johnston hat dieses Buch vor Jahrzehnten geschrieben, es ist bis heute auf Deutsch auch erhältlich.
Ja, 1970er.
Er ist ein dauerhafter Bestseller und jetzt denkt man schon die ganze Zeit, ja aber im Moment, ich dachte wir sollen uns jetzt diesem Kollektiv unterordnen. Nein, nein, es gibt natürlich herausragende Persönlichkeiten. Für die gilt das nicht. Die können sich deviant auch verhalten. Und gerade wenn sie das tun, dann sind sie wahrscheinlich genial. Und das war ja das große Problem einer Kultur, in der man überhaupt nicht mehr Dissens üben kann, in der alle wie die Duckmäuse rumlaufen, dass eben die, die abweichen, nicht mehr gewollt werden. Dass er also hier erstmal uns ein repressives System antritt, in dem er dann aber gewisse subversive Elemente haben möchte, damit die die Innovation vorantreiben, ist ja wirklich ganz interessant.
Ihr habt ja das Buch zuletzt gelesen, Robert Musil, glaube ich, der große SPD-Theoretiker. Nein, nicht Musil, sondern doch, doch, er hatte, ich hab's bei euch gehört, Robert.
Also Robert Musil ist der Schriftsteller.
Nein, nein, ich meine nicht Robert Musil, das ist ja der Manu in den Ereignissen. Michels.
Michels über die Parteien.
Genau, genau, genau.
Strukturen, ja.
Damals wurde schon immer, also damals, also in diesem Text, diese Idee lautet ja so, um die Gesellschaft als Demokratie aufzubauen, brauchst du demokratische Parteien, die wie Armeen aufgestellt sind. So, du hast also eine Konvertierung des Codes zwischen Organisation und Gesellschaft. In deren Sicht ist das schon, also das passt ziemlich gut und ist auch in dem Falle mal mit Soziologie gedeckt, was er hier schreibt.
Ne, das glaube ich auch nur, ich finde es interessant, dass er das manchen nur zugesteht. Also er sagt ja nicht generell dürfen die Leute den Legen wenden.
Und da ist er ja ganz konkret, er hat ja die ganze Zeit schon die Silicon Valley Ingenieure kritisiert. Also der hat ja jetzt Part 1, Part 2 auf dem Kicker gehackt und jetzt hier geht es eben ans Eingemachte. Wir als Normalos spielen ja keine Rolle, wir sind ja nur Verfügungsmasse. Das soll auch so bleiben, aber die Ingenieure, die also organisiert werden, um die Gesellschaft zu gestalten, die brauchen eine disruptive Organisation, in der es konstruktiven Ungehorsam gibt, das ist für diese Organisation, die Gesellschaft, die die Gesellschaft gestaltet, lebenswichtig, schreibt er.
Ja, also es geht nicht darum, dass er sagt, wir brauchen einen preußischen Staat, wo alle nur in eine Richtung rennen.
Es geht jetzt nicht um den Staat.
Ja, also wir brauchen im Ganzen, brauchen wir so eine Hierarchie und brauchen diese klaren Strukturen und alle müssen sich unterordnen. Aber an den Schaltstellen, dort ist Delinquenz angesagt. Dort ist es wichtig, dass man improvisieren kann. Das bedeutet dann für das Unternehmen, der Senior Vice-Präsident sollte nicht überall, wo er auftritt im Unternehmen, wann immer er ein Gespräch hat, die Position des Senior Vice-Präsidenten haben. In dem Sinne, dass alle da hochschauen zu ihm und sagen oh, ich darf jetzt gar nichts sagen. Sondern er muss sich dann mit den anderen auf eine disruptive Augenhöhe begegnen. Muss dort seinen Status nur instrumentell verstehen. Also er kann dann irgendetwas ermöglichen. Aber muss alles an sich rankommen lassen. Es geht also natürlich hier um eine ganz moderne Form der Unternehmensführung, wo die Hierarchien nicht mehr so klar sind, wo also auch die Gedanken nicht unterdrückt werden. Und er sagt auch da ist wichtig, dass gerade die wirklichen Chefs im Prinzip agieren wie der Dirigent im Orchester, der mit jedem einzelnen Musiker im Orchestergraben Blickkontakt haben kann und sich die Sache nicht nur über irgendwelche Abteilungsleiter erzählen lässt. Was hier also passiert ist eine moderne Managementtheorie einzufordern, von der ich sagen würde, naja, aber die ist ja auch sehr präsent. Das ist jetzt nicht so, als würde uns hier was völlig Neues angeboten werden, sondern es war ja doch gerade so, dass dieses Think Different das Credo des Silicon Valley war. Dass natürlich vielleicht manche Unternehmen dann träge werden und dass sie größer Unternehmen werden, dann sich Bürokratien plötzlich bahnbrechen. Das ist sicherlich so, aber es ist ja jetzt nicht so, als sei er der Erste, der auf die Idee kommt, dass Disruption hilfreich sein kann für Innovationen.
Ja, nur der große Witz ist eben, dieses Konvertierungsverhältnis, also dass der Code nicht kopiert wird, sondern vorher konvertiert, einmal umgedreht wird, funktioniert nur in eine Richtung. Die alte Lehre ist eben, damit die Gesellschaft in Freiheit, in Demokratie und damit auch sensibel für, es gibt Sachen und wir müssen uns anpassen. Das ist ja der große Vorteil des Kapitalismus. Er hat einfach eine Profitlogik. Wer am Ende was konkret herstellt, ist egal, aber die Bedürfnisse werden irgendwie befriedigt. Und wenn da eine Lücke entsteht, kommt halt jemand anders. So, wir haben also eigentlich in der Gesellschaft das Chaos und in Organisation, Hierarchie, Formalität, Mitgliedschaftsregeln. So, seine Idee ist jetzt genau umgedreht und das ist natürlich absurd. Ja, man kann nicht 80 Millionen Menschen oder 300 Millionen hierarchisch durchorganisieren und im Gemütszustand auf einen Nenner bringen und das Ganze dann aber über eine vom Chaos dominierte Organisation.
Ja, im weißen Haus.
Und das sehen wir ja gerade in Amerika, dass da einfach alle Chaos machen und das auch, also das wird ja jetzt gerade auch als Management-Methode von Trump. Nee, da hat er immer zwei, da gibt die Aufgabe immer doppelt und dann wird abgerechnet. Das heißt, die Leute, die einen Auftrag bekommen, stehen immer im Wettbewerb und so der ganze Kram. Nur das meinte ja genau nicht damals, was der Michel sagt. Das ist ja total dumm und dafür gibt es auch weder theoretisches Gerüst noch irgendeine empirische Entsprechung.
Und man sieht es ja auch daran, dass er sich dann zum Beispiel auf Beethoven beruft. Beethoven war ein Ausnahmemusiker, weil er taub war, konnte er gewisse Dinge nicht mehr hören, das hat ihn aber dann erst dazu gebracht, über die Grenzen hinauszugehen.
Völlig absurd sowas.
Kann man so sagen, nur hat das mit der Unternehmensführung dann künftig nicht zu tun.
Die meisten Menschen, die taub werden, hören die Gefahren in ihrer Umwelt nicht mehr und sterben dann auch früher. Ausnahmen, die Regeln bestätigen, schön und gut. Und dass es hier um Spezialfähigkeiten des Musikherstellens geht.
Der saß ja auch alleine am Schreibtisch und hat komponiert, Beethoven.
Das könnte ich sich heute eh nicht vorstellen, dass die nicht an Logic saßen und immer gehört haben, sondern dass es wirklich im Kopf stand.
Genau. Und das ist ja bei ganz vielen Komponisten so, dass auch wenn sie nicht taub sind, dass es im Kopf entsteht, sie schreiben es nieder. Viele Komponisten komponieren nicht am Klavier.
Sie schreiben es einfach so. Von Jupp Haum gibt es dieses schöne Bild, dass er seine eigenen Partituren gelesen hat und anfing zu weinen, weil er die Musik so schön fand. So das ist das Prinzip. Aber davon sind die ja ganz weit weg.
Ja, aber man kann sowieso nicht von Beethoven als dem Ausnahmekünstler eine Unternehmensphilosophie ableiten, weil Beethoven kein Unternehmen geführt hat, sondern nur alleine komponiert hat und dann wurde das dem Verleger gegeben und gesagt, hier ist die neue Symphonie. Die Ingenieure sollen was tun, bessere Gewehre bauen. Die Politik hat sich nicht um die Armee gekümmert. Wir brauchen vor allem im Militär Disruption. Es geht darum, dass er hier noch mal eigentlich, ohne dass er ihn erwähnt, Elon Musk und Doge schon einführt, wenn er sagt, eigentlich braucht das Militär jetzt eine klare Verschlankung und die Privatwirtschaft muss Tür und Tor geöffnet bekommen und muss einfach auch unabhängig von irgendwelchen Entscheidungen, die man da mal festgeschrieben hat, soll also die Privatwirtschaft sich da austoben dürfen. Und das bedeutet, dass man ja natürlich im Militär alles Mögliche festgelegt hat. Er bringt dann auch mal diese Beispiele, dass beim US-Militär es einen Katalog gibt, es gibt 123 verschiedene Kugelschreiber und 47 verschiedene Tinten und dann gibt es irgendwelche Bestimmungen, die am Ende dafür gesorgt haben, dass man ein Kofferradio 15 mal teurer und vier Monate verspätet erst bekam, obwohl man es hätte einfach am Supermarkt kaufen können. Und das liegt nur daran, dass es so Regularien beim Militär gibt. Und da ist ja auch etwas dran und Bill Clinton hat ja schon dagegen eine Politik gemacht und das war aber dann alles am Ende nicht so erfolgreich, dass man das ganz entschlackt hat. Und eigentlich ist das jetzt so ein Ruf danach, dass man Doge im Militär macht, dass man also dort Budgets nicht mehr so eng mit irgendwelchen Regularien versieht, sondern sagt, hier ist Geld, wirf es raus und mit anderen Worten, nimm das Geld, gib es Palantir, die werden schon dafür sorgen.
Doge und das Militär wird noch ein interessantes Kapitel in der Praxis, denn das 900 Milliarden Budget pro Jahr, also eine der größten Organisationen der Welt, zudem mit diesen Aufträgen, die man auch nicht ehrlicherweise marktwirtschaftlich durchrechnen kann, Betreuung von Atomwaffen und lauter so ein Zeug, dass da einiges im Argen liegt und da auch mal so ein großer Audit, ja, okay.
Also es ist so natürlich, wenn man auch mit Leuten gesprochen hat, das ist selbst für die Bundeswehr so hoch, die ist nur ein Zehntel, wenn überhaupt so groß. Ja, wenn man mit Leuten da gesprochen hat bei der Bundeswehr, die da für die Beschaffung zuständig waren, dann denkt man auch, das gibt's doch gar nicht, aber das ist in allen größeren Komplexen, ist das etwas und das kann man auch kritisieren, nur was hier ja eigentlich gefordert wird oder was hier eigentlich gemacht wird, ist eine Wärmung für Palantir, gebt uns einfach das Geld. Wir können alles besonders effizient einsetzen, weil wir die Querdenker sind, weil wir nicht gemocht werden wollen. Er zitiert dann den Comedian John Mulaney, der sagt, likeability is a jail. Und aus diesem Gefängnis sind die Palantir Leute natürlich längst ausgebrochen, um auf den Spuren der Beat Generation von Jack Couric quasi das andere zuzulassen, hinauszugehen und sich nicht mehr einem Gruppenzwang zu unterwerfen. Also er hat wirklich auch so eine interessante Idee davon, dass man dann aber auch wiederum hart regieren muss im Unternehmen, damit man Widerstand erzeugt. Daraus erblüht dann wieder was Neues. Und immer sind es so Künstler-Assoziationen, die er weckt. Er geht beispielsweise auf Jackson Pollock ein, also der Maler der Drip Paintings. Der hatte als sein Lehrer Thomas Hart Benton, der eher so an so mexikanischen Realismus, Surrealismus angelehnt malte, also eine sehr klare figürliche Ausrichtung hatte. Und dass da sich ein Jackson Pollock daraus entwickelte, weil er sich an diesem Lehrer rieb, das sei doch wiederum ein Zeichen dafür, dass man auch mit Härte in einem Unternehmen reagieren muss. Dann kommt was hervor. Das sind natürlich alles Beispiele. Man kann die auch alle genau anders erzählen. Ja, also das ist ja das Schöne. Ich könnte jetzt auch genau die gegenteilige These mit solchen irrsinnigen Beispielen unterfüttern. Das ist so, wie man überall Jürgen Habermas dran schreiben kann, wenn man möchte. So kann ich jetzt auch sagen, nein, also es gibt viele große Künstler, die hatten gar keinen Lehrer. Und gerade wenn man keinen Lehrer hat, dann wird man der allergrößte.
Wir haben Wirtschaftsobell-Preise für die Einsicht vergeben, dass es für jede Bauernregel immer genau die Gegenbauernregel gibt.
Ja, so ist das hier.
Sonne ist gut, Regen aber auch. Flache Hierarchie, steile Hierarchie, also es geht alles. Hier ist allerdings noch etwas eingebaut, das für uns natürlich, da wir jetzt sensibel sind, Werbpflicht. Also die Werbpflicht diskutieren wir ja die ganze Zeit unter so einem Diktum, dass sonst reicht es nicht, sonst sind wir nicht groß, leistungsfähig genug. Die Bundeswehr braucht Leute, da sind 20.000 Stellen unbesetzt, müssen wir machen. Seine Argumentation ist so ein bisschen anders. Ich lese mal vor. Das derzeitige Modell ist völlig unhaltbar. Wir sollten als Gesellschaft ernsthaft in Betracht ziehen, uns von einer reinen freiwilligen Armee zu entfernen und den nächsten Krieg nur zu führen, als ob man sich das aussuchen kann, ja, auch so amerikanisch, wenn jetzt die Bedingung, wenn jeder das Risiko und die Kosten teilt. Es geht also auch um so eine Gemüseszustandsdimension. Ne, wir können jetzt nicht einfach nur sagen, die Soldaten kämpfen für uns wie die Ukraine für uns, wir können es da nicht einmischen, sondern die Risiken und die Kosten müssen verteilt werden. Hier muss man wieder ganz klar fragen, dann heißt das aber Wehrpflicht für alle. Dann machen wir nicht einfach eine Altersgrenze. Und erst recht machen wir kein, wir lassen uns nicht drauf ein wie die Ukrainer so ein, oh, hier ist ganz viel Korruption. Woraus besteht denn die Korruption? Na die kaufen sich frei. Also diese Art von Wehrpflicht, das Risiko und die Kosten zu verteilen, gilt dann insbesondere auch für die Alex Carps dieser Welt. Einfach nur zu sagen, ich bin hier Führungspersönlichkeiten, mich braucht man an der Heimatfront. Nee, du willst eine Organisation im Chaos, die kommt sehr gut ohne dich aus. Vielleicht sogar noch mehr Chaos, ist ja noch besser. Du musst auch an die Front.
Lass uns noch über den vierten Teil reden, Rebuilding the Technological Republic. Da begegnen wir uns in Kapitel 15 erst noch mal zum FBI, zu Edgar J. Hoover. Ja, da gibt es ja schon auch problematische Aspekte bei so Geheimdiensten, aber dieses Mal ist es sowieso auch anders. Was ja hier auch vorgestellt wird, ist ja so eine gewisse Planwirtschaft, die er möchte. Also der Staat plant gemeinsam mit den Silicon Valley Größen, wohin sich dann der Staat zu entwickeln hat. Und dann wird darauf hingewiesen, dass diese Technologien, die man in Afghanistan eingesetzt hat von Talenteer, dafür gesorgt haben, dass man sich in den USA dachte, ach das könnten wir hier auch mal probieren. Ja, mit Gesichtserkennung etc. Und da gab es dann Protest. Da ist man ganz verwundert, warum die Leute nicht auch quasi wie die Terroristen in Afghanistan behandelt werden wollten. Machen wir das doch hier auch. Was hier eigentlich vorgestellt wird, ist eine Anpassung an China.
Ja, es gibt doch diesen Film mit Tom Cruise.
Minority Report.
Genau, wo die Augen, die Iris Scanner so wichtig sind. Wir wissen ja, was Open AI macht, diese Iris Scanner. Jeder identifiziert sich da so. Wo wurde diese Technologie eingeführt? In den Flüchtlingscams. Ja. So, wo kommt diese komische Bürgergeldkarte her, diese Flüchtlingsbezahlkarte und so weiter aus diesem Migrationsdiskurs? Also diese Gefahr, wie du sie beschreibst, ist natürlich gigantisch und riesig, weshalb man da unbedingt Einhalt gebieten muss und da hoffe ich fällt jedem, wenn man das so hört und liest, sofort die Einsicht nahe und dann schließen sich auch entsprechende Freiheitsappelle an, dass man das genau nicht will. Wir haben uns für Geld entschieden, wir haben uns für Papiere entschieden, die wir so ein bisschen von Personen unterscheiden. Also man darf auch mal ohne Personalausweis unterwegs sein, notfalls begleitet einen die Polizei nach Hause und dann zeigt man ihn wieder. Ja, aber diese letzten Freiheiten sollen bitte zugestanden sein.
Hier ja nicht. Es geht dann auch so weit, dass überlegt wird, wie kriegt man eigentlich so ein nationales Bewusstsein wiederhergestellt. Und da sagt er ja, wir haben uns ja schon darauf geeinigt mal, dass es so eine gewisse Inklusivität geben soll. Aber die Frage ist ja, wie sieht dann eigentlich dieses Projekt aus? Wir haben das nationale Projekt so ausgehöhlt, heißt es da, dass man argumentieren könnte, dass es nicht mehr viel Substanz hat, in die man überhaupt eingezogen werden kann. Unser Gefühl der bürgerlichen Zugehörigkeit zueinander ist verkümmert. Und da würde ich sagen, ja stimmt, aber das liegt ja zum Beispiel daran, dass wir so eine unglaubliche Ungleichheit in der Gesellschaft haben. Interessiert den aber alles nicht. Weiter heißt es, und es sind andere Mittel entstanden, um dieses Verlangen nach zwischenmenschlichen Bindungen zu erfüllen und die klaffende Lücke zu füllen, einschließlich des gefühlste Zugehörigkeit und des Engagements für eine große Erzählung von Triumph und Niederlage, wie sie beispielsweise im Sport zu finden ist. Okay, der Sport da so als Ersatz. Und dann heißt es aber, solche Bündnisse werden entstehen. Wir werden einen Weg finden, Koalitionen und Gruppen von Kämpfern zu bilden. Also am besten jetzt diese Leute aus dem Sport, die sind ja schon mal so da. Die haben ja auch dieses gemeinsame Gefühl des Triumphes. Wie könnten wir die jetzt für unser Projekt rüberziehen? Und der Wunsch ist, dass man wieder eine geteilte Mythologie hat und dann kommen sie noch mal auf Palantí, auf den Namen zu sprechen. Der bezieht sich ja auf Lord of the Rings. Und da sei ja nun ein Auto, der noch die Mythologie hergestellt hat. Und das braucht man wieder gemeinsame Geschichten entwerfen. Wir haben eben aus dem Presseclub gehört und man muss mal drauf achten, wenn man so Nachrichten guckt und Journalisten so hört. Alle sprechen immer so von, wir brauchen mal wieder eine gemeinsame Geschichte und wir brauchen jetzt jemanden, der kommt, der uns sagt, wo es auch mal langgeht. Oder wir hatten da von der Lage der Nation diese Ausschnitte gehabt. Das ist ziemlich nah, immer an KAP dran. Ich will die jetzt nicht alle sofort in einen Eimer werfen und einmal umrühren, aber ich will einen Topf werfen. Aber ich sage hier ganz klar, da ist etwas, was gerade in der Luft liegt. Nämlich so dieser Wunsch, dass doch mal wieder so etwas Identitätsstiftendes da ist. Irgendein großes Wir. Und das macht mir echt große Sorge. Und dann kommen wir zu Martin Walzer.
Ja genau, wir nähern uns ja hier der Auschwitzkeule.
Ja.
Vorher noch zwei Punkte, also die du eben schon gemacht hast. Im Text ist es ja, also die Kompositionsleistung ist ja schon irgendwie ganz gut. Also es wurde sehr viel besser lektoriert als geschrieben, muss man so zu sagen. Denn hier kommt wieder so ein kurzer Magermoment. Die Amerikaner oder Amerika hat es ja immer besonders gut hinbekommen, schreibt er, eine Nation zu konstruieren von Menschen, die sich in ihrer Herkunft und so weiter und auch in ihren sozioökonomischen Rahmdaten nicht so sehr gleichen, aber eben als Mitglieder etwas Bedeutenderen sehen. Die also nicht nur in einem oberflächlichen Appell an ethnische oder religiöse Identität folgen, sondern die sich als Amerikaner sehen. Da würde ich gern wieder wissen, wann war das so erfolgreich? Also wann war es mal mehr als Sonntagsrede? Würde ich sagen, also politisch, ja, kann man das klar markieren. Vor Ronald Reagan wurden wahrscheinlich Reden gehalten, die irgendwie so weiter. Aber so im Alltag ist auch diese Geschichte damals durchsetzt, von wie wir heute noch in so Ku Klux Klan hier und da und alles ging drunter und drüber, also es war sozusagen immer verworfen. Und dann machte man auch besondere Vorwürfe den Linken gegenüber, denn vielleicht ist das der eklatanteste strategische Fehler der modernen Linken, sagt er. Das kann man mal diskutieren. Ich habe mir ein Fragezeichen an den Satz gemacht, er lautet, Sie, die Linken, behauptet, sich den Exzessen des Marktes widersetzen zu wollen, aber Ihre Unwilligkeit, sich mit dem Guten, das aus einer nationalen Kultur oder gemeinsamen Identität entstehen kann, auseinanderzusetzen und ernst zu nehmen, hat nur die Exzesse ermöglicht, den sie sich angeblich widersetzt. Ich würde Ihnen jetzt Folgendes entgegnen. Ich bin durchaus bereit, meine negative Sicht auf die deutsche Volkswirtschaft, weil sie so viel Ungleichheit und so weiter produziert, so viel Unfairness, so viel Verlierer zurücklässt, weil sie die Jugend nicht in den Blick hat, die Kinder gar nicht und so weiter. Ich würde diese Abneigung der deutschen Volkswirtschaft sehr wohl gegen eine Zuwendung eines deutschen politischen Projektes ummodeln, wenn dieses deutsche politische Projekt bedeutet, dass wir es jetzt ernst machen und die negativen Seiten dieser volkswirtschaftlichen Verwerfung ausgleichen. Also sobald einer auf der Bühne steht und sagt, wer derer sind alle scheiße, die FDP ist asozial und so weiter und so fort, bin ich sofort Deutscher. Nur solange das Angebot keiner macht oder es einfach nur als Oppositionsspektakel dargestellt wird, sage ich mir, na dann nehme ich wenigstens diese Opposition. Aber weiter geht es dann nicht. Also er hat immer so Ideen, wo ich mir denke, ja klar, aber nur weil du jetzt meinst, du hast eine Vorstellung von Amerika, der folge ich dann nicht automatisch. So und dann kommt da eben Martin Walzer. Denn Martin Walzer hat ja auch schon mal gesagt, damals in der Paulskirche 98, jeder kennt die Last unserer Geschichte, unsere ewige Schmach, aber keine ernsthafte Person leugnet heute aus, schwitzt, keine Person, die noch bei gesunden Menschenverstand ist, feilscht um den Horst. Das ist ein Horror von Auschwitz, aber wenn mir diese Vergangenheit jeden Tag in den Medien vorgehalten wird, bemerke ich, dass etwas in mir gegen diese unaufförliche Präsentation unserer Schmach rebelliert. Das ist der Wortlaut von Walzer. So hab ich das so vorgelesen und fragte sich, wieso passt das da überhaupt? Wieso hat er das denn? Will er jetzt so ein... Also die ganze Zeit erklärt er uns, wie geil die Vergangenheit war und dass wir jetzt in unsere Raketen steigen und dahin zurückdüsen müssen. Und jetzt kommt er plötzlich mit Martin weiter.
Aber nicht alle, immer nur die schönen Seiten der Vergangenheit. Und das bedeutet natürlich, dass der Holocaust stattgefunden hat, aber muss man sich laufend an ihn erinnern. Da spricht er ja tatsächlich an einer Stelle von einer Erinnerungsindustrie in Deutschland und sagt, die Deutschen der Gegenwart sind ja schon müde geworden, was diese Erinnerung anbelangt. Und sagt dann noch mal, dass diese schwache Identität, die Deutschland deshalb hat, weil man sich den Schrecken, den man verursacht hat, so oft vor Augen führt, dass der dazu geführt hat, dass man den russischen Angriff hat zu lassen können. Also das ist einfach so eine Verdrehung von Geschichte und Wirklichkeit, und weiß ich nicht was alles, dass man es kaum aushalten kann. Und ich habe ja danach gelesen in dieser Dessertation, die übrigens heißt, pass auf, Aggression in der Lebenswelt, die Erweiterung des parsenschen Konzepts der Aggression durch die Beschreibung des Zusammenhangs von Jargon, Aggression und Kultur. Und dort gibt es eben dieses Kapitel zu Martin Walser. Da interessanterweise versucht er aber in einer gewissen wissenschaftlichen Abgeklärtheit nur so diese Rhetoriken von Walser zu beschreiben oder zu analysieren, wär schon fast so weit gesagt. Da bezieht er sich aber nicht derart positiv auf diese Walser Rede und auf diese Diagnose und wendet sie zu seinen Interessen, wie er das jetzt in diesem Buch tut.
Genau, weil es nämlich in diesem Buch einfach auch aus intrinsischer Logik nicht passt. Man kann nicht nach 200 Seiten zum Thema die neue nationale Idee, das neue politische Erwecken, die Abkehr von wirtschaftlicher Freiheit, muss man ja mal ganz deutlich sagen. Und dann zuspitzend auf, wir brauchen wieder einen patriotischen Stolz, so schreibt das ja, und eine primäre Loyalität. Und dann macht er den kleinen Schritt und sagt, und auch Walzer sagte schon, so eine Art Erinnerungskultur steht denen im Weg. Und ich denk mir nur, nee, diese Art Erinnerungskultur ist genau dafür da, dass ihre einzige Funktion um diese Art von primärer Loyalität, patriotischem Stolz, heute zumindest noch Aufklärung darüber zu geben, wohin es führt. Also es ist sozusagen mir zu passgenau. Wir müssen uns immer wieder an diesen Holocaust ereignen, erinnern, damit er eben nicht nochmal passiert.
Ja, aber das ist ja genau das, also ich will jetzt auch gar nicht hier, Walzars Rede ist nochmal komplexer, also die ist problematisch, aber wesentlich komplexer als Alexander Karp uns das darstellt. Aber wenn wir jetzt einfach mal diese Karp-Interpretationen und Idee da übernehmen, dann haben wir doch exakt das gefunden bei einem Gauland, der sagt, der Nationalsozialismus ist Fliegenschissen der Geschichte. Das heißt also, die deutsche Identität ist eigentlich so viel größer, da müssen wir uns gar nicht damit groß auseinandersetzen. Und wir haben einen Auftritt von Elon Musk bei einem AfD-Parteitag, bei dem er in etwa genau das sagt.
Lasst euch da nicht kleinkriegen.
Lasst euch da nicht kleinkriegen, eure ganze Erinnerungskultur. Wirft die mal weg, die braucht ihr nicht. Jetzt gilt es, nationales Interesse wieder stark zu artikulieren. Und in dieser Verbindung steht das und man nimmt dann hier den Martin Walser, weil das natürlich quasi die intellektuellste Ausprägung einer neuen Nationalbewusstheit ist. Und das ist etwas, was in den 90er Jahren dann auch so präsent ist. Auch bei Boto Strauß findet man das ja auch.
Man kann das sehr aufwendig machen und die Walser Diskussionen gibt es, und an die kann man anschließen und erinnern. Aber für mich, meine Lesart und die ist natürlich jetzt individuell. Ich kann es nicht am Text direkt belegen, aber es bleibt ein Gebührzustand zurück. Das, was mir der Karp hier sagen will ist, die beste Idee, wie man einen Staat organisiert, jemals war Deutschland zwischen 1933 und 45.
Das sagte natürlich an keiner Stelle.
Genau, aber das ist, was von mir, bei mir als Leser ein Problem ist.
Das ist die Idee eines totalitären Überwachungsstaats, bei dem es darum geht, dass man ein bisschen inklusiver als die Nazis ist.
Ja, für mich ist das hier, werden dieses Buch irgendwann DRM-frei und so weiter als Gesamtext zur Verfügung haben, dann gibt man das einfach GPT und sagt, du kennst ja die Standardwerke zur Aufarbeitung, wie hat Deutschland damals funktioniert. Gleiche mir ab, wie der Ideenhaushalt hier organisiert ist. Nur weil er den Deckel nicht drauf macht und sich da einfach duckmäuserisch, weil er es nicht aussprechen will, heißt das noch lange nicht, dass in dem Topf alles drin ist und von ihm zu einer Sache verrührt wurde. Ich meine, ein Führer, der sich die Unternehmer als Oligarchen unterwirft, um den Staat hierarchisch zu organisieren. Von Kinderzahl über werfähige Zuwächse und so weiter. Das ist einfach diese, und ich will jetzt nicht sagen, hier geht es mir nicht um eine Ideologie-Diskussion, sondern geht es mir um praktische Politik.
Genau.
Dass die Nazis noch eine Ideologie darüber hatten, das ist ja das, worunter er leidet. Ja, mussten die das mit dem Holocaust machen. Er glaubt ja, das kann man entknüpfen. Man kann es wie die Nazis machen, aber ohne Holocaust. Da denk ich mir, ne, also für diese Art von FOMO, Angst und was man alles braucht, muss man ein Feindbild erklären und dann auch durchziehen, dass man Holocaust tatsächlich veranstaltet. Nur dann ist so eine Idee hier denkbar.
Nur wirkt das Buch dann in vielen Passagen so harmlos oder so. Manchmal intuitiv einleuchtend. Also er sagt beispielsweise zwar an einer Stelle, Criticism and Value Judgements are forbidden. Das ist so eine Diagnose, die er oft hat. Und ich würde sagen, ja es gibt einen gewissen akademischen Diskurs und der wurde auch von so Leuten wie Bruno Latour vorangetrieben, dass man gar nicht mehr Kritik üben soll und das alles in ein größeres Netzwerk aufgehoben ist. Und es gibt auch die kunsttheoretische Annahme, dass das Schöne eigentlich überhaupt nichts in der Kunsttheorie verloren hat. Ja und wenn man sich so manchen Ramsch ansieht, der auf die Volksbühne oder so gehoben wird, dann stimmt das natürlich immer alles. Nur wird das hier mit einem ganz anderen Programm noch verknüpft und dann ist ja auch interessant, dass er immer wieder gegen diese Leute schießt, die ihr Leben genießen. Also das ist für ihn das große Problem und zwar nicht Milliardäre, die ihr Leben genießen, sondern dass normale Leute ein bisschen Freude am Leben haben. Ich habe ja diesen Essay geschrieben über Staatsbürgers Schuld, warum wir dem Staat nicht schuldig sind in der Anthologie, was ich mit Ann-Christin rausgegeben habe. Und da zitiere ich ja Treitschke, das war ein ultrakonservativer Historiker im 19. Jahrhundert. Und der sagt, während Friedenszeiten, da ist nur das Geld relevant, da konsumieren die Leute, dann ist die Freizeit plötzlich das, was die Leute interessiert. Und er spricht darüber äußerst despektierlich. Aber in Kriegszeiten sagt er, da geht es wieder um das Eigentliche, da erhebt sich der Einzelne wieder zu einem Ganzen und so weiter. So ist dann die Rede. Und im Prinzip ist dieser Treitschke-Diskurs aus dem 19. Jahrhundert, der dann im Prinzip wunderbar in den ersten Weltkrieg mündete, das, was jetzt hier von Karp uns in einem Update wiedergeliefert wird.
Also im Finale schreibt er hier und das ist dann einfach sehr widersprüchlich zu seinen eigenen Ausführungen. Aber den Aufbau einer technologischen Republik, eines reichen und blühenden und lautstark kreativen gemeinschaftlichen Experiments, bla bla bla. Hier ist nichts lautstark und hier ist nichts kreativ. Ja. Es mag gerecht und notwendig gewesen sein, die alte Ordnung zu demontieren. Wir sollten jetzt gemeinsam etwas an ihre Stelle setzen. Also mein Gegenprogramm zu diesem ganzen Doge-Kram, was sie da so veranstalten und versuchen, von dem ich jetzt auch denke, okay, mit internationaler Allianz vielleicht, ohne auf gar keinen Fall. Also das, was wir bei KAPI lesen, ist zum Glück zum Scheitern vorurteilt. Aber das europäische Gegenprogramm, ich möchte es nochmal sagen, ist das Museum. Wir haben einen zivilisatorischen Stand erreicht, bei dem wir sagen können, der ist schon ganz schön genug, er muss nur ein bisschen anders verteilt werden. Also noch mehr Wohlstand, würde ich wieder vorsichtig sein, so auch klimagedingt so. Wenn jeder zum Friseur einfach fünf Minuten über die Straße geht, statt ich steige in meinen Chat und fliege zum Pieperpoo und so. Nee, das ist alles Blödsinn. Also die kleine Stadt, 15 Minuten, alles zu Fuß, Familie, also mit Familie meine ich auch mein Familienbegriff, also Family and Friends sind alle erreichbar. Das reicht. So und ab hier sollte dann einfach gelten, wenn wir in einem Museum sind und uns fällt dort irgendeine Münze runter, dann sind wir erst mal bestürzt darüber, dass sie überhaupt runtergefallen ist. Dann gucken wir, ist sie noch heile? Ja, okay, gut, Glück gehabt. Erst danach gucken wir, was ist das eigentlich für eine Münze? War sie eigentlich wertvoll? Wie auch immer. Wir zertrümmern nicht alles und fragen danach, war überhaupt irgendwas Wertvolles dabei? Und stellen dann fest, ja, da war ganz schön vieles Wertvolles dabei. Also ich würde es genau umgedreht machen. Europa muss jetzt Museum sein. Bitte genau darauf achten, dass hier nichts mehr kaputt geht. Über die Schuhe bitte Schutz anziehen und so weiter. Nicht rennen, nicht zu laut sein. Keine große Gruppen, die irgendwie hier denken, das ist eine Party-Location oder so, sondern wir machen es jetzt mal ganz geruhsam. Erst mal ganz wichtig, nichts soll kaputt gehen. So, das wäre so meine Antwort. Und dann gehen wir Schritt für Schritt in so eine Zukunft, in der wir erstmal die Errungenschaften, die wir haben und die er ja nun auch zugesteht. Er sagt ja, wir leben alle wie Aristokraten, dabei können wir uns das doch gar nicht leisten. Ich sag, doch wir können es uns leisten. Das müssen nur ein paar Milliardäre mal ein bisschen abgeben. Wir können nicht die Hälfte unseres volkswirtschaftlichen Ertrags auf drei Konten überweisen, damit das da liegen bleibt und in Dubai verballert. Das ist das Problem. Und nicht, dass hier zu viele Leute einfach... Also in näher Sicht, dieses Buch finde ich ganz schrecklich, ganz gefährlich, dass solche Leute überhaupt Macht haben und sei es nur unternehmerische, finde ich falsch. Da sollte es Regeln geben, dass man das nicht zulässt, dass solche Produkte dann einfach bei der hessischen Polizei plötzlich verkauft werden. Das ist alles absurd.
Ich unterschreibe alles, was du sagst. The Technological Republic von Alexander C. Karp, dem Mitgründer von Palantir, ist sicherlich das schrecklichste Buch, das wir je im Salon gelesen haben. Aber es ist ein ungeheuer zeitgemäßes Buch, ein Buch, über das gesprochen werden muss. Denn diese Utopie, die uns hier verkauft wird, ist eine Dystopie, vor der wir uns fürchten sollten. Denn vieles von dem, was hier ausgebreitet wird, liegt schon in der Luft.
Alex Kaab ist derjenige, der im Hintergrund wahrscheinlich Strüppen zieht, während Elon Musk seinen Handlanger auf der Bühne steht und Hitlergrüße macht. Und dieses Buch ist der intellektuelle Hitlergruß, über den man einfach diskutieren muss.
Die Journalistin Colette Shade hat ein Buch geschrieben Why 2K? How the 2000s became everything. Es ist ein Essayband, bislang nur auf Englisch erschienen, weiß nicht, ob es da irgendwann noch eine Übersetzung geben wird. Und diese Autorin, die für The Buffalo, The New Republic und Gorka und so weiter schreibt, setzt sich mit den 2000ern auseinander. In der Zeit ist sie auch groß geworden. Das Buch beginnt damit, dass sie sich Ende der 90er-Jahre so einen aufblasbaren Sessel wünscht. Du kannst dich erinnern, dass die überall schon... Ah ja, und dass das für sie etwas ganz Großes war. Und diese Möbelstücke haben ja auch einen besonderen Namen bekommen, der hat dann etwas später Blobjacks. Also alles war so rund und war nicht eckig, war nicht kantig. Und in gewisser Weise strahlte dieser Sessel auch aus, wie die Zukunft wohl sein wird. Eben nichts mehr hakt und eckt und ist hart, sondern alles ist weich und rund und schön. Und die Zukunft könnte doch so toll sein. Und sie schreibt da einen Brief, den findet sie viele Jahre später, wie sie sich die Zukunft vorstellt. Und natürlich leben die Menschen in Frieden und mehr Wohlstand ist da.
Den hatte sie sich auch selbst geschrieben?
Den hatte sie sich selbst so verfasst und findet den später wieder und sieht dann, es ist dann doch alles ein bisschen anders gekommen. Sie hat hier Essays vorgelegt, die nicht diese 2000er Jahre verklären. Aber sie beginnt ihre Reise in die 2000er Jahre damit, dass sie sagt, dass sie sich dabei ertappt hat, bei YouTube sich alte Musikvideos anzusehen. Immer häufiger. Und dann hat sie eine Zeit lang gesagt, ja ich mache das ja, um zu recherchieren. Und irgendwann hat sie gemerkt, nee, ich gehe in die Zeit zurück, weil sie irgendwie noch unschuldig war. Vielleicht auch, weil mein Leben da noch so unabgeschlossen war, noch so voller Erwartungen war und vieles hat sich dann nicht so eingelöst, beziehungsweise die Zukunft ist nicht angenehmer geworden und die Blobjacks sind längst nicht mehr da, sondern was wir heute haben, ist eine große Verpanzerung bei den Autos ebenso wie auch sonst in der Gesellschaft. Und sie will jetzt aber auch diese 2000er-Jahre nicht verklären und sagen, da war alles so lustig und schön und sexy, sondern sie beschreibt beispielsweise in einem Kapitel, das einen sehr amüsanten Titel trägt, nämlich Larry Summers caused my eating disorder, wie natürlich Essstörungen sehr präsent werden in einer Zeit, in der die sogenannten Magermodels gezeigt werden. Was hat jetzt Larry Summers damit zu tun, der ja damals, also Ende der 90er Jahre dann zu Clinton administriert, so noch gehörte. Finanzminister. Nun, was hat er damit zu tun? Er war es ja, der mit anderen Harvard-Guys Russland diese Austeritätspolitik aufoktroyiert hat und dass die Menschen dort eine große Perspektivlosigkeit hatten. Und für junge Frauen gab es in Russland aber einen Traum, man könnte Supermodel werden. Und sie beschreibt dann, wie also Herr Scharen von Agenturleitern in die Provinzen von Russland und auch sonst in andere Provinzen Osteuropas fahren, um dort schon 12-, 13-jährige sehr dünne Mädchen zu casten, die dann plötzlich die Trendsetter werden für die Mode in Paris und Mailand. Und sie geht also sehr häufig in diesen Essays, das kann man natürlich auch kritisieren, von sich aus. Kommt dann aber bei anderem an und sie assoziiert, zum Teil sehr wild, digitales, mit popkulturellem, mit politischem oder dann auch mit solchen ökonomischen Fragen. Sie beschreibt, wie sie den Onkel immer wieder besuchen. Der Onkel war eigentlich so ein Vertreter der Counterculture, die jetzt eben Alex Carpen in seinem Buch kritisiert hat. Aber irgendwann hat er sich dann den Bart abrasiert und die Haare frisiert und einen Anzug angezogen und dann hat er Karriere bei Intel gemacht. Und dann war so viel Geld da, dass man auch noch in Start-ups investiert hat. Und so wurde er immer reicher und reicher. Und sie erzählt dann eine Anekdote, wie sie Anfang der 2000er mit ihm in San Francisco spazieren geht. Und plötzlich kommt ein Mann an, der sie bedroht, der verwahrlost aussieht und sehr, sehr aggressiv ist. Und der Onkel verjagt ihn dann und sie ist dann erst so froh, dass sie da rausgekommen ist und denkt auch nicht weiter darüber nach, was wohl mit diesem Mann ist. Aber es ist natürlich die Obdachlosigkeit, die die Gentrifizierung durch das Silicon Valley produziert hat, wird ihr erst später klar. Und das ist ganz interessant, dass sie in diesen Essays immer wieder was beschreibt, was vielleicht auch eine hübsche Seite hat und dann wie das aber später nochmal eine andere politische Dimension bekommt. Oder worüber sie aufgespricht ist, wie sehr MTV, also der Musiksender, alles beherrscht hat. Also auch unsere Vorstellungen von Sexualität, von Ästhetik, von Liebe, wie sehr das dadurch geprägt war. Sie spricht über Klimaschutz und Al Gore, der damals diesen Film macht, eine unbequeme Wahrheit. Und wie zugleich aber immer mehr Leute dazu übergehen, einen SUV sich anzuschaffen. Sie spricht von dieser über hypersexualisierten MTV-Generation, die aber zugleich dann auch so etwas wie den Purity Ring hervorbringt. Also das werden manche Leute noch erinnern. Britney Spears hatte so einen, Jessica Simpson und auch andere. Das war dann, wenn die ihren Freund hatten, hat jeder so einen Ring angezogen. Wir sprechen heute noch über einen anderen Ring. Er hat so einen Ring angezogen, um damit deutlich zu machen, dass sie sich aufsparen mit dem Sex bis zur Ehe. Und dass das interessant war, dass man Britney Spears die ganze Zeit in solchen fast pornografischen Outfits rumlaufen ließ und dann aber zugleich diese Reinheit und diese Religiosität auch damit reingebracht hat. Viel geht es immer wieder auch um diese Widersprüchlichkeit einer Gesellschaft, die zum Teil immer inklusiver wird, aber auch die Bush-Administration in der Zeit ihre, ja wie soll man es ausdrücken, ihr Machtspielchen spielt. Das heißt, es ist ein Buch, das einen nochmal in so eine Zeitkapsel setzt und man hat aber dann doch auch viele, viele Tendenzen, die wir heute in radikalisierter Form finden, damals schon präsent. Ja, also Drill Baby Drill, was wir heute beispielsweise von Donald Trump hören, ist ja etwas, was den Wahlkampf von Sarah Palin damals bestimmt hatte. Sie hat Drill Baby Drill gesagt und meinte das durchaus auch ein bisschen sexuell. Ja und Trump greift das jetzt wieder auf. Also inwie präsent diese 2000er Jahre, in denen Marc Andreessen und viele andere im Silicon Valley unglaublich reich waren, inwieweit das alles bringt, das kann man in diesen sehr leichten, amüsanten, vielleicht manchmal ein bisschen banalen, aber doch immer ganz hübschen Essays gut nachlesen. Ich empfehle das Buch also für die Leute, die eine Zeitreise machen wollen oder die vielleicht sehen wollen, wie unschuldig in gewisser Weise manches auch damals war, was heute längst die Unschuld verloren hat und weshalb vielleicht auch eine solche Nostalgiewelle so stark ist, weil eigentlich viele genau nicht jetzt vor den Karren gespannt werden wollen eines Alexander Carp oder sonst irgendwen, sondern sich eigentlich dahin zurücksehnen, wieder in so einem Blockjacked zu sitzen, einem aufblasbaren Sessel und darauf zu warten, welches Musikvideo Lil Kim oder Britney Spears wohl als nächstes veröffentlichen werden.
Lass mich raten, die Autorin ist hier eingegangen, 85?
In etwa glaube ich, es steht hier nicht, aber es wird so sein, also sie hat die Zeit erlebt und durchlitten kann man sagen.
Sehr gut. Dann würde ich sagen, bleiben wir mal so ein bisschen beim Thema. Es geht um junge Menschen. Förderung der frühen Bildung auch in alternden Gesellschaften, warum es ein Bundesprogramm für Kitas braucht, schreibt also Katharina Spieß, die Direktorin des Bundesinstituts für Bevölkerungsforschung. Trockener geht es nicht. Also wir sind hier sozusagen im Verwaltungsapparat der Alten Republik. Danke für die Zuschrift. Ich hab leider den Namen nicht präsent, aber es ist eine höhere Lesempfehlung. Denn der Wirtschaftsdienst, Zeitschrift für Wirtschaftspolitik, ich kannte sie nicht. Sie scheint mir Special Interest zu sein, aber sie ist öffentlich online ganz gut verfügbar.
Der Wirtschaftsdienst vom Bundestag?
Ach, das ist der Wirtschaftsdienst. Na dann wird wahrscheinlich der Bundestag hier mitlesen, je nachdem in welchen Turbulenzen.
Also mir ist das jetzt von Molchan für alle so bekannt. Ich nehme anders.
Das ist gar nicht, dass sie einen Wirtschaftsdienst haben. Ich dachte, es gibt nur die wissenschaftlichen Dienste und dann stellt man denen halt seine Fragen. Aber wie auch immer, also ist gar nicht so wichtig. Aber kann durchaus sein. Denn das politische Programm, das hier gefordert wird, ist ganz gut begründet, möchte ich doch sagen. Deutschland altert und immer mehr Babyboomer werden in den Ruhestand eintreten. Soweit bekannt, sie nennt nochmal die Zahl. Menschen im erwerbsfähigen Alter, im Erwerbsalter bis Ende der 2050er Jahre werden um 14 bis 29 Prozent abnehmen. Daumenregel, Pi mal Daumen, in den nächsten 25 Jahren wird das Erwerbspersonenpotenzial um 25 Prozent sinken. 25 Jahre, 25 Prozent. Also wenn wir heute sagen, in Deutschland arbeiten 45 Millionen Menschen, dann müssen wir davon jetzt ein Viertel abziehen und dann sagen wir 2050 arbeiten. Und dann kann man ja überlegen, sind es noch über oder unter 30 oder sowas. Also es ist ein rapides abbauen.
Aber da haben wir doch so viele Leerstände, dann was machen wir denn dann? Jetzt haben wir gerade eine Wohnungsnot.
Naja, die Leute sterben ja nicht sofort nur weil sie uns ein Berufsleben ausscheiden, die sind ja Rentenadern.
Okay, aber das eine hängt ja mit dem anderen auch mal irgendwann dann zusammen. Also das heißt, es werden ja nicht mehr Menschen in Deutschland dann leben. Es werden ja auch dann weniger Menschen im Ganzen werden. Also erst geht man meistens, so soll es sein, aus der Arbeit und irgendwann tritt man auch aus dem Leben.
Diese Leute, die mit 65 in Rente gehen, sind jetzt nicht mit 85 alle nicht mehr da. Das dauert, also die sind sehr lange in ihrer Rentenzeit. Also in der Hinsicht, wenn wir jetzt sagen, naja, die gehen jetzt in Rente, aber in 20 Jahren dann, ja, also irgendwann gibt es natürlich eine Lebenserwartung, die dann greift, aber ich würde mal sagen, mindestens 15 im Schnitt 17 Jahre sind die dann schon noch da. Also wir haben einen Mehrbedarf an nicht nur, also die Leute wollen ja, die wollen vielleicht aufs Land, nicht unbedingt. Viele bleiben natürlich da leben, wo sie leben und wir sind in urbanisierter Region. Plus urban heißt, man kann auch schon mal im dritten Stock wohnen ohne Fahrstuhl oder am vierten. Das heißt, diese Leute machen nicht plötzlich eine Wohnung frei, sondern die brauchen da noch Personal. Also es ist alles sehr kritisch, möchte ich sagen. Es ist wirklich sehr kritisch. Wenn ich hier sage, in 25 Jahren wird das Erwerbspersonpotenzial um 25 Prozent sinken, ist das sehr dramatisch. Das ist auch weltweit beispiellos. Vielleicht Südkorea noch, aber ansonsten. Na gut, wir brauchen also bessere Schüler. Damit meine ich nicht bessere Menschen, sondern der Schüler teilt die Schule, muss hier besser werden. Mehr Kompetenz. Es muss viel früher angesetzt werden, nämlich bereits bei der frühen Bildung. Denn sie macht ein ganz einfaches Prinzip. Ein Zweitklässler und ein Drittklässler verbessert sich immer um dasselbe im Verhältnis zu sich selbst. Das heißt, wenn man klüger in die Schule kommt mit mehr Fähigkeiten, ist auch danach die Entwicklung besser. Denn man macht nicht plötzlich Sprünge von der zweiten zur dritten Klasse. Wenn man mit niedrigem Niveau startet, bleibt man auf niedrigem Niveau. Weshalb sie sagt, es muss ganz früh angesetzt werden, das wird vor allem kostenspielig. Sie kommt dann kurz auf diese Theorie der Fähigkeitsentwicklungen, weshalb man eben besonders effektiv und effizient relativ früh ansetzen muss. Da stellt sich ein besonderes Problem, umso kleiner die Kinder, umso früher, umso mehr sind sie noch bei der Familie. Auf Schüler haben wir Zugriff, 6-7 Stunden am Tag. Außer der Haushalt ist knapp, dann werden 4 Schulstunden gestrichen. Aber das ist bei Schülern so. Bei Kindergartenkindern Ü3, ja, die haben ein Recht auf Kindergarten, nehmen den auch weiter. Was ist eigentlich mit den Ü3-Kindern? Und da sagt sie, ja, da muss man dann die Familien fördern. Also da ist einfach die Familie die Einflugsschneiße. Frühe Bildung erfolgt zuallererst und von Anfang an in der Familie. Das ist der erste Bildungsort. Hier braucht man frühe Bildungserleichterungen und sie kommt auf das Beispiel Vorlesen zu sprechen. Denn Vorlesen wissen wir ja, bringt uns am meisten weiter. Was bedeutet, wenn wir klügere Schüler, Studenten, Arbeitnehmer, Auszubildende wollen, müssen wir die Eltern befähigen, ihren Kindern vorzulesen. Was bedeutet, Studien immer nur aus Amerika, das ist ganz erstaunlich. Also sie kann kein Studienwissen aus Deutschland zu irgendeiner Fragestellung hier bringen. Das ist alles nur amerikanisch. Wo will man denken, da kümmert sich ja keiner darum. Doch, doch, also die Forschung ist doch da. Allein den Eltern per SMS zu sagen, es ist voll gut, wenn du deinem Kind vorliest, mach es doch heute Abend, steigert es schon um enorme Werte. Ich kann mir überlegen, okay, kriegen wir wenigstens das Geringste hin, die Eltern mal so einzubinden. Ich mache ja im Buch auch diese Argumentation, dass man sich um Kinder kümmern muss, um sie lieben zu lernen, sich mit ihrem Schicksal und so weiter zu befassen. Und diese Liebe entsteht nicht, ah ja, du hast es geboren, also es ist deins, sondern es ist ein soziales Phänomen, kein biologisches. Umso mehr man Zeit mit einem anderen Menschen verbringt, umso wichtiger wird er einem, was insbesondere bei diesen generationenübergreifenden Kind-Erwachsenen-Beziehungen zutrifft. Das kann also dann auch eine Pflegeelternschaft oder eine Oma sein oder wie auch immer eine Nachbarin. Nur man muss halt diese Beziehung fördern. Und da haben ältere Menschen eine Beziehung zum Kind und der Staat selbst hat eine Beziehung zum Kind. Und die müsste man dann intensivieren. Na ja, sie hat jedenfalls in diesem Text eine Sache, die ganz wichtig ist für uns, weil wir hier einen kollektiven Auftrag, wie ich sagen möchte, haben. Bei den jungen Menschen im Kindergarten, also U4 in dem Falle, haben wir es mit einem großen Problem zu tun, insbesondere bei Zweijährigen zum Beispiel. Denn wenn zu Hause überwiegend kein Deutsch gesprochen wird, dann bleiben diese Kinder auch überwiegend zu Hause. Sie vergleicht das hier mit 40 Prozent der Zweijährigen, werden betreut. Vergleichsgruppe bis zu 70 Prozent, wenn dann auch noch Armut eine Rolle spielt. Also Migration und Armut halten die Kinder vom Kindergarten fern, weil häufig diskriminiert wird beim Thema Zugang zum Kindergarten. Wir können uns das ja ungefähr so vorstellen. Es ist ja nicht so, dass man plötzlich feststellt, oh ich habe eine riesige klaffende Wunde am Fuß. Ich ruf jetzt mal einen Krankenwagen, dann kommt einfach einer und fährt dich ins Krankenhaus. Sondern du musst dich ja beim Kindergarten bewerben. Und wenn der Kindergarten sieht, ah da kommt schon wieder so eine ausländische Mutter, die hat bestimmt auch kein Geld, das wird super aufwendig mit der, wie können wir mit der reden und überhaupt, wenn wir mal irgendwas wollen, kann sie wieder keine Windeln mitgeben, weil Hartz IV ist aufgebraucht oder sowas. Dann sagen diese Kindergärten einfach nee. Das ist eins der größten Probleme in Deutschland, wie sie schreibt, dass wir einfach einen diskriminierenden Zugang zum Kindergarten haben, weil hier der Staat einfach wegschaut, man einfach die Trägerschaft abgibt, kennt man ja von den Kirchen. Die Kirchen sind dann der Träger, aber der Staat finanziert. Damit ist der Staat außen vor. Er hat ja die Träger, die das für ihn organisieren. Und die sagen sich dann, oh nee, die Familie kenn ich schon und so. Ja, lehnen wir mal ab, machen was kompliziert, wie auch immer. Also diese Kinder bleiben einfach überwiegend zu Hause, weil es diesen Zugang da nicht gibt. Also Migration und Armut. Sagt so, hier wird häufig diskriminiert. Und dann hat sie ein Punkte-Programm. Also zuerst Entwicklungsstand der Kinder früher erheben. Wir brauchen in Deutschland Forschung. Zu der Frage, was passiert eigentlich im Kindergarten und wie lässt sich das dann auch mit späteren Lebens- und Lernphasen verknüpfen. Mehr und nachhaltigeren Ausbau von frühen Hilfen. Also wenn jemand feststellt, ich bin schwanger, braucht er eine bessere Ansprechperson, eine besseren Adresse Staat. Dass man da immer allem nachrennen muss, ist einfach blöd. Ausbau von Kinderbetreuung sowieso, ist natürlich Pflichtprogramm. Familien gezielt über Kita-Zugänge und Kita-Leitung über die Bedeutung dieser Zugänge informieren. Da denke ich mir ja immer, aber sobald man es einmal mitgemacht hat, versteht man es. Man kriegt ja auch mit, wie die Kitas mit anderen Eltern reden. Also selber als privilegierter Typ. Mir fällt das ja nicht auf, aber ich höre dann die Geschichten der anderen. Sie sagt sogar, wir brauchen ein Opt-out-Verfahren. Dir steht der Kindergartenplatz erst mal zu, bis du selber sagst, ich nehme ihn aber nicht in Anspruch. Kennen wir ja von der Grundschule, es gibt ein Einzugsgebiet, das bedeutet, dieses Kind wird verpflichtend zum Schuljahresbeginn dort eingeschult. Und nicht, ach nee, fragen sie nochmal bei der anderen Schule oder sowas. Irgendso ein Völlefanz. Also man kann dieses Grundschulprinzip durchaus mal auf die Kinder ausweiten und das finde ich auch bei der Pflege super interessant. Kein Thema dieses Textes, aber ich will es mal nennen. Die stationäre Pflege können wir uns niemals leisten. Schon die ambulante ist zu teuer. Also wir werden es auch erleben, dass der Pflegediskurs dahin läuft zu sagen, sorry, kein freier Markt mehr, keine Formulare ausfüllen oder so. Das ist dein Pflegeein. Das ist die Adresse. Da leben Menschen, die werden vor Ort betreut und diejenigen, die dort als Pfleger arbeiten, schwärmen auch aus in die Straßenzüge drum herum. Je nach Einzugsgebiet. Also diese Art von der Staat kümmert sich und ist wieder da. Alleine dadurch, dass er ansprechbar ist, ist ein ganz zentrales Prinzip, wie ich finde. Schreib ich auch in wo.
Aber das würde ja bedeuten, dass dann ältere Leute nur müssten die dann das Pflegeheim in ihrem Umkreis nehmen.
Du kannst dir immer ein privates Pflegeheim buchen wie ein Hotel.
Ach so.
Gar kein Problem. Nur wenn du einen Pflegebedarf hast, weil dein Hausarzt feststellt, komm wir machen mal eine Pflegestufe. Das geht mir hier ein bisschen zu. Sie brauchen jetzt Hilfe. Dann gibt es eine Adresse wie eine Apotheke, zu der man dann hingeht. Statt einfach nur zu sagen, wir haben jetzt eine Pflegestufe, aber sorry. Wie, ach sie haben ein dreijähriges Kind, sorry. Wir haben leider keinen Platz. Also sie sagt opt out. Das finde ich schon sehr weitreichend. Das ist sehr gut. Und sie sagt ganz deutlich, Diskriminierungen bei dem Zugang zu Kitas dürfen nicht vorkommen, sondern hier müssen Strukturen geschaffen werden, die dies verhindern. Also da sieht man mal wieder, wir sind ein wahnsinnig rassistisches Land. Diese Familien kriegen es einfach mit und die anderen, die davon nicht betroffen sind, wie, was, hab ich noch nie gehört, wie du wirst die ganze Zeit kontrolliert. Sobald ein Polizist dich sieht, fragt er, was ist das für ein Fahrrad, und du sagst, das ist deins, ist mir noch nie passiert. Bei meinem Kumpel, Mutti, passiert das jede Woche. Also da sieht man es immer wieder. Einheitliche Mindeststandards, fragt man sich, gibt es die nicht? Anscheinend nicht. Mehr pädagogische Fachkräfte gewinnen und nicht einfach nur Pools von irgendwedem einstellen. Eltern und Kinder gemeinsam in Zentren für Familien adressieren. Also sozusagen dieses Stadtteilprinzip scheint mir super wichtig zu sein. Und sie fordert eben ein Bildungsfonds und Kita-Programm auf Bundesebene. Dies sollte ein Fonds sein, der von jährlichen Haushaltsverhandlungen ausgeschlossen wäre. Was haben wir für eine Diskussion? Alle lassen sich breit schlagen. Also ab 1% nicht mehr die Schuldenbremse. Super wichtig. Beim Thema Nachwuchs, Kinder, Zukunft? Nein, beim Thema Panzer, Raketen und dem ganzen Scheiß. Also wir sind mal wieder auf einem völlig falschen Track und hier wurde es uns für uns gut aufgeschrieben.
Lukas Maisel hat einen kurzen Roman geschrieben, 120 Seiten mit dem Titel Wie ein Mann nichts tat und so die Welt rettete. Wer ist dieser Mann? Er hat tatsächlich gelebt. Er heißt Stanislav Petrov und er hat in einem sowjetischen Raketenabwehrzentrum gearbeitet. Dieser Roman beginnt so und erst einmal ist vorangestellt, dass wir schon von Anfang an wissen, dass diese Geschichte gut ausgeht, sonst würden wir nämlich diesen Text nicht lesen können.
Die KI hätte den Abzug gedrückt, jetzt hören wir die Erfolgsgeschichte, warum es damals nicht passierte.
Ja, darum geht es im Nachwort nochmal, dass das ganz problematisch sei, dass das jetzt ausgelagert wird. Stanislaw Petro lebte mit Frau und Kindern in einem Städtchen, das auf keiner Karte zu finden war. Der Name des Städtchens war auch auf keinem Straßenschild oder Busfahrplan zu lesen. Wenn Petrovs Kinder ihre Großmutter in Odessa besuchten, durften sie niemandem erzählen, woher sie kamen. Fragte sie jemand danach, sollten sie das Gespräch abbrechen und wegrennen. Niemand außerhalb des Städtchens durfte wissen, dass es existierte. Ja, man ist also dort an einem geheimen Ort. Das Leben ist dort aber so wie gewöhnlich überall, nur ist es ein sehr herausgeputztes Städtchen. Es ist ja extra dafür errichtet worden und dieser Petro lebt dort, hat ein beschauliches Leben, bekommt dann eines Abends den Anruf, ob er eine Schicht übernehmen kann, denn ein Kollege ist krank und dann sagt er ja gut, wenn es denn sein muss, dann gehe ich dahin und dann geschieht etwas, nämlich um 0 Uhr 15. Es gibt einen Alarm und er liest auf roten Lettern C-T-A-P-T und das bedeutet Start. Eine Rakete muss aus den USA gestartet sein und der atomare Angriff scheint bevorzustehen. Alle warteten auf seinen Befehl, denn er ist es, der jetzt in dieser Befehlskette die Aufgabe hat, das zu bewerten, das dann an entsprechende Ranghöhere weiterzugeben und auch die anderen zu koordinieren, dies und das zu tun. Das ist ein Erstschlag, schrie ein Offizier. Wir müssen sofort zurückschlagen. Es war Offizier Mishin. Kein Wunder, dachte Petroff. Mishin hat noch nie starke Nerven gehabt. Mishin ist dieser Hahn, der noch vor dem Sonnenaufgang mit dem Krähen beginnt und die Hähne der umliegenden Höfe dazu bringt, mit einzustimmen. Mishin kräht herum und wenn die anderen Offiziere auch zu Krähen beginnen, Gott bewahre, dann habe ich ein Problem. Vor lauter Krähe wird niemand mehr auf mich hören, auf den Hahn, der als Einziger nicht kräht. Er beugte sich über das Mikrofon, setzt euch auf eure Plätze. Seine Stimme klang ruhig und fest. Er war überrascht, dass seine Stimme nicht zitterte oder brach. Gerade jetzt war es wichtig, eine ruhige und feste Stimme zu haben, eine Stimme, der man vertraute und der man gehorchte. Und dann geht dieser Petrov der Sache immer weiter nach. Was kann das sein? Er muss ja sehr schnell eigentlich entscheiden. Ist das wirklich so, dass es da nur diese eine Rakete gibt? Wollen die uns veräppeln, weil mit einer Rakete allein? Warum schicken sie nicht gleich 50 oder 100 oder 1000 los oder was auch immer? Was würde denn geschehen, fragt er sich, wenn er jetzt einfach Bescheid sagt, hier ist ein Angriff. Was würde weiter geschehen? Man würde Juri Antropov, das Staatsoberhaupt, in seinem Krankenbett wecken und er müsste noch schlaftrunken eine Entscheidung treffen. Und wie würde Antropov entscheiden? Als ehemaliger Chef des Geheimdienstes war ihm ein berufsbedingter Verfolgungswahn eigen. Er war überzeugt, dass die Amerikaner einen Angriff planten. Er ließ seine Spione vor amerikanischen Regierungsgebäuden parken. Sie sollten melden, wenn bis spät abends noch Licht brannte. Ein Atomkrieg, so schien er zu denken, konnte nur in verlassenen Ministerien geplant werden, in verschwörerischen Sitzungen nach Einbruch der Nacht, bei gedämpften Licht, keinesfalls am helllichten Tag. Andropov würde nicht erbleichen. Er würde nicht zittern wie sein Vorgänger Brezhnev. Brezhnev, so wird hier beschrieben, war einmal dort zu Gast und er sollte da mal auf diesen roten Knopf drücken, so als Beispiel. Und er hat sich dann zittern davon abgewandt, hat immer wieder gefragt, ob das jetzt wirklich so eine Probe nur sei oder ob er irgendetwas anrichtet. Antropov wäre ein anderer. Und selbst wenn er nicht myrisch aus einem Alptraum erwacht wäre, selbst wenn die Medikamente, die er gegen sein fortschreitendes Nierenversagen nahm, seinen Geist nicht trübten, er würde den roten Knopf drücken. Dessen war sich Stanislav Petrov sicher. Für einen Gegenschlag musste man nichts weiter tun, als die Kreiselkompasse der Raketen anzuwerfen und die Zielkoordinaten zu bestätigen. Dann würde sich Andropov wieder hinlegen, irgendein Lakei würde sein Bett in einen Bunker schieben, wo er weiter dämmern würde. Man sollte einem dahinsichenden nicht die Verantwortung für die Welt überlassen. Dessen ist er sich sicher. Na ja, und dann nimmt die Geschichte ihren Lauf. Wir wissen, sie ist gut ausgegangen, aber es ist vielleicht jetzt gerade ein sehr wichtiger und auch in der Prägnanzen, der das geschildert ist, sehr kluger Text darüber, wie schnell man in eine totale Eskalation hineingerät. Und ich musste auch dabei denken an diese Raketen, die dort an der polnischen Grenze eingeschlagen war. Und wir hatten sofort Strack Zimmermann und weitere, die bei Twitter geschrieben haben, das ist der Bündnisfall, das kommt von Russland. Und an diese musste ich denken, so Charaktere werden hier nämlich geschildert. Und was es dann eigentlich bedeutet, was dann wirklich das Heldenhafte wäre, nämlich besonnen zu sein. Also ein geradezu wichtiger, relevanter Roman, den man sich ruhig zugemütigieren sollte, wie ein Mann nichts tat und so die Welt rettete von Lukas Meisel. In einer sehr schönen, klaren, prägnanten Sprache mit ein paar wunderbaren Überlegungen zu der Zeit, in der wir heute leben.
Ja, all diese Leute, die hier beschrieben werden, als der Präsident ans Bett gefesselt, vom Alter gezeichnet und so weiter, die sind alle damals jünger gewesen als Trump, Biden, Putin heute.
Ja, naja.
So, wir lesen zwei Texte. Zum einen Kevin Roos in der New York Times. Wir kennen ihn ja. AI and Vibe Coding helped me to create my own software. Er ist kein Programmierer, sagt er. Wir sind alle keine Programmierer. Wir können also damit gut umgehen. Aber er hat mit Hilfe von KI Apps gebaut. In seiner eigenen Erfahrung aus, er war mal jung und hat Webseiten gebaut und Flash benutzt und so. Schön und gut, doch jetzt plötzlich ein Podcast-Transkript-Zusammenfasser. Ein Social Media Bookmark Organizer. Eine App, die ihm hilft herauszufinden, welche Möbel in seinen Kofferraum passen. Alles das aus seiner eigenen Software-Schmiede jetzt mit KI Hilfe. Eine App, die er auch veröffentlicht hat, Lunchbox Buddy. Man macht ein Foto vom Kühlschrank-Inhalt und dann wird einem ein Rezept gegeben, was man daraus so machen könnte. Es gibt also einen neuen KI-Trend, der heißt Vibe Coding. Er eröffnet allen Leuten, die Interesse daran haben, auch mal was zu kreieren, das zu machen, ohne eine Ahnung davon zu haben, müssen haben zu müssen, was sie da tun sind. Die können ja einfach prompten. Diese Namensgebung von Vibe Coding kommt von Andrej Karpathy. Das ist jemand, der bei OpenAI gearbeitet hat, bei Tesla und so weiter. Es scheint also ein Ding zu sein. Es ist eine Sache für Non-Technical-Hobbyists, die nun funktionierende Apps bauen. Man braucht nur eine Idee und etwas Geduld. Und Roos ruft dieses Zeitalter der Software for One aus. Also man stellt eine Software her, die nur eine Person benutzt. Es geht also nicht um und so weiter, wie was die letzten 20 Jahre hatte. Man macht so eine mega Idee und dann hat man passives Einkommen und wird Milliardär, weil man irgendwie 10 Millionen Downloads hat. AI Vertigo wird das genannt. Man fühlt sich so fünf Jahre in der Zukunft und weiß noch nicht so ganz genau, was man damit jetzt eigentlich machen soll. Und wenn man gehört, okay, dann baut man erst mal ein Podcast-Transkript-Zusammenfasser, ein Social-Media-Bookmark-Organizer und ein Lunchbox-Buddy und so. Nun gut. Selbst gescheitert ist allerdings an den einzigen Sachen, die er wirklich brauchte, nämlich ein Inbox-Autopilot. Also er hätte gerne, dass in seinem Stil E-Mails beantwortet werden und er dann eine Zusammenfassung seiner Konversation bekommt, die aber damit schon abgeschlossen sind. Das ist ihm nicht gelungen. Also er hat sehr viel Kram, dem man so nice to have, aber das einzige Wichtige ist ihm nicht gelungen. So. Und jetzt sagt er, wenn man ein junger Programmierer ist und jetzt kommt diese ganze KI-Sache dazu und so, da muss man sich ja fragen, lohnt es sich eigentlich noch, Coder zu werten oder sind wir wirklich nur noch ein paar Monate davon entfernt, dass es alles von alleine funktioniert? Und darauf antwortet nun Gary Marcus, ehemaliger Professor für Psychologie in New York, an der New York University und heute selber KI-Unternehmer, der relativ viel zum KI-Hype schon gesagt hat und eben so ein Newsletter führt, Marcus on AI heißt der. Und der findet Kevin Ruse Artikel Dreamy und widerspricht auch dieser neuen Realität, dass es da einfach gar keine Hürden mehr gibt und jeder einfach jetzt coden kann. Denn der Text verherrliche nur wieder Technologie, wie man das insbesondere von Kevin Ruse schon gewohnt ist, finden wir ja auch. Und ist durchaus anerkannt. Und dieser Text ist nicht nur enthousiastisch, sondern over the top. Also er geht ein bisschen zu weit. Und er sieht hier vier große Probleme. Das eine ist, die meisten App-Ideen gibt es schon. Das einzige, was neu ist, dass man sich halt was generieren lassen kann, was man ansonsten kopiert hätte. Dadurch kommen die ganzen Leute jetzt immer auf, ich hab mein eigenes Tetris gebaut. Und man fragt sich so, hast du wirklich dein eigenes Tetris gebaut? Also in der Library ist halt Tetris verfügbar. Und wenn man der KI sagt, bauen wir mal Tetris, baut es halt Tetris. Hätte man genauso gut runterladen können. Nur jetzt promptet man halt noch so Farben rein und sagt, das ist meine. Find ich erstmal, okay, ist ein guter Hinweis. Zweitens, wenn der generierte Code, den man dann hat, originell ist, was er eben nicht ist, wenn man einfach nur statt bei GitHub zu stöbern, sich Sachen generieren lässt, dann stößt man relativ zügig an so eine 80-20-Regel. Die kennen wir ja, das Pareto-Prinzip oder wie es heißt. 80 Prozent des Weges mühelos, aber die letzten 20 Prozent, da kriegt man dann eben doch nicht seinen Inbox-Autopilot und so. Also da scheitert es dann. Dafür braucht man dann menschliche Kreativität, weshalb man sich selbst wieder, sich selbst und seine Limitierung unterwirft und nur die Sachen macht, die halt einfach so funktionieren per prompt. Also man stößt jetzt nicht wirklich in neue Gefilde vor. Drittens, dieser Code, den man sich durch prompten herbauen lässt, den versteht man selber nicht, weil man ihn nicht lesen kann. Aber auch andere, die ihn lesen könnten, verstehen ihn relativ wenig, weil es ja nicht ihr eigenes Projekt ist, das sie entwickelt haben, sondern sie stehen halt vor so einer riesigen Wand an Text und müssen dann erst mal gucken, was hier wie zusammenhängt, was bedeutet. Darauf kann man gar nicht aufbauen. Also hier gibt es keine Maintenance, hier gibt es keine Pflege. Sobald sich ein System ändert, das hat Kevin Drews auch beschrieben, er brauchte halt eine Software, die ihm das Foto ausliest. Also hat er da ein relativ teures, ich verstehe Fotos, KI-System gebucht. Nur in dem Moment, wo er die App veröffentlicht, muss er halt eine kostenlose Version benutzen und dann wird das Bild nicht mehr so gut ausgelesen, funktioniert dann noch das Zusammenspiel mit dem Auswertungscode, den man da hinterhergepromptet hat. Wenn ja, Glück, wenn nicht, dich, setzt man sich dann wirklich hin und baut das nach und so. Es ist alles sehr schwierig. Und er macht auch diese generelle Kritik, dass Kevin Ruse relativ viel Silicon Valley in Ideologie channeln, channelt, aber sie nicht challenged. Diesen Unterschied als so begrifflich finde ich eh geil, channel, challenge, kann man sich häufiger mal unterwerfen, wenn man so Sachen beobachtet. Es gibt heute schon eigentlich zu wenig Nachwuchs beim Programmieren. Ach. Das Silicon Valley lässt zwar jetzt viele Leute gehen und so, aber die Programmierer stellen dann doch unter sich fest, dass manche Leute einfach programmieren können und die anderen sind zwar auch Programmierer, aber so richtig unterscheidet das jetzt nicht. Also man würde nicht wirklich erkennen, ob das jetzt KI generiert ist oder von der Qualität her. Also es gibt eh schon zu wenig Nachwuchs und jetzt wird hier nochmal ausgedünnt, auch weil die Leute so unklaren geblieben lassen, was jetzt in der Zukunft ist, sondern jetzt kommt so Kevin Drews und sagt, wir brauchen keine Coder mehr, wir können das alles selbst. Und die Unternehmen denken sich so, nee, wäre doch schon ganz cool. Also die, die wir Einblick haben, wir können jetzt nicht die Jugend so entmutigen. Weshalb in China das eben auch anders funktioniert. Also in China gibt es halt Bildungsprogramme, in denen du Coding lernst. So wie man das hier auch studiert, nur da werden halt diese Studiengänge nicht einfach, ja, brauchen wir doch nicht. Und erst recht gibt es keine unternehmerische Ideologie, die sagt, ja, komm direkt zu uns, du musst gar nicht studieren, sondern da geht man noch mal das Bildungsprogramm durch. Auch wenn man heute augenscheinlich denkt, brauchen wir ja gar nicht mehr. Aber doch wird man schon noch brauchen, denn der Markus sagt hier, in den nächsten Jahrzehnten werden immer Softwarearchitekten gebraucht, die auch wenn sie das einzelne Fenster nicht in das Gebäude einsetzen, trotzdem nachvollziehen müssen und verstehen müssen, was da grad passiert. Ob man jetzt zu einem Kollegen an den Schreibtisch geht und mit ihm die Software zu besprechen oder eine KI konsultiert, ist dann egal, aber man muss sich auskennen damit. Irgendwer muss den Blick haben. Ich würde dann auch noch mal so ein paar Kritiken hinterher schieben, denn dieses ganze Gehype insgesamt, also diese Art von Tetris, ich hab meinen Pac-Man gebaut und so, da unterwirft man sich ja auch nur wieder einer Normierung, die schon da ist. Also man baut keine eigenen Erwartungen, man hat keine eigenen Erwartungen, sondern man sagt sich so, ich kenne da so ein Spiel, Pac-Man, das bau ich mir jetzt mal nach. Eigentlich geht es ja um die Spielidee Pac-Man und nicht darum, ob man sie umsetzen kann. Und das war ja auch damals schon so. Diese ganze Nintendo-Geschichte ist ja eine von, wir haben eine Spielidee und dann setzen wir sie in Software um. Wir setzen uns nicht hin und gucken, was uns die Software so bietet und dann sagen wir, okay, das ist jetzt ein fertiges Projekt, sondern es funktioniert eigentlich genau umgedreht. Man braucht so einen inspirativen Zusammenhang.
Es ist eigentlich nur so eine Individualisierung, die man vornehmen kann, ganz so wie man in Online-Shops heute nicht einfach nur Sneaker bestellen kann, sondern gerne hätte man noch den Namen drauf.
Man promptet sich halt in die Schule zusammen. Ich hab ja auch so ein Jahr, wo ich 18 Fragen bei Nike beantworten musste, weil 18 Stoff-Leder-Lappen mit unterschiedlichen Farben kombinierbar sind. Ich hab natürlich alle grün genommen. Und er macht hier noch ein interessantes Beispiel. Wir haben eine inzwischen schon jahrzehnteüberdauernde Idee davon, dass wir keine Spezialistenärzte mehr brauchen, weil die KI das immer besser kann. Also diese Laborsituation, jemand, der gar keinen Kontakt mit dem Patienten hat, bekommt einfach nur ein Röntgenbild, schaut sich das an und jetzt kommt die KI und sagt, ich kann mir das viel besser anschauen und so weiter und so fort. Es gibt keinen einzigen Bereich in der Medizin, in dem es jemals hieß, davon haben wir zu viel Personal. Nie. Also die KI hat hier nie jemanden aussortiert. So und diese Art von, aber demnächst könnte das die KI, die darf man einfach nicht zulassen. Also das ist einfach ein völlig bananer Gedanke. Von daher ist ja dieser ganze Ansatz zu sagen, Software-Ingenieure brauchen wir nicht, weil wenn die KI eins kann, dann mit Computer kommunizieren. Das kann sie ja wohl alleine machen und so. Nein, gar nicht. Also wir brauchen alle Ärzte, auch wenn ich Ihnen gesagt würde, die KI würde ich ersetzen. Wir brauchen alle Software-Ingenieure, auch wenn es heißt, die KI würde das ersetzen und so. Das führt alles in die Irre. Und wenn man unter diesem Gesichtspunkt, wenn man den Kevin-Ruze-Text nochmal durchgeht und auch hört, wie er in seinem Podcast darüber spricht, ja, für die Unbedarften hat sich ein neuer Spielplatz ergeben. Aber darauf lässt sich nichts begründen. Es ist einfach kein Fundament für Gesellschaft, wenn es auf dem Spielplatz ein bisschen mehr Spaß macht. Oder auch die Eltern jetzt mal Spaß haben auf dem Spielplatz oder so. Das führt einfach in die Irre. Und hier an diesem Beispiel, an diesem Rumgehype, dass man jetzt mit diesen ganzen, wie sie alle heißen, den Dingern selber coden kann. Das kann man übrigens auch in der deutschen Community nachhören. Also hier Tim Pritlav und so weiter, der jetzt auch auf dem Kongress mit seinem großen 23 Zoll Computerbildschirm da anreiste, um einfach vor Ort auch noch so ein bisschen. Ja, es bringt die Leute, die schon Programmiererfahrung haben, jetzt wieder zurück, weil es nicht mehr so anstrengend ist zu programmieren. Aber am Ende ist es dann doch deren originelle Idee, die dann umgesetzt wird. Und wenn die KI da nicht mitspielt, müssen sie halt doch nochmal händisch ran. Aber um es umgedreht zu machen. Ich kann gar nicht händisch rangehen und lobe jetzt ein Jahrzehnt, die Software wird es schon richten und die KI macht das am Ende selbst, wird wirklich krass in die Irre führen. Also in der Ansicht würde ich sagen, so toll die New York Times auch immer ist, ich lese jetzt doch vermehrt auch diese ganzen Newsletter. Wir werden mal einen Salon rund um Blick machen von Newslettern, von denen ich glaube, dass man sie lesen sollte, denn das ist wirklich eine sehr sehr sehr lebendige Landschaft, die es da jetzt gibt, zum Beispiel von diesem Markus on AI, das ist wirklich sehr gut.
In der FAZ berichtet Stefan Locke, dass es immer mehr zu Gewalt kommt, wenn in der Ukraine rekrutiert wird. So beginnt der Text. In der Ukraine häufen sich Fälle, in denen sich Männer, die zur Armee einberufen werden sollen, mit Gewalt dagegen wehren. Für Aufsehen sorgt ein Fall in der zentral ukrainischen Stadt Poltava, wo am Samstag ein Mann einen für die Einberufung verantwortlichen Offizier des Gebietswehramtes Poltava erschossen hat. Eine Erklärung der ukrainischen Armee zur Folge griff der Mann an einer Tankstelle eine Gruppe frisch eingezogener Männer an, die sich auf dem Weg zu einem Ausbildungszentrum befanden. Und so hat der Tatverdächtige dann es zu lesen mit Sturmhaube, den Offizier mit einem Jagdgewehr bedroht und dann noch aufgefordert, dass er die Waffe übergeben bekommt. Der hat sich dann geweigert und dann kam es eben dazu, dass der Angreifer das Sturmgewehr des Getöteten dann gegriffen hat und dann mit einem der eingezogenen Männer geflohen ist und dann wurden aber beide später von der ukrainischen Polizei festgenommen. Weiter heißt es in dem Text, der Angriff reiht sich ein in eine Folge von Gewalt gegen die Rekrutierungsinfrastruktur der Ukraine. Ebenfalls am Samstag hatte in Rivne im Nordwesten des Landes ein Eingreifer, einen Sprengsatz in ein Rekrutierungszentrum geworfen, wobei ein Mensch getötet und sechs weitere verletzt wurden. Ein ähnlicher Vorfall ereignete sich am Sonntag in einer Rekrutierungsstelle im ostukrainischen Pavlograd, wobei ein Soldat verletzt wurde. Wir sehen also, man versucht mit aller Gewalt im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, irgendwie dieser ukrainischen Armee zu entgehen, der Einberufung zu entgehen. Man hofft in irgendeiner Weise noch vielleicht andere mitzubefreien oder handelt schon in deren Auftrag. Da sind schon welche geschnappt worden, dann sagen die jetzt ziehe ich los und versuche die anderen frei zu boxen.
Ja, was ich dir auch vorhin versucht habe zu sagen.
Du hast ja auch schon im letzten Podcast auch schon mal betont.
Also diese Familienfrage wird, da geht es hier ans Eingemachte. Es gibt immer ein spezifisches Verhältnis von Außen- und Innenpolitik. Und wenn man außenpolitisch in einem Krieg ist, ist man auch innenpolitisch in einem Krieg. Ein Krieg geht immer mit einem Bürgerkrieg einher.
Ja, dieser Artikel ist nicht gut, weil er das auch quasi noch so rechtfertig. Also es wird dann da einfach geschrieben, wer mindestens 25 Jahre alt ist und keinen Hinderungsgrund vorweisen kann, wird in der Regel sofort mitgenommen. Dabei müssen die Rekrutierer zum Teil selbst zu Gewalt greifen, was in der Öffentlichkeit nicht verborgen bleibt und auf den Zorn aneilt. Das liegt am korrupten Strukturen, die es Familien mit Vermögen und Beziehungen ermöglichen, ihre Männer vom Wehrdienst zu befreien. Ja, das mag nochmal den Zorn besonders groß machen, aber auch wenn das ganz gerecht wäre und alle dort eingezogen werden würden, wollen die Eltern ja trotzdem nicht, dass ihre Kinder eingezogen werden und verstecken die Männer sich trotzdem davor, weil sie wissen, was ihnen da an der Front blüht. Es hat sich auch herumgesprochen, heißt es dann da, dass Männer, die von der Straße weg rekrutiert werden, anders als bei freiwilliger Meldung, keine Mitsprache mehr über ihre Verwendung haben und sich nach kurzer Grundausbildung oft an vorderster Front wiederfinden. Das heißt, die wissen, dass sie Kanonenfutter werden. Und ich will hier nochmal ganz ausdrücklich sagen, das ist nichts, was man unterstützen sollte. Man wird nicht zum Putin getreuen, wenn man das kritisiert. Man kann hier nicht sagen, ist eben Krieg, so läuft es.
Muss ja.
Muss ja. Jeder muss seinen Beitrag leisten und das am liebsten noch dann aus irgendeinem fernen Land zugerufen, diesen Leuten. Nein, das darf einfach nicht sein. Und deshalb sieht man an diesen Fällen, die jetzt hier in der FAZ auch geschildert werden, man findet es ja jetzt überall, man kann weitere solche Artikel hervorkramen, dass das ein großes Problem ist und dass dieser Anfangsenthusiasmus, der durchaus bei vielen da war, längst verflogen ist und die auch natürlich wissen, was passiert und die kriegen auch die Nachrichten mit und sehen auch wohin das alles auf Dauer führen wird. Und dass dieser Krieg nicht militärisch zu gewinnen ist, wie Millie schon im November 22 feststellte, wissen Leute im März 25 nun allemal. Und sich damit gemein zu machen ist grundfalsch. Und dass das nicht größer thematisiert wird, dass man nicht sagt, wer nicht will, wer fliehen will, soll fliehen. Eigentlich das, worauf man sich mal geeinigt hatte. Darauf basierte im Prinzip auch unsere Flüchtlingspolitik von Angela Merkel im Jahr 2015. Ist eigentlich skandalös.
Auch skandalös, wir haben schon häufiger darüber gesprochen, die Reichweite verpflichtet uns, da ein Auge drauf zu haben, was ist los bei Haus und Hopf.
Ja.
Und in einer Thematisierung der Lebensregeln von Rockefeller, auf die wir noch zu sprechen kommen, Clips liegen bereit. Ich glaube, es war in diesem Podcast oder davor oder danach, je nachdem. Er wird auch über das Lieblingsbuch von Philipp Hopf gesprochen. Er macht das relativ spontan. Wir hören deswegen ausnahmsweise mal ein Clip im Salon um uns in die Tonalität. Okay, da wird ein Buch vorgestellt.
Das Lieblingsbuch von Philipp Hopf.
Das wird uns sehr enthusiastisch, aber nicht inhaltlich vorgestellt, weshalb wir die inhaltlichen Sachen soweit nacharbeiten. Aber wir steigen mit dem Enthusiasmus von Philipp Hopf ein.
Also ich darf mal tippen, es ist weder der Zauberwerk noch Effie Priest.
Nein, das ist ja Literatur. Wo sind da der Nutzwert? Das ist natürlich anderes.
Ich habe das Buch, ob es jetzt 34, 35 oder 36 mal, aber deutlich über 30 mal gelesen. Ich kann das gerne mal auch hier in dem Podcast. In den früheren Folgen habe ich das öfters dabei gehabt. Es ist total zerfleddert, es fallen viele Seiten raus. Ich habe in diesem Buch über fast ein Jahrzehnt lang jeden einzelnen Tag gelesen. Es geht um das Buch von Napoleon Hill, ein absoluter Weltliteratur, Think and Grow Rich, Denke nach und werde reich und das umfasst die Prinzipien des Erfolges und eben wie es schon im Titel heißt, Reichwerdens. Und weil ich eben auch irgendwann mal Millionär sein möchte, habe ich mir eben damals gesagt, dieses Buch lese ich mir durch und zwar sehr genau und sehr oft, damit ich das Ganze auch manifestiere. Und ich meine, das ist mir ganz gut gelungen bis heute.
So, das ist ja schon maximal irrsinnig. Wenn man sich das mal vorstellt, dass man ein Buch zehn Jahre lang sich damit beschäftigt. Das machen vielleicht Bibel-Exegiten.
Ja, darum geht es ja hier wahrscheinlich.
Aber sonst ist es ja nun schon eigentlich ein Eingeständnis an die eigene Beschränktheit, oder? Dass man sagt, ich muss da mich zehn Jahre lang mit beschäftigen. Und jetzt glaubt man, weil man tatsächlich reich geworden ist, dass es an dem Buch gelegen hat. Man muss ja eher so fragen, es ist ja erstaunlich, dass er trotz dieser intensiven Lektüre, noch Zeit hatte Geld zu verdienen.
Genau so. Du steigst jetzt schon mit sehr viel harten Urteilen ein, auf die komm ich auch gleich zu sprechen. Vorher will ich aber eine Erlaubnisstruktur dafür geben, blöd zu finden, was ich jetzt sage. Denn die Einflugsschneise ist für die Kritiker uns aus Podcastern, Stefan, du hast ja dieses Buch gar nicht gelesen. Nee, hab ich nicht gelesen. Ich habe Fragen an dieses Buch. Das heißt nicht, dass ich mich hinsetze und dieses Buch komplett lese, sondern ich stelle die Fragen natürlich klot. Wir haben sie also mit Think and Grow Rich von Napoleon Hill mit einer fast 100-jährigen Literatur zu tun. Also sie erschien 1937. Das heißt, sie ist in allen Books 1, 2, 3 Corporate drin. Also die ganzen KI-Modelle sind darauf trainiert. Wir müssen das jetzt nicht als Material mitgeben, sondern das Trainingsmaterial selbst enthält dieses Zeug. Es geht um ein Buch, das 20-jährige Forschung zusammenfasst. Der Hill ist also den Persönlichkeiten seiner Zeit nachgegangen, zum Beispiel Andrew Carnegie oder Carnegie, Carnegie, wie man heute auch gern sagt, Henry Ford, Thomas Edison und so weiter. Also die großen erfolgreichen Unternehmer ihrer Zeit. Und es werden herausdestilliert 13 Prinzipien für finanziellen Erfolg und persönliche Entwicklung. Und wir wissen ja, persönliche Entwicklung wird im finanziellen Erfolg gemessen. Also diese 100 Jahre hat diese Ideologie durchgehalten. Schlüsselprinzipien dieser persönlichen Entwicklung sind die Kraft des Wunsches, starkes Verlangen als Grundlage für Erfolg, der Glaube an sich selbst, Überzeugung und Selbstvertrauen als Erfolgsfaktoren, Autosuggestion, positive Selbstbestärkung und mentale Programmierung, Vorstellungskraft, kreative Visualisierung von Zielen. Also viel davon begegnet uns heute ganz oft. Durchhaltevermögen, Beharrlichkeit trotz Rückschläge, spezialisiertes Wissen, Fokus auf spezifische Expertise, organisierte Planung, strukturierte Herangehensweisen. Das ist ja eine tolle Liste, aber hier geht es ja wirklich nur um Sachen, die ich mit mir selber kläre. Stehe ich morgens auf, lese ich dieses Buch, bin ich hartnäckig, habe ich das richtige Einstellungen und Wunschvorstellungen und so weiter. Ich hatte also eine spezifische Frage, als ich diesem Ding nachging und habe mich deswegen dann entschieden, das zur Salon-Lektüre zu machen. Gibt es eine soziale Dimension in diesem Buch? Denn wir wissen ja, diese Leute, die damals sehr viel Geld verdient haben, sind Chefs von Organisationen gewesen. Organisationen sind soziale Gebilde. Wenn wir heute sagen, ein Milliardär hat ganz schön viel Geld, dann ist es nicht sein Erfolg, sondern dann haben ganz schön viele Leute dafür gearbeitet. Aber er hat eine juristische Struktur geschaffen, die ihn enttitelt hat, den Mehrwert einzusacken. Also es ist im Grunde schon diese einfache marxistische Diskussion. Nun gut, die Antwort. Gibt es eine soziale Dimension in diesem Buch? Ja, allerdings nur particularistisch. Es gibt Mastermind-Gruppen, also die Betonung kollektiver Intelligenz. Es gibt Mentorenschaften und Unterstützung. Erfolgreiche Menschen agieren selten allein. Dienstleistungsmentalität, Reichtum entsteht durch Wertschöpfung für andere, von der man dann selbst profitiert. Zwischenmenschliche Fähigkeiten, Wichtigkeit von Loyalität und Empathie. Ich hab dann also nochmal nachgefragt. Gibt es neben diesen sozialen Dimensionen eine gesellschaftliche Diskussion? Also spielt jenseits des eigenen, sagen wir mal Wertschöpfungshorizontes, dass man natürlich Mitarbeiter, einen Chef braucht, einen Förderzusammenhang, irgendwer der einen arbeitsteilungsmäßig unterstützt und so. Gibt es darüber hinaus eine gesellschaftliche Komponente in diesem Buch? Nein, der Antwort lautet nein. Fokus liegt primär auf individuellem Erfolg, nicht auf gesellschaftlichen Wohlstand. Keine tiefergehende Analyse von systemischen Fragen oder sozialer Gerechtigkeit. Moralische Prinzipien werden hauptsächlich als Mittel zum persönlichen Erfolg dargestellt. Fazit, das Buch ist ein Produkt seiner Zeit, 1930er Jahre, mit starker Betonung des individuellen Aufstiegs. Das Buch vereint individuelle Eigenverantwortung mit particularistischen sozialen Strategien, bietet jedoch keine umfassende gesellschaftliche Vision. Es lehrt, dass Erfolg durch eine Kombination aus persönlicher Initiative und strategischer Zusammenarbeit erreicht wird. Was für mich bedeutet. Es gibt eine Dimension. Auf der einen Seite steht Gesellschaftstheorie und auf der anderen Seite steht sowas. Das ist eine Dimension, ganz wichtig, aber ganz unterschiedliche Ausprägung. Und irgendwann kann man sich auch, auch wenn man ein Buch besonders mag, mal mit einem anderen Buch befassen. Aber das scheint hier gar nicht stattgefunden zu haben. Also das hört man ja auch in dem Podcast, in den Gesprächen, die da stattfinden.
Es gibt nur, es gibt nur Individuen. Jeder boxt sich durch und die, die am hartnäckigsten sind, die schaffen es dann nach oben. Ich frage mich nur, wenn man da der klügste und stärkste sein muss, warum ist man dann so schlicht, dass man solche Ratschläge braucht? Denn all diese Ratschläge, die du davor liest, sind ja so simpel, dass sie sofort, wenn man nicht völlig verrückt ist oder nicht auf der Baumschule gewesen ist, einem auch selbst in den Sinn kommen. Dass ein gewisses Durchsetzungsvermögen und ein Selbstbewusstsein sinnvoll ist, um beruflich erfolgreich zu sein. Wer dafür ein Buch lesen muss, der muss ja sehr an sich selbst zweifeln.
Also es ist ein Buch, anscheinend, ich habe es ja nicht gelesen, also die Kritik lasse ich mir gerne dann anhören, dass dir gar kein kontraintuitives Denken oder jenseits des Horizonts überhaupt eine Wahrnehmung gibt, sondern es baut einfach nur an deiner schon vorhandenen grundlegenden Intuition auf. Ja. So, also du verlässt einfach niemals eine Denkweise, die du nicht grundlegend in so, ich muss essen, also brauche ich essen, mehr essen ist besser. So, also du baust einfach nur ganz klein, du hast gar keinen emergenten Sprung irgendwo. Keine Perspektivübernahme, weil ein anderer Perspektive übernimmst und so findet gar nicht statt. Ich will es jetzt nicht übertreiben, aber wenn schon Milliardäre aus Gründen, die wir häufig befasst haben, keine soziale Dimension in ihrem Denken mehr drin haben, weil sie alles jenseits des Horizonts ihres eigenen Handlungsvermögens als zivilisatorische Verfügungsmasse sehen, wenn diese Art von Denken jetzt auch schon bei einfachen Millionären zugegen ist, dann bin ich kurz davor zu sagen, auch Millionäre abschaffen.
Ja, ich bin auch sehr dafür.
Da wir alle selber natürlich immer in der Handreichung einer, wir könnten auch mal Millionäre sein, nehme ich davon natürlich wieder ab, statt weil ich bin ja auch ein particularistisch egoistischer Mensch. Da ich aber links nie einen Milliardär, selbst wenn, würde ich so sagen, Verzicht sofort, wenn ich eine Milliarde habe, brauche ich nicht noch einen Euro weiter. Ist ja auch absurd eigentlich. Du hast eine Milliarde, aber der eine Euro darüber, der ist dir ganz wichtig dann plötzlich. Also ich bin kurz davor, Millionäre abzuschaffen, wenn ich sowas hier lese und höre.
Ich denke ja sehr stark an die Leute, die dem zuhören und jetzt sich fragen, ach ja, Durchsetzungsfähigkeit, Selbstbewusstsein. Warum bin ich denn, obwohl ich das alles habe, noch kein Millionär geworden? Denn man könnte natürlich auch die Geschichte von Unternehmern erzählen, die auch all diese Eigenschaften haben, die aber trotzdem pleite gegangen sind, weil die Umstände andere waren, weil externe Schocks kamen, weil die Situation so aussah, wie sie nun einmal aussah. Und dann bedeutet all dieses Geschwätz von dem Selbst, das genau weiß, wo es hinzugehen hat und alles tut, um den Erfolg zu bekommen, damit bedeuten diese Geschichten nichts mehr. Und es ist ja so lustig, dass bei Hoss und Hopf doch garantiert die meisten, die dazuhören, entweder Azubis sind oder Angestellte sind. Das heißt, dieser Unternehmergeist, der da so glorifiziert wird, den erleben sie doch nur, wenn sie nach oben blicken und Ansagen erwarten, die sie bekommen. Statt von dort ausgehend mal darüber nachzudenken, wie könnte man eigentlich das sozialverträglicher gestalten, sehnen sie sich nach einem Individualismus, von dem sie selbst überhaupt nicht partizipieren.
Eine spontane Pointe, weiß ihr an mir selbst, Merkel und du hast jetzt beschrieben, die jungen Leute und da hören ja viele jungen Leute zu. Wir sollten vielleicht nicht allzu sehr eine Gefahr sehen, beim Hoss und Hopf hören, denn die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist hoch, dass wenn man mit 20 Jahren Hoss und Hopf hört und glaubt, was sie sagen und dann stellt man aber weitere 20 Jahre fest, es sind falsche Versprechen, dann ist man mit 40 ein radikaler Sozialist. Es kann sich also ergeben, dass dieser Spruch mit 20 war er links und dann ist er immer konservativer geworden und irgendwann hat er als Innenminister den und so weiter Polizeihelm aufgesetzt für die Fotoshow. Die Otto Schielig-Story. Es kann durchaus sein, dass es auch andersrum geht. Dass man durch eine Desillusionierung mit dem größten Scheiß, den es überhaupt publizistisch gerade gibt und das ist zum Beispiel Hoss und Hopf, dass es einen Erweckungsmoment danach gibt und man sich denkt, Mist.
Falsch abgebogen.
Genau. Ich bin falsch abgebogen, ich versuch's nochmal links. Und ich empfehle sehr, wir kommen natürlich auf die Männer Podcasts zu sprechen in der KS dann. Aber jetzt gerade Robin Alexander zu folgen, ist wirklich eine Freude. Denn bei dem Umschwung, den die CDU gerade macht mit der Wählerverarsche und auch mit der Selbstverleugnung von wir brauchen kein Geld, keine Verschuldung und dann plötzlich doch 500 Milliarden. Selbst jemand wie Robin Alexander ist gerade ein sehr vernünftiger Typ, der sehr viele richtige Sachen in seinem Podcast sagt, wir haben es ja auch schon gehört. Weil irgendwann wird die Irrationalität und die Bizarriertät von dessen, womit man sich die ganze Zeit befasst, nicht mehr haltbar. Und dann, ich will jetzt nicht hoffen, also ich will es hoffen, aber ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen, dass Hoss und Hopf selbst diesen Moment haben. Aber bei dem Publikum bin ich doch hohen Mutes, weil ich einfach glaube, die jungen Leute sind klüger. Die sind klüger als das Angebot, das sie bekommen.
Für Dest Digital schreibt Serena Smith über einen neuen Partnerring. Und zwar nimmt sie erst Bezug auf den Begriff Surveillance.
Überwachung, Surveillance, Beobachtung. Su.
Also nicht Surveillance, sondern Surveillance.
So wie Surdakten, nee.
Und zwar das Unter, also das Druntergehen. Das ist ein Begriff, der schon 2006 wohl geprägt wurde. Und da geht es eben darum, dass nicht der Staat von oben, also Surveillance, also von oben draufblickt, sondern das ist so von unten. Die Bürger überwachen sich selbst. Unterwachung.
Ja, sehr gut. Das ist halt der Grundbegriff.
Das ist etwas, was sie jetzt als erstes mal hier aufruft, um über ein neues Produkt zu sprechen, nämlich den Raw Ring. R-A-W geschrieben. Das ist ein neues Variable. Und angeboten wird dieses von der Dating-App Raw und Queen's Tech. Was kann nun dieser Ring? Sie kaufen ein paar Ringe, einen für sich und einen für ihren Partner. Der Ring kann ihren Herzschlag mithilfe von Biosensoren, die ihre Vitalwerte messen, verfolgen. Stimmungsschwankungen mithilfe einer emotionalen KI, die ihren Zustand liest, erkennen. Und ihre Stimmung und Energie in Echtzeit mit der ihres Partners synchronisieren. Sie und ihr Partner können auf die Daten des jeweils anderen zugreifen, um auf eine Weise in Verbindung zu bleiben, so verspricht dann die Werbung für diesen Ring, die über Worte hinausgeht. Weiter heißt es dann auf der Website, halten sie und ihr Partner ihre Herzen im Gleichklang. Die Ehe entwickelt sich weiter. Das gleiche gilt für die Treue. Heilige Gelübde werden digital. Die Mission von Raw, wahre Liebe nachverfolgbar machen.
Wie genau?
Ja, das ist die Dystopie. Das heißt, du kannst auf dem Ring dann sehen, wie die andere Person sich fühlt. Serena Smith.
Also wie der Pulsschlag ist.
Ja, nicht nur das, sondern auch Stimmungen sollen damit abgebildet werden. Serena Smith schreibt, was eigentlich Vertrauen ausmacht ist, zu akzeptieren, dass man die Gedanken des Partners nie lesen kann und trotzdem entscheidet man sich ja zu vertrauen. So funktioniert der generelle Vertrauen.
Oder gerade deswegen, weil es immer noch was zu besprechen gibt.
Ja, weil auch noch das Geheimnis da ist und so etwas. Jetzt schreibt sie, nehmen wir an, ihre Stimmung hebt sich mitten am Tag, weil sie zum Beispiel einen süßen Hund gesehen haben. Aber was ist, wenn ihr paranoider Partner mit diesem Ring dann da abfinger, sagt, hm, da ist die Stimmung so gestiegen am Nachmittag, was war denn da los? Ist da vielleicht ein heimlicher Geliebter, auf den sie gewartet hat und der nun kam, als sie im Park war?
Oder wurde sie gerade vom Auto angefahren?
Also das heißt, es ist ein Ring, der nicht alles irgendwie toll nur abstimmt, sondern ein permanentes Misstrauen produziert. Sie zitierte noch eine Studie, die ergab, dass die Angst, etwas zu verpassen, ja eine der Hauptursachen für die Smartphonesucht ist, da die Menschen zwanghaft dann auf ihr Handy blicken und wissen wollen, was machen eigentlich die Artgenossen gerade, ja was machen meine Freunde, was macht die Familie. Und dieser Ring intensiviert das natürlich nochmal und soll dann so eine Treue herstellen, bedeutet aber genau nicht mehr Treue im Sinne von Vertrauen, sondern bedeutet wirklich eine permanente Überwachung oder Unterwachung, ist dann da das richtige Wort und dass das jetzt von einer Dating-App verkauft wird und es wohl schon mehrere solche Variables gibt, mit denen Partner sich gegenseitig tracken können und all das, ist natürlich sehr besorgniserregend. Ich glaube jetzt noch nicht, dass wir es hier mit einem großen Trend zu tun haben, aber dass überhaupt so etwas produziert wird und auf eine gewisse Nachfrage trifft, ist ja schon verrückt genug.
Ich will das mal kurz diskutieren, denn das ist eine wirklich sehr interessante Fragestellung, auch für die Frage, welche Funktion hat eigentlich Familie? Ja. Denn das beginnt ja immer mit einem Excitement. Jemand hat eine Vorfreude jemanden zu sehen. Du hast ja eben schon beschrieben, jemand ist excited, obwohl ich gar nicht in seiner Nähe bin. Weshalb ist er denn plötzlich excited? Warum ist er so aufgewühlt, erregt, keine Ahnung wie sich das dann... Wahrscheinlich echt einfach Pulsschläge. So, aber gut. Wir brauchen auch Rückzugsräume, in denen es geruhsam zugeht. Wir können uns aber nicht ganz vorstellen, dass ein Dating darüber läuft zu sagen, du siehst voll gut aus, aber besonders gut finde ich, dass bei dir einfach nichts los ist. Dass ich weiß, wenn ich zu dir nach Hause komme, du siehst ein ganz großes Sofa. Also keine große Aufregung. Das sind mir zu viele Urlaubsbilder gewesen auf Tinder. Ich mag es lieber, bist du auch mal zu Hause, geht es bei dir auch mal geruhsam zu oder ist bei dir immer nur Action? Und dass man dann so feststellt, ach so, das Verkaufsargument meiner selbst ist die Geruhsamkeit. Hier kommt man nach Hause, hier ist Ruhe, hier ist der Drubel vorbei und so weiter und so fort. Und dem widerspricht dieser Ring nun komplett. Aber ich glaube eigentlich wollen das die Leute. Das Leben ist aufregend genug. Also gerade ich kann es jetzt so für mein Leben, sehr viele in meiner Schicksalsgemeinschaft, die sagen einfach, das Leben ist voll. Drei Kinder, mehrere Haushalte, dann noch pendelt man irgendwie hin und her, dann geht es Fahrrad kaputt, keine Ahnung und so weiter. Braucht man jetzt noch Excitement? Also sollte man sich noch darüber aufregen, dass jemand andere eine Aufregung hat, woanders. Also das bringt ja alles nur in Turbulenzen. Nennen Sie sich, das ist wirklich interessant, denn es scheint mir hier wieder mal ein Vorzeichen falsch gesetzt worden zu sein. Gut, hier werden auch Vorzeichen umgedreht. Mein letzter Text. The Rise of the Brutal American. Der brutale Amerikaner. Es ist Anne Applebaum und sie schreibt für The Atlantic. Wir haben alle die Vorstellungen im Oval Office gesehen. Das sagt natürlich einiges über Amerika, aber was genau? Müssen wir uns hier an ein neues Stereotyp gewöhnen, nämlich den brutalen Amerikaner zu sehen, statt nur von ihm zu hören. Hollywood, der Bösewicht, zum Glück hat das Gute gesiegt. Puh, jetzt erstmal den Film ausmachen. Was sagt eigentlich der Präsident? Sonntagsrede so, ja. Dabei wissen wir, nee, die Rede ist nicht die Realität, sondern Hollywood ist die Realität. Jetzt haben wir Trump und Vance im Oval Office gesehen. Die, und das ist ja, ich lege den Fokus jetzt vermehrt darauf, gerade in diesen Fällen, wir haben ja eine Interaktion gesehen. Interaktionen haben ein Eigenrecht, da ist alles ein bisschen ausgeblendet. Die Apparate sind riesig, der Krieg ist bedeutsam und so weiter und so fort. Aber in dem Falle, da sind Menschen in einem Gespräch. Und das muss man erstmal so ernst nehmen. Und wenn man dann sieht, dass sie in diesem Gespräch unhöflich sind, bedeutet das etwas. Diese Unhöflichkeit hat einen Eigenwert und sie hat Aussagekraft. Es ist also nicht mehr Ronald Reagan, der als Cowboy mit weißem Hut eine Fernsehshow macht, sondern die andere Seite. Trump und Vance sind jetzt Mafia-Bosse aus denselben Film. 2016 war das alles noch bedrohlich, was man sah, aber 2025 nun ist es gefährlich. Und im Finale schreibt sie, im Oval Office verhielten sich Trump und Vance wie imperiale Herrscher, die eine unterworfene Kolonie zurechtweisen und artikulierten den gleichen Ekel und die gleiche Verachtung, die russische Propagandisten verwenden, wenn sie über die Ukraine sprechen. Europäer wissen, jeder weiß, dass wenn Trump und Vance so mit dem Präsidenten der Ukraine sprechen können, dann könnten sie schließlich auch so mit dem Führer ihres Landes sprechen. Also Merz zum Beispiel.
Ja.
Die Frage ist jetzt, können wir uns als politisches Publikum darauf einstellen? Also wie schicken wir eigentlich geistig Merz nach Amerika? Wenn es jetzt heißt, er ist vereidigt, Staatsbesuch Amerika. Was erwarten wir eigentlich, wenn wir das sehen? Wollen wir so gedemütigt werden in einer Interaktion stellvertretend wie Zelensky und das ukrainische Volk?
Komm, gib zu, man wird es schon Merz mal gönnen, dass er da so richtig vorgeführt hat.
Ja.
Es ist nur blöd, dass das dann auf uns zurückfällt.
Genau. Also es findet etwas auf offener Bühne statt, was da nicht hingehört, zumindest in der bisherigen Sehgewohnheit. Ich finde diese Verquickung, es ist keine Gleichsetzung, es ist kein intensives Ins-Verhältnis-Setzen, aber eine Verquickung aus groß und klein, Interaktion und ganze Gesellschaft, ganze Welt eigentlich, die ist gerade wahnsinnig interessant. Denn dieses Bild des Fürstenhofes, bei dem die Interaktion einfach gelingen muss und wenn die beiden Fürsten da sitzen und miteinander reden und dann stellen die Frauen fest, oh, das ist aber kurz vorm Streit, dann geht durch ein Wunder eine Tür auf und ein Kind kommt herein und das sieht ganz putzig aus und dann sind sie abgelenkt und können sich erstmal mit dem Kind befassen, sich ein bisschen entspannen. Ja und danach geht die Interaktion halt weiter in der Hoffnung, dass es gut ausgeht und alles was weiter staatspolitisch geklärt werden muss, wird über die Anwahnung einer Hochzeit organisiert und so weiter und so fort. So und ich werbe umso mehr dafür, dass wir jetzt diese Idee der Gutenberg-Paranthese wieder ganz ernst nehmen, denn diese Zeit der, aber wir haben doch eine Verfassung und wir haben doch einen Vertrag und wir haben doch eine Beschlussvorlage, ja ja das sind irgendwelche Dokumente. Jetzt geht es wieder um die Person, nicht um das Papier. Wir kommen jetzt wieder in dieses Zeitalter. Ja also wir haben dafür keine Sehgewohnheit, es ist völlig absurd eigentlich, aber wie ein Staatsbesuch von März bei Trump verläuft, da können 100 Diplomaten vorher irgendwelche Vorbereitungen machen, die Tür geht auf, sie geben sich die Hand, gelingen die ersten 10 Sekunden, ja oder nein, das entscheidet das Schicksal der Welt.
Wenn Trump die Krawatte nicht gefällt.
Genau, also in der Ansicht, das ist alles sehr brenzlig und die Gutenberg-Paranthese, ich hab sie ja in Redaktionsschluss beschrieben, ich mach ja bald ein Hörbuch draus, da kann man es nachlesen. Und Jeff Jarvis hat ein Buch nur zur Gutenberg-Paranthese, da ist der Titel geschrieben, das kenn ich aber nicht. Aber das sind so diese Ideen, die sind eigentlich absurd, aber denen sollte man jetzt mal wieder nachgehen.
Zum Schluss noch ganz kurz, wir sind ja schon weit über der Zeit, ein Musiktipp und zwar, ich habe schon häufiger von ihr geschwärmt, die Geigerin Isabel Faust. Ist wirklich grandios, ja. Und man kann sie jetzt in einer Neueinspielung erleben. Harmonia Mundi hat die CD herausgebracht. Ich weiß, das ist natürlich auch alles auf den Streaming-Plattformen erhältlich. Und zwar hat sie mit dem bayerischen Rundfunk-Orchester, nein, mit dem Symphonie-Orchester des bayerischen Rundfunks, so heißt es, das Violinkonzert von Benjamin Britten eingespielt. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es das gibt. Benjamin Britten ist mir vor allem als Opern-Komponist bekannt. In Frankfurt hab ich auch schon hin und wieder was von ihm gehört, zum Beispiel Tod in Venedig. Er ist sicherlich einer der wichtigsten Opern-Komponisten des 20. Jahrhunderts überhaupt. Einer der wichtigsten Komponisten der neueren Musik. Er ist keiner, der ins Atonale gegangen ist. Er ist jemand, der ja vielleicht spät romantisch an manchen Stellen ist, dann neoklassisch. Es ist gar nicht so leicht diesen Benjamin Britten einzuordnen. Jedenfalls sind seine Opern sehr hörenswert, sollte man unbedingt, wenn man wo die Gelegenheit hat, sich ansehen. Er hat aber auch ein Violinkonzert komponiert Ende der 30er, Anfang der 40er Jahre. Und dieses ist auch davon geprägt, dass wir sehr schöne, fast sanfte harmonische Bögen haben, die das Orchester spielt. Dazwischen geht aber dann die Geige. Die schwingt nicht auf diesen Wogen dann immer nur, sondern sie setzt etwas dagegen. Sie ist oft schroff. Es gibt dann gerade im zweiten Satz ein Solo, das unglaublich energisch ist und hart ist und ja wirklich etwas sehr aufgerautes hat im Ton. Und dann aber setzen Posaunen ein. Wir gehen in den dritten Satz über. Es entsteht zwar ein kleiner Dialog zwischen Geige und Posaunen. Und dann wird das Orchester geradezu bombastisch. Wer da an Filmmusik oder so denkt, man kann das auch ruhig tun.
Gut, für mich.
Es ist natürlich mehr als Filmmusik. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall ein Werk, das es sich lohnt anzuhören. Und es ist von Isabel Faust wunderbar, wie ich finde, eingespielt. Auf der CD außerdem sind noch weitere Werke, Kammermusikalische dann, für die Geige zum Beispiel. Auch ein Werk, das Benjamin Britten im Alter von 16 Jahren komponiert hat. Auch das sehr hörenswert. Und vielleicht bekommt man dann auch Lust, die eine oder andere Oper mal zu erleben. Jedenfalls ist das mein Musiktipp, das Violinkonzert von Benjamin Britten eingespielt, von Isabel Faust und dem Symphonieorchester des Bayerischen Rundfunks.
Ja, sehr gut. Du weißt ja, ich bin Banause. Also ich folge deiner Musikempfehlung und höre die dann auf Kopfhörer im Fahrtwind auf dem Fahrrad. Was bei Vivaldi dazu führte, dass ich natürlich genau hingehört habe. Und mich würde auch interessieren, wie die Hörer das finden. Aber wenn die Musik, und du hast uns ja beschrieben, da wurden extra alte Instrumente und so weiter, also dass da so ein bisschen Leben reingeholt wurde. Nur wir kennen das, Dirigenten dirigieren nicht nur optisch, sondern auch mit einem Schniefen.
Ja, sie atmen so ein.
Ja. Und ich war überrascht, dass doch bei jeder Zeile der Partitur einmal eingeatmet wird. Also quasi alle zehn Sekunden.
Wirklich? Hast du das so?
Ja, was...
Überdeutlich da gehört auf deinem Kopf.
Ich fand's wirklich sehr störend, muss ich sagen. Also die Musik wirklich sehr gut und du hast es ja auch beschrieben und genauso, man hört das auch. Also man kennt die Musik, aber man hört, das ist ein bisschen anders so. Aber das hat mich gestört. Okay.
Also hier...
Also war zu nah sozusagen am Lebendigen.
Ich hab jetzt nicht so drauf geachtet, würde aber mal behaupten, dass jetzt bei dieser Einspielung von Isabel Faust nicht heftig eingeatmet wird.
Wenn es ein ganzes Orchester ist, ist es anders mikrofoniert. In dem Falle waren es ja kleine...
Es ist ein kleineres Ensemble gewesen, es kann sein, dass die da anders mikrofoniert werden.
Man hat ja auch die Hände voll zum Dirigieren, man hat ja eine Geige entpackt.
Aber generell neigen auch Streichquartette zum Beispiel dazu, wenn sie ansetzen zu machen. Also das ist schon etwas, was da ist.
Wir hören das auch in der Oper.
Jaja. Manche Dirigenten sind da sehr laut. Jaja, das ist auf jeden Fall so. Also hier kann ich eine Warnung geben, das ist glaube ich bei Benjamin Britten nicht der Fall. Ich empfehle das sehr und ich glaube es wird auch keine störenden Ausatmer oder Einatmer geben.
Sehr gut. Aber ich folge allen Empfehlungen und höre die natürlich dann auch auf den Streaming-Plattformen.
Wir hören uns ja sowieso nochmal im Live-Salon in der KES. Für alle die da sind, wir stehen natürlich davor und danach bereit für Frage und Antwort oder signieren auch Bücher. Wir verkaufen aber vor Ort keine Bücher. Und alle anderen können es dann gleich am nächsten Tag hören.
Genau. Gerne Smalltalk, aber ihr könnt uns auch eure Dissertation mitbringen.
Bis dann.